EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND THE
SUBJECT IS AN UPDATE REVIEW AN
EXAMINATION OF CALIBRATE
COLLEGE OUR- RELATIVELY NEW
ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
JUST TO OPEN IT UP- I KNOW ALL
OF YOU WHO WERE HERE NO BUT-
WITH THE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT WE
LAUNCHED- ABOUT A ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
EFFORT SOMEONE TIME SOMEONE
GOING AT THE TIME. TO ESTABLISH
A NEW SEPARATE ONLINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WITH THE NEW PRESIDENT
TO NEW ADMINISTRATIVE TEAM.
CREATING A NEW ONLINE
CURRICULUM TO SERVICE A LARGE
GROUP OF WORKERS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AT THE TIME.
DESCRIBED AS STRANDED. SINCE WE
ARE NOW BEGINNING THE SECOND
YEAR OF THIS IMPLEMENTATION AND
EXECUTION PROCESS- AND SINCE
THE TWO OF US WERE NOT IN THESE
CHAIRS. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AT THE TIME THAT THIS
ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CONCEPT WAS HATCHED. IN THE
SHIP WAS LAUNCHED. WE THOUGHT
WE'D TAKEN OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPLORE THE FOUNDATION FOR THE
ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CONCEPT AS WELL AS THE STATUS
OF THE ROLL OUT- AND
IMPLEMENTATION TO DATE. SO WITH
THAT LET ME TURN IT OVER- TO MY
SENATE EDUCATION CHAIRS SENATOR
CONNIE LEIVA FOR ANY STATEMENTS
THAT SHE MY WHICH TO MAKE AT
THIS POINT. THANK YOU SENATOR
ROTH GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I AM
EXCITED THAT YOU'RE ALL HERE
AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM
REPRESENTATIVES FROM CALIBRATE
REGARDING THE STATUS OF THE
STATE'S ONLINE COLLEGE. AND
PROGRESS TOWARDS MEETING THE
STATUTORY DEADLINES THAT WERE
GIVEN TO THE COLLEGE WHEN IT
WAS ENACTED. HAVING FLEXIBLE
AND AFFORDABLE EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES THAT CATER TO THE
NEEDS O WORKING LEARNERS IS
CRITICAL FOR OUR EDUCATION.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY VALUABLE
WHEN IT COMES TO COURSE
SCHEDULING AND TESTING SUPPORTS
DURING NONTRADITIONAL HOURS.
THAT IS WHY IT'S IMPORTANT THE
LEGISLATURE CONTINUE TO MONITOR
IMPLEMENTATION. THE CAL I
PROPER MODEL TO HEARINGS THIS.
THAT SAYS I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE HE
HAVE A- WE GOT. A TRAJECTORY
AND I'M OF THE SEA THOSE PRESS.
THIS MONTH GIVEN THE RECENT
MOVEMENT AND THE IMPORTANCE OF.
THE EDGE MODEL. I AM FOR IN TO
HEAR WE ARE NOW WHERE WE NEED
BEAT BEST SIR TO AND WHAT STEPS
SHOULD BE TAKEN TO ENSURETHAT
CAL BRIGHT. CONTINUES TO MEET
ITS DIRECTIVE I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE DISCUSSION TODAY AND THANK
EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE. BEFORE
WE START WITH OUR- OVERVIEW OF-
CALIBRATE COLLEGE HAVE BEEN
JOINED BY SEVERAL OF MY
COLLEAGUES IMAGES TO. PASS THEM
AT FIVE IF ANY OF THEM WANT TO
MAKE A ANY BRIEF COMMENTS
BEFORE WE START. SEEING NONE WE
WILL GO RIGHT INTO THE OVERVIEW
OF CALIBRATE COLLEGE AND IDEAS
TO REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE TO
JOIN US. FOR THAT OVERVIEW. SIR
WHEN YOU COMFORTABLE PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD. THANK YOU POLICY IN
HOUSE IN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. OF USER OF
NICE TO BE HERE THANK YOU. SO
THE SERGEANT IS DISTRIBUTING A
HAND OUT IN THE HANDOUT
CONSISTS OF TWO MAIN PARTS
FIRST TO PROVIDE CONTEXT FOR
CALIBRATE THEY HAND OT BEGINS
WITH A BACKGROUND. OF ONLINE
INSTRUCTION AND INITIATIVES IN
THE CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
COLLEGE SYSTEM. THEY HAD OUT
THEN TURNS TO WHAT.
SPECIFICALLY THE LEGISLATURE
WANTS HAS ASKED CAL RIGHT TO DO
HOW MUCH FUNDING IS PROVIDED
FOR CALIBRATE AND THEN I DO
HAVE THAT IDENTIFIES MAJOR
MILESTONES THAT CAL RIGHT MUST
MEET OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS. SO IF YOU START ON PAGE
ONE OF THE HAND OUT. ALL ONE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN LOCALLY
RUN COMMUNITY COLLEGES OFFER
ONLINE COURSES. ONLINE COURSES
REPRESENT ABOUT 17% OF OVERALL
INSTRUCTION AMONG THE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN COLLEGES IT'D HAVE
BEEN OFFERING ONLINE
INSTRUCTION WHICH IS UP FROM 7%
A DECADE AGO. THAT THESE
HUNDRED FOURTEEN COLLEGES YOU
MAINLY SEE ONLINE INSTRUCTION
IN CREDIT COURSES SEARCHES
PSYCHOLOGY OR HISTORY OR
ENGLISH COURSES THAT ARE
TRANSFERABLE TO A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY ARE YOU ALSO FIND-
ONLINE INSTRUCTION SOME CREEK
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
AND THE HAND OUT NOTES SO
WEBSITE DESIGN AS AN EXAMPLE.
STUDENTS TAKING ONLINE CLASSES
CLASSES OFTEN TYPICALLY TAKE
FACE TO FACE CLASSES AS WELL A
COLLEGES WILL TELL YOU THAT
ONLINE COURSES ARE AMONG THE
VERY FIRST TO FILL UP OTHER
POPULAR IN GENERAL WITH
STUDENTS- BECAUSE STUDENTS. WE
HEAR OF FIND IT BENEFICIAL TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE A CLASS WHERE
THEY ARE WHEN THEY ARE ABLE TO-
AND LEARN AND PROGRESS. ONLINE
COURSES TYPICALLY FALL OF THE
SAME- SEMESTER CALENDAR THAT
SIXTEEN TO SEVENTEEN WEEKS
SEMESTER CALENDAR THAT REGULAR
FACE TO FACE CLASSES FOLLOW.
OUR ONLINE INSTRUCTION
GENERATES FOR COLLEGE IS THE
SAME FUNDING RATE THE SINGAPORE
SENATE RATE FROM- THE STATE AS
REGULAR FACE TO FACE CLASSES
AND ON STUDENTS TAKING ONLINE
ONLINE CLASSES PAY THE SAME
FEES STATUTORILY SET FEES OF
REGULAR FACE TO FACE CLASSES
THEY ALSO ON MY STUDENTS
QUALIFY FOR. FEE WAIVER THERE
FINANCIALLY NEEDY. AND THERE IS
NO CHARGE FOR NON CREDIT ADULT
EDUCATION COURSES OFFERED
THROUGH THE COMMUNICATOR AGES
AND THAT'S A PURSUANT TO STATE
LAW. PAGE TWO DESCRIBES A
COUPLE OF THE ONLINE
INITIATIVES FUNDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. MOST NOTABLY THE
STATE PROVIDES TWENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING TO
ENCOURAGE COLLABORATION AND
ECONOMIES OF SCALE BY COLLEGES
THROUGH THE ONLINE EDUCATION
INITIATIVE AN ONLINE EDUCATION
INITIATIVE CONSISTS OF SEVERAL
COMPONENTS INCLUDING TRAININGS
FOR FACULTY IT'S STATEWIDE AND
LOCAL LEVEL. A LEARNING
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM SO THAT
FACULTY CAN DELIVER COURSES- IN
AN ONLINE FASHION. AND ALSO A
SYSTEM THAT ALLOW STUDENTS FROM
PARTICIPATING COLLEGES TO CROSS
AND ROLE IN OTHER COLLEGES
TAKING ONLINE CLASSES ACTUALLY
PAGE FIFTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA
GOES INTO MORE DETAIL ON THAT
ONLINE- LOOK OF COURSE EXCHANGE.
PAGE THREE OF THE HAND OUT
NOTES THAT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEMS ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEENTH COLLEGE WAS CREATED
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. AS CHAIR JUST NOTED.
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS WHICH
OVERSEES THE COMMITTEE BECAUSE
SYSTEM ALSO SERVES AS CAL
RIGHTS OWN BOARD IT'S KNOWN AS
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES. THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET PROVIDED ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME AND TO
THAT TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING FOR THE ONLINE COLLEGE
THE ONE TIME FUNDS WERE
INTENDED TO START UP COSTS
COVERING EXPENSES SUCH AS
TECHNOLOGY ACQUISITION. THE ON
FUNDS ARE FOR OPERATING COSTS
SEARCHES OF. WHICH IS
COMPENSATION FOR STAFF. IN
ADDITION THE COLLEGE IS
ELIGIBLE UNDER STATUTE TO CLAIM
APPORTIONMENT STICK CLAIM STATE
FUNDING FOR ANY ENROLLMENT SET
HAS WHICH IS THE SAME AS OTHER
COLLEGES. THE COLLEGE IS
DIRECTED TO FOCUS ON CREATING
SHORT TERM PATHWAYS FOR
STUDENTS THAT LEAD TO
EMPLOYMENT AND EARNINGS GAINS
AND CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE STUDENTS TO COMPLETE AND
CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION AT ONE
OF THE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND IT'S TO
FOCUS ON AND ROLLING WORKING
ADULTS WITH NO POST SECONDARY
CREDENTIALS WHO ARE NOT
CURRENTLY ACCESSING HIGHER
EDUCATION NOT MIGHT BE BECAUSE
OF TIME FINANCIAL CONSTRAINTS
RATHER REASONS. NOW THE
COLLEGES REQUIRED TO DEVELOP
THESE PROGRAMS IN COLLABORATION
WITH INDUSTRY. AND FOR EACH NEW
PROGRAM CREATED THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE MUST NOTIFY
YOU MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION-
ADMINISTRATION ON HOW THE
PROGRAM IS NOT DUPLICATIVE OF
PROGRAMS AND OTHER COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THE COLLEGE IS ALSO
TO PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS TO ACCELERATE THEIR
LEARNING ACCELERATE THE
COMPLETION OF A OF A PROGRAM
THROUGH PRIOR LEARNING
ASSESSMENT SIR OTHER WAYS THAT
STUDENTS CAN SHOW WHAT THEY
KNOW. AND THEREBY ADVANCE
THROUGH THE PROGRAM. PAGE FOUR
OF THE HAND OUT NOTES ACCOUNT
RIGHT GENERALLY MUST FOLLOW THE
SAME RULES AS OTHER COLLEGES.
THERE ISN'T- THERE ARE SOME
EXCEPTIONS FOR EXAMPLE THE HAND
OUT NOTES- THAT THE COLLEGE
EXEMPT FROM USING THE REGULAR
STUDENT FEE STRUCTURE WHICH I
DESCRIBED EARLIER. FINALLY PAGE
FIVE OF THE HAND OUT LISTS THE
MAJOR STATUTORY MILESTONES THAT
CAL BRIGHT MUST MEET. IN
PARTICULAR CALIBRATE MUST START
BY CREATING AT LEAST THREE
PROGRAMS. AND TO HAVE BEEN
ROLLED THE FIRST STUDENTS BY
THE LAST PART OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN CALIBRATE IN ADDITION
MUST DEVELOP A TOTAL OF SIXTEEN
PROGRAMS BY MID. TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THREE. AND PROVIDE
REGULAR UPDATES TO LEGISLATURE
IN IN WRITTEN FORM AS WELL AS
OF COURSE- APPEAR IN A AND
HEARINGS THAT YOU CALL. CAL
RIGHT ALSO MOST AVAILABLE PLAN
FOR. OBTAINING ACCREDITATION
AND ACTUALLY OBTAIN OCCUR
ACCREDITATION BY. TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY FIVE. SO WITH THAT ALL
AND MY REMARKS IN HAPPENED IN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE CALLINGS ANY QUESTIONS
FIRST LET ME TURN TO MY SENATE
EDUCATION CHAIR CENTER LIVE A-
GOOD RIGHT NOW THANK YOU ALEX
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE LA
DOCTRINE. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OVERVIEW AND PRESENTATION- IS
TALKING ABOUT- MILESTONES I'M
SURE WE WILL BE HERE AT WE ARE
GONNA BE HERE A STATUS REPORT
FROM THE- COLLEGE SELF BUT FROM
THE ALEJO'S PERSPECTIVE- WHERE.
YOU KNOW IT'S WELL IT'S A
TWENTY TWENTY SO YES THEY'RE
STILL MANY MILESTONES AGO- IN
YOUR X. EXAMINATION- HOW ON
TRACTOR BEHIND TRACK ARE THEY-
WELL YOU'LL HEAR- THE NEXT
PANEL ABOUT THE PROGRAMS THAT
WERE CREATED SO FREE UP
PROGRAMS. WERE CREATED- HELP
RIGHT HAS STARTED TO ENROLL
STUDENTS- INITIALLY AND A- A
COURSE REALLY DESIGNED TO SEE
F THIS IS THE RIGHT FIT FOR
THE STUDENTS SO THEY HAVE
SEVERAL HUNDRED THERE. AND THEY
HAVE THE ABOUT TWENTY ACTUALLY
ROLLED IN THE THREE PROGRAMS I
MENTIONED- THEY HAVE PROVIDED A
STATUS REPORT THAT IS IN YOUR
YOUR PACKET THERE- FAIRLY
FAIRLY COMPREHENSIVE
INFORMATION- SO. I THINK YOU
KNOW THEY- HIGHER THEIR THEIR
CO NOW. CO HE'S LEAVING ABOUT A
YEAR AGO SO. DEFINITELY THEY'VE
BEEN EASY- AND- ACCOMPLISH SOME
OF THESE GOALS AND- WE'LL HAVE
TO SEE FROM YOU KNOW THE NEXT
PANEL ABOUT THEIR FUTURE PLANS
TO CONTINUE THAT TRAJECTORY.
AND SO WHAT IS THE- LA- DOING
TO MONITOR THE PROGRESS AND
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE REPORT YOU
BEING HERE SIDES THEY'D SO I
KNOW TO WHAT DEGREE IS THE LA
JOH MAYER'S. CAL BRIGHT SO WE
AND GONNA HEAR AN UPDATE FROM
THE ACTUAL. FOLKS WHO ARE DOING
IT- BUT I JUST WANT YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE SORT OF OUR-
YOU WORK FOR US SO I WANTED TO
DIAL IN TO HEAR FROM YOU WHAT-
IT WHAT IS LA WILL. BUT LA AS
PLANTS IN TERMS OF MONITORING
CALIBRATE YEAH THAT'S- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT. YOU'D
LEGISLATURE'S GIVEN CAL RIGHT A
LOT OF MONEY. YES HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. A ONE TIME IN
AND TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
ANNUALLY IN ONGOING. IN
ADDITION TO GIVING CAL RIGHT
THE OPPORTUNITY TO. OUR CLAIM
STATE FUNDING FOR ENROLLMENT.
SO THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT.
INITIATIVE TO FOLLOW AND TO
OVERSEE IT'S SOMETHING. WE PLAN
TO CONTINUE WE'VE WRITTEN ABOUT
IT BEFORE WE'VE DONE ANALYSES
ON IT ALREADY WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE WAS CONSIDERING.
THE WEATHER TO FIND THIS IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
FOLLOW AND PROVIDE YOU WITH
UPDATES WE OFTEN INCLUDE
UPDATES IN OUR- FORMAL BUDGET
ANALYSES WHEN THEY'RE PROPOSALS
WE ALSO PROVIDE. WED POSTS AND
OTHER UPDATES- TO LET YOU KNOW-
WHAT ARE THE DEVELOPMENTS IN IF
WE SEE SOMETHING THAT SAYS. IT
NEEDS TO BE TAKEN A CLOSE LOOK
AT OKAY WELL I GUESS I'D SAY IS
AS YOU'RE MONITORING THIS
PROGRAM- I URGE YOU TO. LOOK AT
FROM THIS FRAME ALL RIGHT- I
MEAN WE COULD OF COURSE IS THE
LEGISLATURE WE CAN DECIDE HOW
MUCH MONEY WE GIVE TO THIS AND
OTHER PROGRAMS. BUT AND I'D
CERTAINLY I THINK THE FUNDING
THAT. WE PROVIDED FOR EDUCATION
IS WORTHY. THE QUESTION IS THIS
IS THE RIGHT WAY TO SPEND THE
HUNDRED MILLION PLUS THE TWENTY
MILLION EVERY YEAR SO AS YOU'RE
LOOKING AT IS THE LA I WAS
LOOKING AT THIS- I THINK WHEN
THE FRAME TO LOOK AT IT IS TO
SAY. IS THIS THE BEST WAY TO
SPEND THE MONEY. THE AT AND TO
DRAW A COMPARISON BETWEEN WHAT
WE'RE GETTING FOR THE
INVESTMENT WILL PUT IN HERE AND
WHAT WHAT. WHAT WE HAVE GOTTEN
AND I KNOW IT'S A LITTLE HARD
TO ALWAYS FIGURE THAT OUT IF WE
HAD DECIDED TO PUT THE MONEY IN
OUR EXISTING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM DERRY HAS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ALL SET UP. THAT
RATE HAS IT CETERA AND YEP
BECAUSE WE USE YOU MENTIONED-
THERE 17% READY ONLINE IN OUR
EXISTING COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO
THEY'RE DOING STUFF. SO THE
QUESTION IS IT MAKES SENSE TO.
BUT ALL THE OVERHEAD AND IT
CETERA FOR THIS AS WE PREPARE
FOR FIGHTING A UNIQUE PRODUCT
THAT COULDN'T BE OBTAINED. BY
OR- WE TOOK THE SAME ABOUT
MONEY AND GAVE IT TO THE
EXISTING COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
TODAY DO THE SAME OR EVEN MORE.
I MEAN THAT'S A TRUE COMPARISON
RIGHT IS THIS THE WISEST WAY TO
SPEND THE MONEY ARE YOU GETTING
THE BIGGEST RETURN FOR
INVESTMENT- SO. SO I HOPE THAT
AS THE ELLIE I WAS MONITORING
THIS IS NOT MERELY LIKE DID YOU
HIT THE STATUTORY DEADLINES.
BUT IS THIS THE BEST WAY WE
COULD SPEND OUR MONEY- IN TERMS
OF. EDUCATION FOR AND HE CALLED
SYSTEM YES NIGHT. WE WOULD
AGREE- AND I WOULD KIND OF ADD
TO THAT- WE HAS A- LOT OF.
ONLINE INITIATIVES GOING ON IN
THE STATE YOU HAVE THE HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN COLLEGES AND YOU
HAVE CAL PRIDE WE HAD ONLINE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE. WHICH YOU
ALSO FIND. IN CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION LEARNING LAB. WHICH
IS ALSO IN THE HAND OUT THAT'S
TEN MILLION DOLLARS
ADDITIONALLY SO. TO WHAT EXTENT
IS IT COMING TOGETHER INTO
SOMETHING THAT'S COHERENT AN
INTEGRATED AND WORKING TOWARD
THE SAME PURPOSE AS OPPOSED TO.
DUPLICATION TO BEAM DUPLICATIVE
AND- AND NOT NECESSARILY
PROVIDING A COHERENT EXPERIENCE
FOR STUDENTS WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH I LOOK FORWARD TO FUTURE
VALUATIONS IN THE LA- AND-
PLEASE LET US KNOW IF. YOU NEED
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE RESOURCES
OR ACCESS TO INFORMATION TO
MAKE THIS HAPPEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. CENTER ALSO YES
THANK YOU- IN YOUR IN YOUR-
PRESENTATION TO US THE ONE AREA
THAT I DON'T SEE. YOU YOU YOU
TELL US ABOUT THE FUNDING RIGHT
THAT'S A HUNDRED MILLION AND
TWENTY MILLION ON GOING. BUT I
DON'T SEE WHERE YOU MADE THIS
SORT OF AN ANALYSIS OF HOW MUCH
HAS BEEN SPENT UP UNTIL NOW AND
ANY OPINIONS THAT YOU HAVE
ABOUT. THE SPENDING THAT'S
ALREADY TAKEN PLACE AND HOW
MUCH IS LEFT AS IT MAKES SENSE
OR DOZEN THAT- SO COULD YOU.
YES THAT'S SOMETHING WE
COORDINATED WITH STAFF ON ABOUT.
WHAT WE SHOULD COVER VERSES
WHAT STAFF COVERS THE AGENDA IF
YOU LOOK ON AGE IS TWO AND
THREE OF THE GENDER THAT GOES
INTO DETAIL. OF A SPENDING YOU
CAN SEE ON MIDDLE OF PAGE TWO
ON THE FUNDING THAT I MENTIONED
AND THEN YOU'LL SEE AN UPDATE
ON CAL GRANT CAL RIGHT SPENDING.
ONE THING. TO THINK ABOUT.
OTHER THAN WHAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER ABOUT THE TWENTY
MILLION ONGOING IS AT TO WHAT
EXTENT IS THAT GOING TO BE
NEEDED REALLY ON AN ONGOING
BASIS GIVEN THAT CALIBRATE HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CLAIM
APPORTIONMENT SINCE I THINK
YOU'LL HEAR THEY HAVE OTHER
PLANS- IN TO BRING IN REVENUE
AS WELL SAID SOMETHING TO TAKE
A LOOK AT. THAT FUNDING AND
WHETHER IT'S IT REALLY IS
NEEDED AN ON GOING BASIS AS THE
COLLEGE CONTINUES TO EVOLVE.
THE OTHER IS TO JUST TAKE A
LOOK AT THE SPENDING- TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING REGULAR
UPDATES ON THE SPENDING.
SOMETHING THAT JUST JUMPED OUT
TO ME IS THE MONEY SPENT ON
CAPITAL OUTLAY FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN CAPITAL OUTLAY FOR
AN ONLINE COLLEGE I THINK WE
JUST WANT TO GET A BETTER IDEA
BETTER SENSE AND UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT THAT IS FOR WHAT THAT.
THAT MONEY IS REALLY NEEDED FOR.
THE LEVEL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
YOU MENTIONED ON PAGE ONE OF
YOUR HAND OUT AND YOU MENTIONED
IT ALSO- THAT 17% OF ALL
INSTRUCTION A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IT'S TO ONLINE IS IT
WORTH NOTING THAT ONLINE
COURSES ARE DIFFERENT THAN
COMPETENCY BASED ONLINE COURSES
WHICH CAL BRIGHT REPRESENTS I
THINK SOMETIMES WE COMPLETE THE
TO AND THAT THEY ARE DIFFERENT
AS- THE LA LOOK AT THAT. YEAH I
THINK THAT'S A THAT IS A GOOD
POINT- I DID MENTION THAT
ONLINE COURSES AT THE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN COLLEGES TYPICALLY ARE
ON A SEMESTER. OR YOU KNOW
QUARTER SYSTEM AT A FEW OF THE
COLLEGES. AND SO. STUDENTS ARE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY USUALLY
WITHIN A WEEK TO GET THERE TO
GET THEIR WORK IN LOG IN. DO
THAT WHATEVER ASSIGNMENT THEY
HAVE TO DO THEY MIGHT HAVE
UNTIL SAY MID NIGHT- ON SUNDAY
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO DO
IT- BUT GENERALLY EVEN IF THEY
KNOW THE MATERIAL THEY NEED TO
WAIT FOR THE NEXT WEEK. IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE THE STUDIES
WERE IS THROUGH COMPETENCY
BASED EDUCATION STUDENT HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE THROUGH
ACCELERATE THROUGH THAT
MATERIAL OR TAKE SOME EXTRA
TIME IF THEY NEED IT- SO THERE
IS THE SOME POTENTIAL ADVANTAGE
TO COPY COMPETENCY BASED
APPROACH. VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
WHAT TO. SET THE STAGE FOR
WHAT'S TO COME. IN THIS-
REVIEW. YOUR HANDLE REFERENCES
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS THAT'S F.
T. E. THAT'S NOT TH TOTAL
STUDENTS. ENROLLED IN ONLINE
COURSES CORRECT CORRECT THAT SO
IT'S MANY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS. OF HEAD COUNT IN
FACT OUR PREDECESSORS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN WHEN WE
WERE INITIALLY CONSIDERING THIS
PROPOSAL. WERE PROVIDED WITH
THE NET ANALYSIS THAT REFLECTS
THAT IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES OFFERED. FOURTEEN
THOUSAND NINETY TWO ONLINE
COURSES. AND FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY THREE ONLINE DEGREE
CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS IN THE-
CALIFORNIA VIRTUAL CAMPUS
CATALOG WITH ROUGHLY EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN ONLINE COURSES DOES
THAT SOUND ABOUT RIGHT YES IT'S
AN AND WE I BELIEVE WE WERE
ALSO TOLD AT ONE POINT. THE OF
THE OF THESE THERE WERE SEVENTY
THREE SHORT TERM FULLY ONLINE
CERTIFICATES OF ACHIEVEMENT
INCLUDED IN THAT PACKAGE IS
THAT ALSO SOUND ABOUT RIGHT.
YES OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY LET'S- LET'S INVITE OUR-
PANEL OF THE TIME IF STEEN AND
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY UP. MISTER
PRESIDENT I PLAN SURE NAME
CORRECTLY. EPSTEIN I APOLOGIZE
WELL DON'T BE I HATE TO
MISPRONOUNCE PEOPLE'S NAMES I
WON'T MAKE THAT MISTAKE AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE BOTH
OF YOU. MR. THANK YOU- IT'S-
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE
AGAIN- TO TALK ABOUT TO COVER A
COLLEGE WHO GETTING GOOD
MORNING CHAIR ROTH- CERTAINLY
CHAIR LEYVA WHEN SHE STEPS BACK
IN CENTERS PLATE SHOULD BE HERE
WITH YOU ALL- MY NAME'S YOU
ORTIZ OAKLEY AND HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF SERVING AS THE
CHANCE OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- YOUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- SO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY DISCUSS
THE PROGRESS OF OUR NEWEST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CALIBRATE
COLLEGE- LESSON TWO YEARS AGO
THE LEGISLATURE. TOOK A VERY
BOLD STEP. TO HELP WORKING
CALIFORNIANS AND I EMPHASIZE
AND I'M GONNA TALK A LOT ABOUT
WORKING CALIFORNIANS. IN MY
REMARKS THIS IS A POPULATION
THAT HAS NOT ALWAYS BEEN WELL
SERVED. BY TRADITIONAL HIGHER
EDUCATION MODELS OF POPULATION
THAT IS THE ON GOING TARGET. OF
FOR PROFITS AND NATIONAL
NONPROFIT MAKE A UNIVERSITIES
TO CONTINUE TO GROW IN
ENROLLMENT HERE IN OUR GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. A YOU
EXPANDED THE EXISTING HIGHER
EDUCATION INFRASTRUCTURE TO
CREATE A TECHNOLOGY DRIVEN
ONLINE COLLEGE INTENTIONALLY
FOCUSED. ON WORKING LEARNERS
THE MANDATE WAS TO ESTABLISH IN
VERY SHORT ORDER GRANTED WE'RE
LESS THAN TWO YEARS FROM THE
FIRST HEARING TODAY IN VERY
SHORT ORDER TO ESTABLISH A
COLLEGE- THAT IS AFFORDABLE AND
FLEXIBLE FOR THOSE CONSTRAINED
BY JOB AND FAMILY OBLIGATIONS A
COLLEGE IT IS FULLY COMPETENCY
BASED IN ALL SPEAK MORE ABOUT
THAT DISTINCTION- THE COLLEGE
IS FULLY COMPETENCY BASED AND
FOCUSED ON SKILL ACQUISITION.
AND JOB PLACEMENT THIS IS ABOUT
JOB PLACEMENT FOR SOME OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO
RECOGNIZING THE STUDENTS PRIOR
LEARNING HELPING THEM OBTAIN AN
EMPLOYER RECOGNIZED COLLEGE
CREDENTIALS LET ME TAKE A
MOMENT TO BETTER ARTICULATE
COME SEE BASED EDUCATION WHAT
DO WE MEAN BY C. B. E. KANSI
BASED EDUCATION IS AN OUTCOME
BASED APPROACH TO EARNING
CREDENTIALS. C. B. E. IS A
COMPREHENSIVE SYSTEM OF
INSTRUCTION ASSESSMENT
TRANSCRIPTION AND SUB AND IT
ALSO SUPPORTS COHESIVE DESIGNED
TO FACILITATE. INDIVIDUAL
STUDENT MASTERY. A STUDENTS
ACQUIRE AND DEMONSTRATE THEIR
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS BY
ENGAGING LEARNING EXPERIENCES
LEARNING EXERCISES ACTIVITIES
AND EXPERIENCES THAT ALIGN WITH
CLEARLY DEFINED PROGRAMMATIC
OUTCOMES. STUDENTS RECEIVE
PROACTIVE GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT
FROM FACULTY AND STAFF LEARNERS
ARE IN CREDENTIALS BY
DEMONSTRATING MASTERY AND I
EMPHASIZE THE WORD MASTERY
BECAUSE THIS IS A FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCE ON HOW WE TYPICALLY
PROVIDE INSTRUCTION IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
HERE INCOMES IT SAID YOU
CATIONS FOCUS ON WHAT THE
STUDENT MASTERS NOT HOW LONG
THE STUDENT IS IN THE CLASSROOM
THE- MASTERY TO MULTIPLE FORMS
OF ASSESSMENT OFTEN AT A
PERSONALIZED PACE AGAIN. IF YOU
THINK ABOUT TRADITIONAL
CLASSROOM. YOU WERE THERE FOR A
SEMESTER REGARDLESS HOW QUICKLY
OR NOT YOU GAIN MASTERY OF THE
SUBJECT MATTER. THE TIME BEGINS
AND ENDS AT A CERTAIN PERIOD IN
THIS COUNTRY ARTIST. AT THEIR
PACE SO YOU COULD HAVE. TEN
STUDENTS IN ONE CLASSROOM ALL
PROGRESSING AT DIFFERENT PACES
THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR WORKING
LEARNERS. BECAUSE HE BE IS
FOCUSED ON DEMONSTRATING SKILL
MASTERY IS AN OUTCOME RATHER
THAN STE A C. TIME PROXY. THE
LEARNING MODEL BETTER
TRANSLATES TO THE SKILLED NEEDS
OF HIRING EMPLOYERS THIS MODEL
BY THE WAY HAS BEEN GROWING
TREMENDOUSLY THROUGHOUT THE
NATION- N. AS A STATE WE ARE
JUST NOW STARTING TO TALK ABOUT
IT IN OUR SYSTEM OF. OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS
FULFILLING ITS OVERSIGHT
OBLIGATIONS YOU HAVE CHARGED
OUR OFFICE WITH ENSURING
OVERSIGHT NOT ONLY OF CAL
BRIGHT BUT ALL OVER A HUNDRED
FIFTEEN COLLEGES. WE'RE
REVIEWING THE PROGRESS OF
CALIBRATE AND RESPONDED TO
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS
REGARDING THE PROGRESS IT'S
MAKING WE REVIEW THE FINANCIAL
REPORTING THAT COVERAGE SUBMITS
AS WE DO FOR EVERYONE OF OUR
COLLEGES. AND I CAN TELL YOU
TODAY THEY HAVE SUBMITTED EVERY
SINGLE REQUIRED FINANCIAL
REPORT THAT WE REQUIRE OF ALL
OF OUR COLLEGES. FOR EXAMPLE WE
ARE CURRENTLY REVIEWING- THERE-
ANNUAL- INDEPENDENT AUDIT AS WE
SPEAK. WHAT WE UNDERSTAND THE
COLLEGE IS IN ITS INFANCY AND
NOT ALL OF ITS REPORTING
SYSTEMS IN TEACHING LEARNING
MODELS HAVE BEEN FULLY
DEVELOPED I EXPECT THAT MY
OFFICE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR
THEIR FINANCES AS WELL AS A
TITLE FIVE COMPLIANCE AS WE DO
FOR ALL OF OUR COLLEGE. WELL AT
TIMES THE ROAD HAS BEEN ROCKY I
BELIEVE CAL PRIZE WELL ON ITS
WAY TO ACHIEVING THE OBJECTIVES
OF THE LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED
AND THAT- MY OFFICE EXPECTS OF
THEM. ON THE QUESTION A
DUPLICATION THIS QUESTION KEEPS
COMING UP- SO I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT I TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME. YOU RECEIVE MY OFFICES
ANALYSIS AND RATIONALE AS TO
WHY WE HAVE DETERMINED THAT THE
INITIAL PATHWAYS ARE NOT
DUPLICATIVE OF OTHER PROGRAMS
IN OUR SYSTEM THAT IS. OUR
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY AND WE
HAVE- THE CAPABILITY IN OUR
OFFICE OUR GENERAL COUNSEL AND
SEVERAL LAWYRS WHO HAVE LOOKED
AT THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT AND
IT MADE THIS DETERMINATION. NOW
WITH ANY CAREER PATHWAY THAT
CALIBRATE OF WELL UPS THERE
WILL BE ELEMENTS. OF THE
SUBJECT MATTER AND THE CONTENT
THAT CAN ALSO BE FOUND IN OTHER
PROGRAMS IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. HOWEVER THE
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE LIES IN
THE UNIQUE DESIGN OF THE
PATHWAYS LET ME GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE THAT I'M SURE YOU ALL
CAN RELATE TO- THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND THE CSU OFFER
DEGREES AND CERTIFICATES AND
CYBERSECURITY. CALIBRATE ALSO
OFFERS- TRAINING CYBERSECURITY.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CERTIFICATE AND A CSU
PASSERS WELL THEY'RE BOTH
CYBERSECURITY PROGRAMS AND
THERE ARE ELEMENTS IN BOTH
PROGRAMS THAT LOOK VERY MUCH
THE SAME IT IS A DIFFERENT
LEVEL OF CREDENTIALING. A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IS NOT
EQUIVALENT TO A CERTIFICATE IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AT
CYBERSECURITY NOR IS A
CERTIFICATE NICK YOU COLLEGES
EQUAL TO THE KIND OF
CERTIFICATION CREDENTIALING
THIS PROVIDED A COP RIGHT THESE
ARE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
EXPERTISE WITHIN THE FIELD OF
CYBER SECURITY. SO YES IT IS
EASY TO THINK THAT THEY ARE
DUPLICATIVE BUT THEY ARE NOT
JUSTICE. WE ARE NOT DUPLICATING
A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN THE CSU.
THE DESIGN OF THE PROGRAM IS
ACTUALLY VERY SIGNIFICANT AND
SPEAK TO THE INTENDED PURPOSE
OF COVERAGE MISSION TO FLEXIBLY
AND INTENTIONALLY PROVIDE
PATHWAYS INTO THE WORK FORCE.
THE DELIVERY MODEL THE CONCISE
NATURE OF THE SKILLS BEING
MASTERED THE DESIGN OF THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN THE
LEARNERS CALIBRATE IN THE
EMPLOYER PARTNERS. THIS THIS
THREE LIKE IT'S TOOL IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
SUCCESS OF CAB RIGHT AS IT MUST
ENGAGE WITH THE EMPLOYER AS
WELL AS THE LABOR ORGANIZATIONS
THAT. REPRESENT THESE EMPLOYEES
ARE NOT AND I'M PROUD TO SAY
THAT. ORGANIZATIONS LIKE S.
YEAH YOU HAVE BEEN AT THE TABLE
HELPING US UNDERSTAND HOW TO
BETTER SERVE THEM- FURTHERMORE
THE PROGRAMS ARE UNIQUE IN
THEIR INTENTIONAL DESIGNED TO
INTEGRATE AND TO CUSTOMIZE A
LEARNER'S PRIOR EXPERIENCE PACE
AND LEARNING NEEDS. SO ANOTHER
QUESTION YOU RAISED WHY DOES
CAL BRIGHT NEED TO BE A
SEPARATE ENTITY. THIS DEBATE
AND DISCUSS IN THE INITIAL THIS
TUNES OVER CALIBRATE. AT THIS.
WITH YOU THE FIRST ON THIS ITS
CREW IMPORTANT AT THE CORE
COMPETENCIES OF THE FACULTY AND
THE STAFF BE FIRMLY ROOTED IN
THE LEARNING SCIENCE IN THE
NEEDS OF WORKING LEARNERS. THIS
IS ALL THIS FACULTY AND STAFF
ARE ASKED TO DO SERVE WORKING
LEARNERS A GROWING POPULATION
IN CALIFORNIA THE NEEDS ACCESS
TO QUALITY CREDENTIALS. UNLIKE
MOST OF OUR THE COLLEGES
CALIBRATED SOLELY FOCUS ON THAT
ONE MISSION. TO PROVIDE
UPSCALING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
WORKING LEARNERS AND MEASURABLE
ATTAINMENT AS WELL AS ECONOMIC
MOBILITY. THIS PROVIDES THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AS WELL AS
YOU THE LEGISLATURE WITH THE
ABILITY TO CLEARLY EVALUATE
OUTCOME DATA AND NARROWLY
FOCUSED ATTENTION ON KEY
MILESTONES IN ADDITION THE
COLLEGE WILL HAVE THE ABILITY.
TO DEVELOP NEW FACULTY ROLES
THROUGH CONSULTATION WITH ITS
ACADEMIC LEADERSHIP CREATING
NEW MODELS FOR BARGAINING
UNITS. FOR BARGAINING CONTRACTS
THAT REPRESENT THE INTEREST OF
THE NEW TEACHING FACULTY AND
SWELLED TO CLASSIFY JOBS ARE
GOING TO BE CREATED BY
CALIBRATE. NOW WE ALSO SEE THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS IN THIS CASE
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES ABLE TO
SERVE STATE NEEDS NOT JUST
LOCAL NEEDS OUR OTHER SEVENTY
TWO DISTRICTS ARE LOCALLY
ELECTED AND GOVERN LOCALLY IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND IN SOME
WAYS A VERY PAROCHIAL. THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES ALLOWS FOR
GOVERNANCE ACROSS THE STATE.
AND I'LL EMPHASIZE THAT. THIS
BOARD OF TRUSTEES HAS A DIRECT
CONNECTION TO YOU AS YOU
CONFIRM EVERY MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES SO YOU HAVE
DIRECT ACCESS AND INFLUENCE
OVER THE GOVERNANCE OF THIS
ENTITY THE WAY IT'S CURRENTLY.
A SET UP. AT THROUGH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF PARTNERSHIPS IN
INNOVATION ALLIANCES WHICH WE
ARE CURRENTLY WORKING ON WITH
OTHER COLLEGES CALIBRATE CAN
ALSO QUICKLY DISSEMINATE THE
NEW TEACHING LEARNING METHODS
DEVELOPS WITH OTHER COLLEGES
WISHING TO REPLICATE THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY IN THE NEW
INNOVATIONS IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY. THIS IS ABOUT ADDING
TO THE CAPACITY THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES NOT REMOVING
CAPACITY FINALLY IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE TRADITIONAL
AROMA GROWTH IS DECLINING AND
THIS IS TRUE ACROSS THE STATE
AND ACROSS THE NATION. AND WE
SEE NONTRADITIONAL FOR PROFIT
AND NOT FOR PROFIT PROGRAMS
LIKE SOUTHERN NEW HAMPSHIRE-
THE UNIVERSITY OF PHOENIX
WESTERN GOVERNORS AN ISSUE ALL
SEEN TREMENDOUS GROWTH IN
CALIFORNIA IN THEIR ENROLLMENTS
BECAUSE THEY ARE OFFERING A
NONTRADITIONAL PATHWAY TO OUR
STUDENTS I BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS ITS OWN
RESPONSE A RESPONSE THAT IS
BOTH PUBLIC AND TRANSPARENT TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
BELIEVE THAT RISK. IT CAL
BRIGHT NOW LET ME POSE STORY
ONE OF THE CAL BRED LEARNERS
LEARNERS TRINIDAD UNITS AT
FIFTY EIGHT MISSED UNION AS AS
A FULL TIME JOB AND SHE
ESTIMATES THAT SHE MUST WORK
ANOTHER TEN TO FIFTEEN MORE
YEARS BEFORE RETIRING SHE
COMMUTES FROM RIVERSIDE TO
VENICE AND SO- CHAIR ROTH YOU
CAN APPRECIATE THAT COMMUTE-
THAT'S HOW FOR SHE COMMUTES FOR
HER JOB SHE ALSO CARES FOR HER
MOTHER. FOR HER ARE OLDER
FATHER. MR SAYS THE CAL I'D
SUPPORT PROGRAM IS THE RIGHT
FIT FOR HER AND SEES IT
COMPLEMENTING HER SKILLS FROM
PREVIOUS CAREER IN SYSTEM AS
BEING A PREVIOUS KOREAN SYSTEM
ANALYSTS CALIBRATED SERVING
HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS LIKE THIS
AND WILL CONTINUE TO SERVE MORE
SO I ASKED THIS BOY. TO ALLOW
CALIBRATE THE TIME IT NEEDS TO
FULLY DEVELOP AND TO SERVE MORE
CALIFORNIANS LIKE TRINIDAD
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME- AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS. CANCER PRESIDENT
SIGN THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH AND
OTHER SENATORS THANK YOU- AS
YOU'VE HEARD MY NAME IS TOM
EPSTEIN AND I SERVICE THE
PRESIDENT OF BOTH CAL RIGHT
BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND I DO
WANT TO SAY THAT I FEEL
RESPONSIBILITY TO BOTH OF IT I
WANT TO SEE THE SUCCESSOF THE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN OTHER
COLLEGES WELL AS COUNT RIGHT SO
I TAKETHIS RESPONSIBILITY VERY
SERIOUSLY. AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY WITH YOU TODAY
ABOUT COUNT RIGHT THIS IS MY
FIRST CHANCE TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU AND I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING YOU FOR YOUR
CONSISTENT SO PORT FOR THE
BECAUSE SYSTEM AND AS WELL VOTE
TO ESTABLISH OUR ONLINE
COLLEGE. WITHOUTVOTE YOU
BELIEVES THE NEW TRAIL IN
HIGHER EDUCATION FUNDING A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE VIENEN RELIC
EDUCATIONAL TRAINING FOR
CALIFORNIANS WORKING IN LOW
WAGE JOBS WITH LITTLE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ADVANCED. THE
CALL WAS A RESPONSE TO RAPIDLY.
ECONOMY THAT IS LEFT TO
CALIFORNIANS BEHIND
PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME WORKERS
OF COLOR. THE ONLINE COLLEGE
WAS GIVEN A UNIQUE MANDATE- AND
IT'S DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY TO
HELP ADULTS WHOSE WORK AND
FAMILY OBLIGATIONS PREVENT THEM
FROM ATTENDING A BRICK AND
MORTAR INSTITUTION ON A REGULAR
ACADEMIC CALENDAR. I CALIBRATE
THESE WORKERS CAN OBTAIN THE
EDUCATIONAL TRAINING THEY NEED
TO MOVE UP THE ECONOMIC LADDER
AT A TIME AND PLACE OF THEIR
CHOOSING. THE METHOD FOR
FILLING THE MISSION IS ONLINE
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION A
CHANCE OR JUST DESCRIBED. IT
ENABLES STUDENTS TO WORK AT
THEIR OWN PACE AND LEARN SKILLS
TO QUALIFY THEM FOR HIGHER
LEVEL JOBS. IMPORTANTLY CALVARY
WAS ALSO DESIGNED TO OFFER A
LOW COST PUBLIC ALTERNATIVE TO
THE FOR PROFIT COLLEGES WHICH
PROVIDE INFERIOR EDUCATION AT
PRICES THAT LEAVE MANY STUDENTS
DEEP IN DEBT. WE'RE STILL IN
THE VERY EARLY STAGES OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
IMPORTANT INSTITUTION CALIBRATE
COLLEGES ANNOUNCED TO THE
PUBLIC ONLY LAST MAY AND BEGAN
ACCEPTING APPLICANTS FOR
ADMISSION IN OCTOBER. MORE THAN
FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS HAVE
ENROLLED NOW AND ARE TAKING
COURSE WORK IN THE AREAS OF
CYBERSECURITY MEDICAL CODING
AND IT SUPPORT. THIS PILOT
GROUP WILL HELP US TO IMPROVE
OUR CURRICULUM IN STUDENT
SERVICES AND THE TECHNOLOGY
BEFORE WE EXPAND MORE BROADLY
THIS SUMMER. BECAUSE WE ARE AT
SUCH AN EARLY STAGE IN OUR
DEVELOPMENT THE INFORMATION WE
CAN PROVIDE TO YOU TODAY IS
VERY PRELIMINARY. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT OUR WORK. AT A
AT THIS HEARING IN WELCOME
INPUT FROM THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO HELP
US IMPROVE OUR SERVICES AND
FULFILL OUR MISSION. FINALLY I
WANT TO UPDATE YOU ON OUR
LEADERSHIP TRANSITION. AS YOU
KNOW OUR FIRST CEO RESIGNED
LAST MONTH. WE ARE PLEASED TO
WELCOME A NEW INTERIM CHIEF
EXECUTIVE A G. TO TELL WALKER
MANON WHO WILL START IN TWO
WEEKS MS MEN. BEARING CAN. SHOW
HER CITIES ASSOCIATES. MISS MEN
AND LET THE ADVANCE TEAM THAT
IMPLEMENTED THE LEGISLATION
THAT CREATED CALIBRATE AND IS
DEEP COMMISSION COMMITMENT TO
THE MISSION OF THE INSTITUTION.
SHE SERVED AS A KEY HIGHER
EDUCATION ADVISER IN THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE IN THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AS
WELL AS ROLES IN CONGRESS AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HELP STUDENTS ACHIEVE THEIR
HIGHER EDUCATION GOALS. AS
INTERIM CEO SHE WILL WORK
CLOSELY WITH YOU TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION YOU NEED FOR
EFFECTIVE OVERSIGHT OF COUNT
RIGHT. AND BEFORE I CONCLUDE- I
WAS GIVEN A FEW ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS EARLIER THIS WEEK
THAT I JUST WANTED TO ADDRESS
VERY QUICKLY- WHERE I WITH US
FOR AN UPDATE ON THE PROGRESS
IN IN MEETING THE START UP
MILESTONES IN- WE HAVE MET IN
IN A REPORT THAT WE SENT TO
YOU- LAST YEAR- MATTER
STATUTORY. OUT MILESTONES AND
WE ARE WORKING TOWARD THE
ACCREDITATION UNDER THE
DISTRICT. AT THE DISTANCE
EDUCATION ACCREDITING
COMMISSION AND WE WILL BE
ELIGIBLE TO SUBMIT- TO DO TO
THIS ORGANIZATION DEAC NO LATER
THAN OCTOBER IN TWENTY TWENTY.
I WAS ALSO AS FOR AN UPDATE ON
STUDENT ENROLLMENT- PROGRAM
OFFERINGS IN PROJECTIONS WE
HAVE FIVE HUNDRED AND TEN
ENROLLEES NOW. IN THE THREE
PROGRAM PATHWAYS AND WE EXPECT
TO HAVE OUR FIRST GRADUATES.
COMPLETE THE CURRICULUM BY LATE
SPRING. AND IN TERMS OF THE
BUDGET EXPENDITURE AND
FINANCIAL REPORTING- WE BELIEVE
WE'VE BEEN VERY CAREFUL
STEWARDS OF THE MONEY- THAT
WE'VE BEEN GIVEN SO FAR A-
SINCE IT. LAUNCHED ITS A TOTAL
OF NINE MILLION DOLLARS HAS
BEEN SPENT- THE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS AT THE LA- INDICATED
WAS FOR CAPITAL EXPENSES HAS
NOT BEEN SPENT THAT'S JUST
WHAT'S BEEN BUDGETED- WE INTEND
AND HAVE BEEN FROM THE
BEGINNING TRANSPARENT. AND
HAPPY TO PROVIDE ANY
INFORMATION THAT YOU EVER NEED
AND WE ALSO DID HAVE AN
INTERNAL AUDIT WHICH FOUND
WHICH GIVE US CLEAN BILL OF
HEALTH- FOR THE FIRST. SIX
MONTHS OF THE ORGANIZATION. AND
FINALLY WAS ASKED TO GIVE AN
UPDATE ON- ON WORK WITH
EMPLOYERS AND LABOR IS TO ME
WORKFORCE MAN'S- WE ARE WORKING
WITH WITH MANY DIFFERENT
EMPLOYERS AND HAVE DONE OUT
REACH TO OVER A HUNDRED OVER
THE LAST- MANY MONTHS- WE HAVE
LETTERS- IN THE RECORD TODAY-
ROM. SALES FORCE AND KELLY
SPACE AND TECHNOLOGY INDICATING
THEIR INTEREST IN WORKING WITH
US TO PLACE- CALIBRATE STUDENTS
IN THEIR JOBS. AND WE'VE ALSO
HAD SUPPORT FROM THE LA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN THE BAY AREA
COUNCILS. AS SO BAD THANK YOU.
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
CALLING I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
BUT RATHER THAN HAVE ME START
LET ME- DEFER TO YOU FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES. LET ME.
LET ME START AND I'M SURE
THEY'LL JUMP IN. YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'VE SPEAKER FOR ABOUT A TIME
UNDER THE DOME HERE CRITICIZING
THE FOR PROFIT EDUCATIONAL
INDUSTRY BOTH FOR THE COST OF
THEIR PROGRAMS AND FOR THEIR-
CURRENT LACK OF- OR FILL YOU TO
TIE PROGRAMS TO ACTUAL JOBS FOR
GRADUATES AND IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
IT'S A DISCUSSION CERTAINLY
THAT'S BEEN OCCURRING ON THE
NATIONAL. STAGE AS WELL SOME OF
THE FOR PROFITS AND OTHERS THE
UNIVERSITY OF PHOENIX S FOR
EXAMPLE CERTAINLY SERVE MORE
THAN COMPETENCY BASED. PROGRAMS
ON THEIR PLATE ON ITS PLATE.
BACHELOR'S DEGREES MASTER'S
DEGREES AND OTHERS- ARE IN A
CONCEPT THAT SHEDS BRICK AND
MORTAR FACILITIES FOR THE MOST
PART. FOR A FLEXIBILITY AND ALL
OF THE REST. THAT'S PROBABLY A
SUBJECT THAT WHEN WE DON'T HAVE
THAT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
AND WE CAN PROBABLY HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION AND I'M SURE. THE
DEBATE WILL BE FIERCE IF WE
EVER STARTED BUT THE REAL ISSUE
HERE IT SEEMS TO ME IS WHETHER
THIS PRODUCT IS NEEDED. AND IF
SO HOW BEST TO DELIVER IT AND
THAT'S WHERE WE GET INTO THE
DUPLICATION CONVERSATION. SINCE
I WAS NOT HERE IN TWENTY EIGHT
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHO AND I
INDICATED I'D LIKE TO SORT OF
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
FOUNDATION FOR THIS PROGRAM
HOWEVER SHORT. LET ME JUST ASK
A FEW QUESTIONS I'VE READ. THE
MILESTONE REPORT THE RECENT ONE
FROM CALIBRATED. AND NOTED THE
EFFORT TO- ENGAGE EXCITE AND
EDUCATE I THINK THE THREE EASE
THAT YOU ALL USE. THE EIGHT
MILLION STRANDED WORKERS IN THE
STATE. AND THEN WHEN I TOOK A
LOOK AT THE- BUDGET COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN FOR THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL. I NOTED THAT- THERE
WAS SOME CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S VIEW THAT
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
INADEQUATELY SERVING THE TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
BETWEEN THE AGES OF TWENTY FIVE
AND THIRTY FOUR WHO WERE IN THE
WORK FORCE BUT LACK A POST
SECONDARY. DEGREE OR CREDENTIAL
AND PRESUMABLY THAT WAS THE ONE
OF THE PREMISES THAT MY
PREDECESSORS- CONSIDERED WHEN
THOROUGHLY EVALUATING THIS
PROPOSAL IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. SO
MY QUESTION I WAS THROUGH THE
QUESTIONS THEY DID TEACH ME HOW
TO ASK THEM ART THERE WERE
THERE ANY SPECIFIC STUDIES THAT
SUPPORT THE PREMISE THAT WE
HAVE EIGHT MILLION STRANDED
WORKERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND TALK ABOUT
STUDIES. AND IT'S EIGHT MILLION
ONE PLACE IT'S A POINT FIVE
MILLION ANOTHER BUT WHAT I HAVE
WHAT I DID NOT NOTICE IN ANY OF
THE MATERIAL THAT I READ IN
PREPARING FOR THIS. ANY
CITATION TO A SPECIFIC STUDY
DOESN'T MEAN THERE ISN'T ONE.
WAS ANY TAKERS. SO SURE RAFI
THERE WERE IS. A LOT OF
DISCUSSION AROUND- WHAT DO WE
MEAN BY STRANDED WORKERS AND
HOW DO WE COME UP WITH THESE
NUMBERS- SO. ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT WE RELIED ON DIRECTLY WAS-
BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
ANALYSIS ON WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS ET DE
DATA- AS WELL AS INFORMATION
THAT COMES DOOR YOU KNOW FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AND
OTHERS WHO ARE SPECIFICALLY
FOCUSED ON THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF.
DEGREE ATTAINMENT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- WORKERS AND
THEIR WAGES- THE WAGES OF
WORKERS THAT- BOTH WORKERS AND
HAVE HAD POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION CREDENTIALS AND WAGES
THAT HAVE NOT SO THERE ARE
MULTIPLE NOT ONLY STUDIES BUT
DATA THAT COMES DIRECTLY FROM
FEDERAL AND STATE SOURCES
THAT'S WHAT WE RELIED ON THAT'S
WHAT WE PROVIDED- THE
LEGISLATURE- THERE ARE THERE
ARE STUDIES- BOTH FROM-
GEORGETOWN- DOCTRINE KERN
VOLLEY DOES A LOT OF. WORK
THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT TWO NINE
LOOK AT THE MACHINE OF STRIP IT
WORK ARTS OR ABOUT DIFFERENT
PEOPLE CALL THIS- DEMOGRAPHIC
DIFFERENTLY. BUT CALIFORNIA HAS
A LAW WHICH IS SEGMENT IN WORK.
WORK GROUPS THAT. COLLEGE
CREDENTIALS IS THIS THE WAY THE
COMMUNITY CALL THIS TO TRY
CAPTURE THOSE WORK SO THEY WE
CAN CERTAINLY PER YOU WITH A
LOT OF THAT IN BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDED TO STAFF BUT- AS YOU
MENTIONED DEPENDING ON WHICH
REPORT YOU READ IT HAS
DIFFERENT- NUMBERS OF WORKERS
BUT IT'S ANYWHERE BETWEEN SIX
AND EIGHT MILLION WHICH IS A
LOT KNOW HOW YOU LOOK AT IT MY
COULD EARN. BOTH THERE IS. THE
US THE PRO OF FOR DATA AND THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT OR EDT
DATA. IS VERY GENERAL
NONSPECIFIC. OVERALL AND
CERTAINLY DRAMATICALLY
NONSPECIFIC WHEN IT COMES TO
THE BREAK DOWN OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE VARIOUS REGIONS IN
CALIFORNIA SO I DON'T KNOW HOW
HELPFUL THAT DATE IS WHEN
MAKING A STATEMENT THAT WE HAVE
STRANDED WORKERS BECAUSE- THAT
STATEMENT. SUGGESTS THAT YOU
HAVE WORKERS WHO IN SOME CASES
WANT TO DO SOMETHING ELSE YOU
HAVE SUGGESTS THAT YOU HAVE
WORKERS WHO WERE IN REGIONS
THAT HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO DO
SOMETHING ELSE. GIVEN THE DISH
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT THERE
ARE A LOT OF ASSUMPTIONS THAT
ARE BUILT IN THERE THAT I
THAT'S WHY I ASK IF THERE WAS A
SPECIFIC STUDY. TAILORED TO
CALIFORNIA AND IN PARTICULAR
TO- THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
ONLINE EDUCATION AND BRICK AND
MORTAR EDUCATION THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN COMPETENCY BASED DIRECT
ASSESSMENT PROGRAMS AND THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE CURRENTLY
OFFER IN OUR C. ISSUE YOU SEE
AND- MORE PARTICULARLY. ARE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM SO THAT ANSWERED THE
QUESTION I'M DISAPPOINTED THAT
THERE WAS NOT A MORE SPECIFIC
STUDY THAT RELY ON. AND THE
SECOND PART OF THE QUESTION
HAVE THERE BEEN ANY STUDIES.
THE DOCUMENT. IN I'M CREED WAY
ARE CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITIES AND
IN PARTICULAR A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE INADEQUATELY
SERVING. ANY PARTICULAR
DEMOGRAPHIC CAN OUR POPULATION
BASE AND IN PARTICULAR THE TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE AND THIRTY
FOUR THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
APPARENTLY RELIED ON. IN
PUTTING THE FORMER
ADMINISTRATION IN PUTTING
FORWARD. THIS PROPOSAL. AND YOU
ALL SHOULD BE AWARE OF IT
BECAUSE IT WOULD BE A TIDY
THAT'S CRITICIZING THE VERY
VERY COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
THAT YOU SUPERVISE. YES SO THE
ANSWER IS YES- AND I WOULD
ARGUE TO YOUR PREVIOUS POINT
AND WE WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
SEVERAL OTHER STUDIES THAT HAVE
BEEN DONE ON THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE SPECIFICALLY. WE ARE
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW ENGAGING
WITH THE GOVERNOR GOVERNOR
NEWSOME ON THE FUTURE OF WORK
COMMISSION WHICH IS ALSO
LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE.
SPECIFICALLY FOR CALIFORNIA AND
THE DISPARITY BETWEEN WAGE GAIN
AND- AVAILABILITY OF COLLEGE
CREDENTIALS SO- I THINK- WE
HAVE RELIED HEAVILY AND HAVE
ARGUED TO THE LEGISLATURE THE
CALIFORNIACOMMITTEE COLLEGES
NEEDS MORE CAPACITY- BOTH IN
TERMS OF ONLINE EDUCATION. COMP
THE BEST EDUCATION AND- THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW BRICK AND
MORTAR CAPACITY. MOST RECENTLY-
THE GOVERNOR'S- POST SECONDARY
COUNCIL ON EDUCATION- REVIEWED
SEVERAL REPORTS OF FROM
MACKENZIE. THAT WERE
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED AT THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE IN THE
CAPACITY OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
TO MEET THE DEMAND PARTICULARLY
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. THESE ARE TWO
AREAS OF THE STATE WHERE WE
LACK CAPACITY FROM BOTH THE
PUBLIC. HIGHER EDUCATION SECTOR
AND THE NONPROFIT HIGHER
EDUCATION SECTOR. IT IS LED TO
INITIATIVES LIKE THE FRESNO
PROJECT THAT ARE TRYING TO
BUILD ADDITIONAL CAPACITY BY
BRINGING TOGETHER THE PUBLIC IN
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR. BUT THERE.
I AT LEAST I AM FIRMLY
CONVINCED. THAT MY SYSTEM. DOES
NOT HAVE ALL THE TOOLS
NECESSARY. TO SUPPORT THE NEEDS
OF PARTICULARLY OF WORKERS WHO
DID NOT GET MORE THAN A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA AND WHOSE JOBS.
I THINK WHETHER YOU'RE READING
MACKENZIE PRICE WATERHOUSE
COOPER THE BROOKINGS INSTITUTE
A NUMBER OF THINK TANKS AND OF
LOOKED AT THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE. THERE IS WHETHER
IT'S EIGHT MILLION SIX MILLION
OR FOUR MILLION. VULNERABLE TO
THE CHANGES THAT ARE HAPPENING.
WITH A AYE AND AUTOMATION IN
THE WORK FORCE SO THAT'S- THAT
WAS THE IMPETUS SO- HAS THERE
BEEN ONE COMPREHENSIVE STUDY
DONE JUST ON THIS QUESTION- I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE HAS
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT
IS BEING DONE. TOLD BRING ALL
THE STUDIES TOGETHER TO FOCUS
ATTENTION ON THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE- AND IS LED TO A LOT
OF CHANGES BOTH THEM OUR SYSTEM
TO SEE IF YOU THE UC AS WELL
AS- CHANGES OF THE GOVERNOR IS
CONSIDERING FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WELL I HAVE MORE
DETAILED QUESTIONS AND I HOPE
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
TO THOSE BUT LET ME JUST ASK
MORE OVER ARCH QUESTION. HERE
BECAUSE I THINK GHOST PART OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING WE'RE
CONVERSATION. ALL THE TO AT.
BACK TO HAVE THIS WORK FOR
PROGRAM WE FIND IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS ONE COMPONENT OF
WITH CONSORTIUM IS ONE
COMPONENT OF TRYING TO BRING
FOLKS FROM HIGH SCHOOL INTO IT
WAS CERTIFICATES AND THEN THE
DIFFERENT JOBS AND WE FUND AT
IT I DON'T KNOW THE LEVEL OF
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OR SO IS A
RECALL WE HAVE ANOTHER ADULT
SIMILAR PROGRAM THAT IS A K. TO
TWELVE CONCERTS YEAR REIGN AS
WELL AND THERE'S THE TENSION
BETWEEN THE- OF THOSE. WE HAVE
OTHER. T. E. EFFORTS THE FUNDED
TO THE TUNE OF HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR.
PLUS YOU HAVE AN INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. AND I'M SURE OTHER
PEOPLE HERE THEY WILL TALK
ABOUT THIS LATER. IN A HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IF YOU HAVE A IF YOU HAVE EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS IF
THAT'S ACCURATE ENROLLED IN
THOSE. AND YOU HAVE HUNDREDS OF
ONLINE PROGRAMS OR THOUSANDS
DEPENDING ON WHICH TO STICK YOU
PICK. ONE AND WORK WITHIN THE
EXISTING SYSTEM. TWO FOR
EXAMPLE. TELL ONE OR MORE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE ALL OF
THEM FOR THAT MATTER. TO TAKE A
CERTAIN PORTION OF THEIR EFFORT
IF WE HAVE TO TAKE A PORTION OF
THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
TAKE A PORTION OF THAT. AND
MOVE AWAY FROM- TRADITIONAL
CLASSROOM MODELED INSTRUCTION
TO IF THE CURRENT VIEW IS WE
WANT MORE COMPETENCY BASED
DIRECT ASSESSMENT PROGRAMS.
WITH FLEXIBLE. START AND STOP
TIMES AND NOT. TETHERED TO
PARTICULAR ACADEMIC TERMS TELL
ONE OR MORE OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE ALL OF THEM TO
MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION 410% OF
THEIR OFFERINGS ARE 20% OR
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. TO
ACCOMPLISH THE OBJECTIVE THAT'S
BEEN OUTLINED FOR CALIBRATED
ASSUMING IT'S A VALID OBJECTIVE
ASSUMING WE HAVE STRANDED
WORKERS ASSUMING WERE
INADEQUATELY SERVING A PORTION.
OF OUR POPULATION IS- FOR
QUESTION. HOW ABSOLUTELY AND I
THINK IT WAS A IT WAS A
QUESTION THAT WAS RAISED TO
BEGIN WITH. THIS QUESTION WHY
WOULD WE NEED ANOTHER COLLEGE
NOW. IT'S A BIG THE QUESTION
WHY DO WE HAVE A HUNDRED
FOURTEEN COLLEGES TO BEGIN WITH
I MEAN THERE IS AN ASSUMPTION
THAT WILL. CONTINUE TO GROW UP
IN CALIFORNIA. SO YES THIS
QUESTION. IS THERE ANY NEED FOR
THIS TYPE OF CASSIDY IS A
BALLOT C<c.cyan>. QUESTION CAN. ASK</c>
BY THIS BY. I WILL. THAT TO UP
I'M- JUSTICE. WAY ME TAKE AN
EXAMPLE OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT THAT I GREW UP
IN THE COASTER BECAUSE SYSTEM I
WENT TO GOLDEN WEST COLLEGE THE
COST ME COLLEGE DISTRICT HAS
THREE COLLEGES ONE OF WHICH IS
FULLY ONLINE- IT WAS DEVELOPED
TO INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY OF
ONLINE INSTRUCTION SO THE CORE
CAPACITY FOR COASTAL IN
COLLEGES ONLY TO DO ONLINE
EDUCATION. THE CHALLENGE FOR US
WHY MARLIN FOR OTHER COLLEGES
IS AT OUR COLLEGES ALREADY.
RECEIVE LESS THAN NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STUDENT THE ALREADY
ASKED. TO SERVE MULTIPLE
MISSIONS INCLUDING IN- ESL
INCLUDING- INCARCERATED
FORMALLY INCARCERATED STUDENTS
FOSTER YOUTH WE CONTINUE TO ASK
OUR COLLEGES TO DO MORE AND
MORE. IT WAS- OUR ARGUMENT THAT
WE NEEDED TO BUILD A COLLEGE
JUST TO SERVE ONE POPULATION
AND THEN TO DISSEMINATE THAT
LEARNING TO ALL OF OUR HUNDRED
FOURTEEN CALL JUST SO THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO BUILD CAPACITY.
IN THE EXAMPLE THAT YOU USE THE
ONLINE EDUCATION INITIATIVE THE
ONLINE EDUCATION IN THIS GOAL.
IS TO DEVELOP A- A CORPSE
EXCHANGE FOR ON. EDUCATION SO
THE ANY STUDENT IN THE STATE
CAN TAKE AN ONLINE COURSE AND
IF THEY CHOOSE TO BE TAKEN INTO
PROBE A STUDY. IT'S BEEN ALL
FIVE YEARS WE STILL HAVE NOT
LEAVE THAT GOAL THAT'S NOT A
CRITICISM OF THE ISLAND.
INITIATIVE THAT'S- AN ISSUE
THAT WE IN THE SYSTEM ARE
CONTINUE TO BE ASKED TO DO
SEVERAL THINGS AT ONCE BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS FIFTY HIM AS
MY WRONG FIFTY SEVEN OF YOUR-
ONE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
COLLEGES ARE PART OF THE-
ONLINE EDUCATION INITIATIVE.
FIFTY SEVEN OUR PARTY ONLINE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE BUT THERE
ARE MUCH LESS COURSES AVAILABLE
ON THE COURSE EXCHANGE IN THE
IN THE REASON FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE WE STILL ARE CHALLENGED
BY TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. HOW TO
SHARE- F. T. HOW TO SHARE THE
EXPENSE THE REVENUE ACROSS THE
COLLEGE THEN WE WILL GET THERE.
BUT BUT THE OTHER THING I WOULD
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IS THESE ARE
CONTINUE TO BE TREATED NO
CORPUS. I WOULD STILL OPEN THE
SUN ESTHER MY- THERE'S SICK
TIME. AND WHILE IMPORTANT WE TO
GO BECAUSE- WE HAVE OUR
COMPETITORS CONTINUE TO GROW
THEIR CAPACITY- IN MY MIND THIS
IS NOT AN EITHER OR SITUATION
WE NEED BOTH. WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THE
STRONG WORK FORCE INITIATIVE
BECAUSE THAT ALLOWS OUR
COLLEGES TO WORK IN REGIONS. TO
WORK TOGETHER TO SERVE TO TRY
AND SOLVE THE PROBLEMS FOR
REGIONAL WORKFORCE WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO REACH MORE STUDENTS
THROUGH THINGS LIKE ONLINE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE AND THE
INTRODUCTION OF C. B. E. WE ARE
PREPARING REGULATIONS TO GO TO
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS THAT
WOULD ALLOW ALL OF FOUR HUNDRED
FOURTEEN COLLEGES IF THEY
CHOOSE TO OFFER C. B. E. IN MY
MIND WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
BUILD. ALL OF LEVELS OF
CAPACITY IN ORDER TO SERVE THE
NEEDS GROWING NEEDS OF OUR
WORKFORCE. WELL ONE OF MY
CONCERNS IS WHETHER WE CAN
AFFORD TO DO TRACK THIS THING
AND- TRACKS WITH. THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET AS I RECALL BUT
YOU COULD THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN PROPER. NINETY ONE
TIME TO IMPROVE ONLINE YES
EDUCATION THROUGH ONLINE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE. AND CAN
LOOK THAT. BUDGET TERM.
INITIATIVE I GUESS FOR THE
ADMIN. MINUS THAT THE PROGRAM
WAS DESIGNED TO- LEAD THIS
THESE ARE THE WORDS LEAD TO
SHORT TERM INDUSTRY VALUED
CERTIFICATES OR CREDENTIALS ARE
PROGRAMS. FOR ENABLE STUDENT IN
A PATHWAY TO CONTINUE IN THE
PATHWAY. IN A PATHWAY OFFERED
BY AN EXISTING COLLEGE WAS
CERTAINLY THE FIRST ONE IS
EXACTLY THE CAL BRIGHT MODEL
ISN'T IT SHORT TERM INTO SHOCK
VALUE TOO DIFFICULT CREDENTIALS
ARE PROGRAMS. AND IF SO IF THAT
DOESN'T DIFFER FROM CAP BRIDES
IT'D MISSION. WHAT ARE WE
DOING. SO SENATOR I WOULD ARGUE
THAT IT IS NOT THE SAME AND I
REALIZE THAT THIS IS. SOMETIMES
A DIFFICULT DISTINCTION BECAUSE
WE ARE SO USE TO THE MODEL OF
EDUCATION THAT WE ALL
PARTICIPATED IN. THAT WE ALL
HAD THE BENEFIT OF GOING TO A
COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY WHETHER
ONLINE OR BRICK AND MORTAR AND
HAVING THE ABILITY TO PURSUE AN
EDUCATION. THAT REQUIRED
SEVERAL SEMESTERS TO GET
THROUGH. AND EVEN IN THE SHORT
TERM CERTIFICATE MODEL IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WE'RE STILL ASKING. OUR
STUDENTS. TO GO THROUGH A
SERIES OF COURSES OVER A SERIES
A LENGTH OF TIME TO ACCOMPLISH
AND ACHIEVE A CERTIFICATE THAT
ROOM. IMPORTANT CREDENTIAL
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS THE
LOWER LEVEL OF CREDENTIALING A
LEVEL CREDENTIALING THAT WE
HAVE NOT STATE BEEN DOING A
LEVEL OF CREDENTIALS AND THAT
IS CHARTER TO WE- WORK. WHO
WERE WERE TO WITH. THAT'S THE
TYPE OF CREDENTIAL IN THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
WHO. DO NOT ALWAYS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DROP WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND ATTEND ONE OF
OUR COLLEGES SO THIS WILL MAKE
US MORE FLEXIBLE NOT LESS
FLEXIBLE. TO MORE CALIFORNIANS
BELLE ISLE NOTE ON THIS.
ATTACHED TO THE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THAT
INITIATIVE IT OUR ANALYSIS
INDICATES SEVENTY QUALIFYING
PROJECTS WERE FUNDED OUT OF A
HUNDRED APPLICATIONS DESIGNED
TO CREATE FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVEN NEW OR IMPROVED FULLY
ONLINE PROGRAMS LEADING THE
HIGHER WAGE EMPLOYMENT. I
REALIZE THIS ISN'T YOU AND THIS
IS WASN'T YOUR INITIATIVE I
DON'T THINK BUT SOMEBODY FROM
THE OUTSIDE LOOKING AT THIS
WOULD PROBABLY THINK WE AREN'T
VERY WELL ORGANIZED. IN THIS
STATE IS JUST AN OBSERVATION
AND I WOULD MAKE LET ME MOVE%
TO. EMPLOYERS AND IT SEEMS TO
ME BASED ON WHAT'S BEEN SAID
AND CERTAINLY WHAT I'VE READ
THAT THE LYNCH PIN IN THIS
PROCESS IS THE EMPLOYER
COMMUNITY AND I FRANKLY Q.
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO FIGURE OUT
WHETHER OUR- CUSTOMERS ARE
EMPLOYERS OR OUR CUSTOMERS OUR
STUDENTS AT THIS POINT AND
I'LL- I'VE GOT SOME QUESTIONS
TO GO TO THAT IN A MINUTE BUT-
WHAT. WHAT NEEDS BASED STUDY
WAS CONDUCTED AROUND THIS STATE
OF HIM OF EMPLOYERS NOW. TO
DETERMINE THE NEED FOR A
COMMUNITY BASED- TRAINING
PROGRAM. THE ONE WE'VE EMBARKED
ON TO INITIATING THIS EFFORT IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OTHER WORDS
WHAT EMPLOYERS WORK OR STUDY
INDEPENDENTLY. AND WHO STUCK
THEIR HAND UP AND SAID LET ME
SIGN ON THE DOTTED LINE I NEED
THIS GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
INDUSTRY THAT. PROBABLY IS MORE
TRAINING INTENSIVE THAN ANY
OTHER AND IT'S JUST WEST OF
HERE IN THE NORTHERN PART OF
CALIFORNIA. MUCH OF THAT
INDUSTRY HAS OR HAS OUR OWN AND
HAS THEIR OWN INTERNAL TRAINING
PROGRAMS WHETHER IT'S COOL OR
WHATEVER- INTUITIVE COULD
PROGRAMS THAT THEY OFFER BOTH
FOR THEIR OWN EMPLOYEES
EMPLOYEES AND OTHER- PLACES OF
EMPLOYMENT. CENTER FOR QUESTION
YES NO ABSOLUTELY AND I THINK
IF YOU PICK UP THE PAPER ANY
DAY OF THE WEEK YOU SEE ONE
MORE EMPLOYER ONE MORE LARGE
EMPLOYER WHETHER IT'S DISNEY
WALMART- DISCOVERED CHIPOTLE
ALL INVESTING IN EMPLOYER LED
TRAINING PROGRAM. FOR THEIR
WORK FORCE SO I THINK ONE THAT
SPEAKS TO THE TREMENDOUS DEMAND
TO THAT SPEAKS TO. THE LUCK OF
CAPACITY EMPLOYERS HE AND I
PUBLIX. OF OTHERWISE THEY
WOULDN'T BE IN IN THE OWN
PROGRAM SO WOULD RATHER SEE THE
INVEST IN OUR PROGRAMS I WOULD
RATHER SEE THEM INVEST THAT
MONEY IN THE PUBLIC SYSTEMS-
NOW SO WHICH EMPLOYERS SHOULD
WE TALKED WE TALKED TO- IT IS A
LARGE LIST OF EMPLOYERS
INCLUDING EMPLOYER
ORGANIZATIONS FROM THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL. THE TO THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP TO THE
LA CHAMBER SAN DIEGO SAN
FRANCISCO. MANY MANY MANY
EMPLOYER GROUPS THAT WE HAVE
MET WITH THEY CONTINUE TO BE
SUPPORTIVE AND CONTINUE TO
RAISE YOUR HAND AND SAY YES WE
WANT THIS INCLUDING LARGE
EMPLOYERS LIKE YOU HAVE-
LETTERS FROM SALES FORCE WE
HAVE- IN WE HAVE SUPPORT FROM-
HEALTH CARE ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
KAISER DIGNITY HEALTH SUTTER.
AND OTHERS. AND AN IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION HERE IS THAT WE ARE
NOT JUST FOCUS ON EMPLOYERS. WE
ARE NOT- GIVING EMPLOYERS MORE
OF A HAND IN THIS DESIGN. THEN
WE ARE WORKERS IT IS AN EQUAL
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT WE CONTINUE
TO REACH OUT TO AND WORK WITH
OUR LABOR PARTNERS WHO SEE THIS
AS A CRITICAL ISSUE. WHETHER
WE'RE TALKING TO- AS YEAH YOU
YOU H. W. S. YEAH YOU IN
GENERAL- CSEA OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SEE THE NEED
NOW THERE IS A CHALLENGE WITH
EMPLOYERS. BECAUSE OF EMPLOYERS
DO NOT FEEL THAT CAL BRIDE IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE HERE FOR
THE NEXT THREE YEARS AS
DIFFICULT TO LAND. A FIRM
PARTNERSHIP. BUT NONE THE LESS
THERE ARE PARTNERSHIPS THAT
ARE. HAVE BEEN DEVELOPING
CONTINUE TO BE DEVELOPED THE
THREE PATHWAYS THAT WERE
DETERMINED- WHEN WE CAME BEFORE
YOU THE FIRST TIME THE THREE
PATHWAYS ARE DETERMINED.
BECAUSE OF THE EMPLOYER DEMAND
AND BECAUSE OF THE LABOR
ORGANIZATION DEMAND THAT'S HOW
THEY CAME INTO EXISTENCE- SO WE
WILL CONTINUE TO ROUTE. I SAY
WIKI IS BECAUSE THIS IS
SOMETHING A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DOES THIS IS IN OUR DNA EXPECT
CALIBRATED TO THE SECOND THING.
IS LEVEL OF CREDENTIALS AS WE
ASK MUST TURN YOUR COLLEGE WITH.
US AND YOU ME BECAUSE THIS MARK
MY FORMER COLLEGE BEACH COLLEGE
WE SEE THIS ADDING TO PASSIVELY
WELL I HAVE SOME WORK. ON THIS
PARTICULAR EMPLOYER ISSUE WHEN
AND THE MAN BUT I. SENATOR UP
IT'S GOING ME A XO UNDER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR OF YEAH. I
WOULD GO BACK TO ALLOW BIT THE
ISSUE OF. TARGET OF WORKERS
BETWEEN THE AGES OF TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY FIVE ON THE UNDERSERVED-
CALIFORNIA'S WORK FORCES ABOUT
HALF LATINO. AND THE MEAT THAT
PARTICULAR DESCRIPTION UP BUT
THE CAL BRIGHT OF COLLEGE
ENROLLMENT SO FAR- IS LESS THAN
THIS MAN THE LATINO ENROLLMENT
IS LESS THAN 20% AND THEN 25%
OF ENROLLEES HAVE ALREADY
OBTAINED A BACHELOR'S DEGREE SO
HOW DOES THAT. DR HOW DOES THAT
MATCH WHAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
THE MISSION OF CAL BRIGHT. I
MEAN LET ME TAKE THEM IN FOR-
FIRST OF ALL YOU KNOW THIS IS A
PILOT- COVERT IT'S THE FIRST
WAVE OF PEOPLE BUT ALSO THERE
IS- IMPORTANTLY THERE WAS A AN
ERROR IN THE CALCULATION
ORIGINALLY THAT. THE PERCENT
OF- LENNIX- ENROLLEES IS OVER
30% IT'S- IN THE MID THIRTIES
AND- WE APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
HAVING THAT ACCURATELY AT THE
BEGINNING- BUT THE- IN TERMS OF
THE 25% BEING- HAVE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. WE'VE HEARD
SOME. SO TALK THAT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM WHO
HAVE. SIGNED UP FOR CALIBRATED
TO SEE WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT AND
WE THINK THAT MAY HAVE- PERHAPS
THROWN OFF THE- THE EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT OF THIS OF THIS
INITIAL COHORT. WE DON'T KNOW
FOR SURE BUT- THAT'S JUST-
THINGS THINGS THAT WE'VE HEARD.
BUT YOU KNOW OUR OUR- OUR
INTENT AS WE AS WE MARKET MORE
BROADLY AND- AND GROW THAT THAT
WE- WE WERE. COMPLETELY
CONVINCED THAT WE WILL HAVE A-
YOU KNOW BE REACHING THE TARGET
AUDIENCE WE HAVE A NUMBER OF.
PROGRAMS IN PLACE BOTH BOTH
JUST- DIRECTED. OUT REACH TO
TWO GROUPS THAT WORK CLOSELY
WITH THOSE POPULATIONS AS WELL
AS- AS A TARGETED ONLINE-
MARKETING- PLAN THAT THAT WE
THINK WILL REACH THEM WHERE
THEY ARE AND THEN WAIT. THE
PAPER SEE THE OUR MISSION SO
WITHIN THAT WILL WILL CHANGE
OVER TIME IN I CAN'T REPEAT
ENOUGH THAT THIS I MEAN WHICH
LAUNCHED A FEW MONTHS AFTER
UNITED AFTER GETTING THE AFTER
EVEN AND ANNOUNCING IN NAME IN
THAT. SO THERE'S A LONG WAY TO
GO TO- TO ENHANCE OUR
VISIBILITY- IN THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE WANT TO REACH AND THAT
WE ARE DEDICATED TO DOING THAT
SO- THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE
IS HOW ARE YOU MAKING SURE THAT
CAO BREAKS OUR RECRUITMENT
PLANS ARE NOT. POACHING THE
STUDENT. THAT OTHERWISE WOULD
HAVE UTILIZE THE ONLINE. US
EIGHTY UP PROGRAM OFFERED BY
COMMITTEE COLLEGES. THE AT THE
INSTRUCTION THAT WE'RE OFFERING
IS VERY DIFFERENT IN IN BOTH
FORM AND SUBSTANCE IT'S- AS
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IT- YOU CAN
START AND STOP WHENEVER YOU
WANT- YOU PROGRESS AT YOUR OWN
PACE. AND IN ITS- IS OFFERING
IT IS NOT FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE
LOOKING FOR DEGREES AS MOST
PEOPLE WHO GO TO A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE YOU'RE LOOKING FOR. TO
BUILD CREDITS TOWARD A DEGREE
THIS IS NOT WHAT THIS IS FOR
THIS IS. TO OBTAIN JOB SKILLS
TO MOVE UP THE ECONOMIC LADDER
FROM FROM WHERE YOU ARE SO- IT
IT'S A DIFFERENT PURPOSE AND A
DIFFERENT METHODOLOGY THEN AND
THEN OTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE USING AND I DO WANT TO ADD
THAT. WE THINK THIS WILL IN THE
LONG RUN BENEFIT ALL THE-
COLLEGES BECAUSE WE'RE- A
VEHICLE FOR EXPERIMENTATION AND
LEARNING HOW TO DO. WHAT AND AS
WITH THAT WE CAN SHARE THAT-
THAT KNOWLEDGE WITH. THE BASE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE SIMILAR AND
WE ALL WILL SHARE- ALSO IN OUR
IN OUR OUT REACH TO EMPLOYERS
FOR INSTANCE- WITH WE FIND AN
EMPLOYER HAS GREAT NEEDS IN
CALIBRATING TO START WITH A
VERY SMALL. STUDENT POPULATION
YOU CAN PUT IN. A STEEP TO BE
TRYING TO GET OTHER COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO TAKE THE JOBS THAT
THAT WITH THE STATEWIDE
EMPLOYERS THAT WERE- THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DEVELOP RELATIONSHIPS
WITH. IF I CAN ADD SENATOR I'D
I THINK. YOU KNOW A AN
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION IS YOU
KNOW AS YOU MENTIONWHO WHO IS
CAL BRIGHT TARGETING RESEARCH
WHO IS. OUR OUR TRADITIONAL
COMMITTEE CALLED IS TARGETING.
AND I THINK- THAT CERTAINLY OUR
EXPECTATION CHANGES OFFICE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE CLEAR
ABOUT WHO THEY SHOULD BE
TARGETING. THEY SHOULD BE
WORKING WITH AND I THINK THE
MORE- LABOR PARTNERSHIPS THAT
ARE CREATED WITH CALIBRATED
THINK THE MORE THAT YOU'LL SEE
THAT TARGET CONTINUE TO. BE
REFINED- I ALSO THINK. THAT YOU
KNOW. WE ARE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SO WE CANNOT DENY ENROLLMENT.
TO ANY COLLEGE I MEAN YOU'RE-
FROM- THE GREAT CITY OF SAN
ANGELES WE HAVE. PROBABLY OUR
TALKING HERE THREE COLLEGES
AROUND OR ARE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES- WE FEEL THAT. THE
COLLEGES IN LAS CHANGES WORK
WELL TOGETHER. TO SERVE THE
NEEDS OF EMPLOYER EVEN THOUGH
STUDENTS MOVE. CONTINUOUSLY
THROUGH ALL THE COLLEGES
WHETHER THEY'RE GOING TO SANTA
MONICA COLLEGE LACC- REAL HONDA
WHEREVER THEY'RE GOING. AND IS
WHY WE EXPECT CAL RIGHT TO
FORM. ALLIANCES AND
PARTNERSHIPS CABARETS ALREADY
FORMED A MEMORANDUM BUT AND
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE SOUTH
ORANGE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. IT'S EXPLORING A
PARTNERSHIP WITH SEVERAL OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS AND
THAT THAT'S THE EXPECTATION WE
HAVE ALL OVER COLLEGES TO WORK
TOGETHER TO ENSURE. THAT WERE
HANDED OUT STUDENTS OF BELONG
IN OTHER PROGRAMS I LIKE WHAT
THE CAN AND OFF THE COP RIGHT
SO SAID ARE BETTER. STRUCTURE
GOING UP. AND JUST ENTER OF THE
EMPLOYER. I MEAN WITHIN A FEW
YEARS- YOU PROJECTED YOU WILL
HAVE TWENTY TWO THOUSAND-
STUDENTS- AND BECAUSE OF YOUR
MISSION OF THOSE STUDENTS WILL
BE PUT IN SOME SORT OF A JOB IT
WILL LEAD TO SOME SORT OF A JOB
OF PAID YOU KNOW WHATEVER
WHATEVER IT IS. HOW DO YOU
EXPECT TO GET FROM WHERE YOU'RE
AT NOW WHERE YOU HAVE NONE. TO
THAT LEVEL IF THAT'S THE
PROMISE THAT YOU'RE MAKING. OF
BOTH TO US AND TO THE PUBLIC
AND TO- PEOPLE WHO ARE LOOKING
FOR CAREER BY THE WAY I HOPE
NOT. DON'T SEE THIS AS A CAREER
AT END UP IN WALMART I DON'T
SEE THAT AS A CAREER. BUT YOU
KNOW A REAL CAREER. WELL ED DO
YOU KNOW WE HAVE JUST STARTED
WE LITERALLY- DIDN'T EVEN START
ACCEPTING- STUDENTS UNTIL
OCTOBER FIRST- WE ARE- TESTING
A LOT OF DIFFERENT SYSTEMS AND
NEW COURSES AND- AND ALSO
EXPERIMENTING WITH WRAPAROUND
SERVICES TUTORING COUNSELLING-
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN ONLINE
ACCESSIBILITY FOR THAT- AND WE
EXPECT TO LEARN QUITE A BIT
THAT'S GOING TO ENABLE US TO.
YOU TO BE- MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE-
WHEN WE BRING IN OUR NEXT WAVE
OF STUDENTS AND WE BELIEVE
THAT- THAT IF WE GET IT RIGHT
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO ATTRACT-
THAT MANY- STUDENTS INTO INTO
THESE AND OTHER COURSES THAT
WOULD BE ADDING- NEXT YEAR. AND
THAT- AS EMPLOYERS SEE THAT
THIS IS A PUBLIC IN A WELL
MAINTAINED WELL MAINTAINED WELL
CREDENTIALED ORGANIZATION THAT
THAT THEY'LL WANT TO PARTNER
WITH US WE THINK WE'VE MADE
SOME REAL PROGRESS- WE HAVE A
TEAM THAT'S OUT THERE TALKING.
I'VE TALKED OVER A HUNDRED
EMPLOYERS SO FAR. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WILL BE ABLE TO-
TO- CREATE PARTNERSHIPS OF THEM
OR WEAKENED WHERE THEY CAN DO-
OUR OUR STUDENTS AS THEY FINISH
THEIR- CREDENTIALS CAN DO- IT
CAN DO ON THE JOB TRAINING. AND
THEN ULTIMATELY LEADING INTO
INTO FULL TIME JOBS I MEAN
WE'VE GOT OBVIOUSLY SOME SOME
MORE THINGS TO DO BUT BUT I
CAN'T STRESS ENOUGH THAT WE'RE
JUST IN THE VERY VERY EARLY
STAGES OF THIS I MEAN LITERALLY
I MEAN TO GET A- A- A WHOLE NEW
ENTERPRISE UP AND RUNNING FROM.
YOU KNOW FROM YOU KNOW IN SIX
OR SEVEN MONTHS IS IT IS REALLY
A BIG CHALLENGE BUT IT BUT
WE'RE PLEASED THAT WE'VE GOT.
WE'RE LEARNING FROM THEM AND-
AND WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
EVERYTHING WE HAVE TO ENSURE
THAT THEY OBTAIN. THE ULTIMATE
EMPLOYMENT THE END OF THE ROAD
THAT THEY'VE BEEN- THAT THEY'RE
THERE FOR. YEAH I JUST FINALLY-
ON THE ON THE ISSUE THAT I'VE I
KNOW WITH. SENATOR ROTH IS
ALREADY KIND OF ALREADY PRETTY
MUCH **** BUT- I STILL DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO HAVE A
SEPARATE ENTITY. A I UNDERSTAND
THE DIFFERENT EDUCATIONAL
MODEL- AND YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT'S A GOOD THING TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT LEVEL OF. A
CERTIFICATE AND THEN THE
DEGREES. BUT WHY IT HAS TO BE A
SEPARATE ENTITY- THAT PART I
DON'T UNDERSTAND BECAUSE- OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE MADE FOR
WORKING PEOPLE. THEY ARE MADE
FOR MEN AND WOMEN YOUNGER OLDER
DOESN'T MATTER- I CAN BE IN A
ROOM FULL OF PEOPLE DOESN'T
MATTER WHERE WHO THEY ARE. YOU
ASK HIM. DID YOU EVER TAKE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE COURSE SOME
OF THEM. GRADUATED WITH A
DEGREEMOST OF THEM DIDN'T
BECAUSE THEY USED IT TO ENHANCE
THEIR SKILL. SO I'VE ALWAYS
SAYING. COMEY CALLED AS A REAL
SWORD CALLED BY COLOR BUT REAL
WORKINGCLASS. AT BASICALLY
BECAUSE- IT'S SO CHEAPER. THAN
THAN THE YOU KNOW FOUR YEAR. ON
ALL CALL. SO OF. I DON'T ICE.
DO GET. WHY THERE HAVE TO BE.
AN T. I'M SURE WHAT. COLLEGES
AN UNCERTAIN RULES THAT THIS
KIND OF LIKE THE A CHARTER
SCHOOL YOU KNOW AND WE DIDN'T
ASK AND EXPECT ON IN THAT WHOLE
DEBATE OUT WE USED IT TO SAY
HEY LET'S BE INNOVATIVE. CELLS
LIKE IT'S TRYING TO DO LET'S BE
INNOVATIVE LET'S FIND A
DIFFERENT WAY REACHING ARE
WORKING CLASS ON COMMUNITIES
WHICH I THINK IS GREAT I THINK
IT'S GREAT THAT YOU EVEN
BROUGHT THAT UP. BUT OF THE
DOESN'T YET TO ME JUSTIFY
HAVING A SEPARATE ENTITY- AND A
SEPARATE GOVERNING A SYSTEM OF
IT'S JUST NOT. CLICKING UP AND
I KNOW THAT YOU JUST STARTED
BUT THIS IS A COMMITMENT. YOU
KNOW THESE ARE COMMITMENTS THAT
YOU MADE- AND IT'S NOT QUITE
CLEAR YET FOR EXAMPLE HI GOING
TO GET ALL THOSE EMPLOYERS WELL
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN UP FRONT
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN PART OF
THE INITIAL DEAL UP FRONT BUT-
IT MAYBE YOU COULD JUST ADDRESS
THAT CONCERN. I'M NOT. YES NO
NO I THINK THOSE ARE IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS SENATOR PARTICULARLY.
YOU KNOW PARTICULARLY THE WORD
USED TO DESCRIBE WHAT THIS
LOOKS LIKE TO YOU- IN TERMS OF
A CHARTER LET ME BE VERY CLEAR
AND TRANSPARENT WE ARE IN NO
WAY SHAPE OR FORM INTERESTED IN
CREATING A CHARTER COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THIS ENTITY WAS CREATED
SPECIFICALLY IN THIS WAY SO
THAT IT WOULD BE. EXACTLY LIKE-
ONE OF OUR OTHER SEVENTY TWO
DISTRICTS. SUBJECT TO- ENSURING
THAT OUREMPLOYEES ARE
REPRESENTED. SUBJECT TO THE
SAME RULES UNDER TITLE FIVE IN
THE EDUCATION CODE AND THIS WAS
IN AND I TAKE THIS VERY
PERSONALLY BECAUSE THIS IS
SOMETHING A COMMITMENT I MADE
PERSONALLY TO OUR LABOR
PARTNERS CTA C. F. T. S. C. R.
U. C. S. C. A. ON ON DOWN THE
LINE. I MADE VERY CLEAR AND I
THINK GOVERNOR BROWN AND
CERTAINLY GOVERNOR NEWSOME ALL
ARE COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT
THIS DOES NOT LOOK LIKE A
CHARTER COMMUNITY COLLEGE IT IS
A DIFFERENT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ABSOLUTELY. THE REASON WE FELT
IT NEEDED TO BE A SEPARATE
ENTITIES BECAUSE IT IS
DIFFERENT BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO
NEED TO ESTABLISH A NEW
BARGAINING UNIT AGREEMENT THAT
HAS VERY DIFFERENT. WHY ROLES
IN. ROLES IT WILL SET A
BLUEPRINT FOR HOW TO DO THIS IN
IN OTHER DISTRICTS IT WILL SET-
GIVE US AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
QUICKLY- DEVELOP TECHNOLOGY
THAT CAN BE EASILY SHARED WITH
OTHER COLLEGES THAT IS THE
INTENT IN AND IF THAT INTENT
HAS NOT BEEN MADE CLEAR. IN THE
FIRST FEW MONTHS I CAN ASSURE
YOU THAT IS FROM THE INTENT
THAT WE IN THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE EXPECT. TO CALIBRATE BUT
I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT IT WILL
WHILE IT WILL BE DIFFERENT WELL
IT WILL DO DIFFERENT THINGS
AND- OF MORE CALIFORNIANS. WE
EXPECTED TO ACT LIKE A CAT.
WHICH IN I COULD ADD JUST A
COUPLE THINGS IN ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION. TO YOU KNOW WHEN
WRITTEN IN THE THAT IT NEEDS TO
BE A- ENTITY IS BECAUSE IT IS.
THE GOING STATE. AND THE OTHER-
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE
DISTRICTS THAT THEY ARE THAT
THEY OF BOUNDARIES AND THIS IS
THIS IS INTO THIS ENABLES US
TO- INTERACT DIRECTLY WITH
STATEWIDE EMPLOYERS AND AS A AS
I SAID EARLIER WE- WE HOPE TO
BE ABLE TO. IF WE IDENTIFY
EMPLOYERS ARE LOOKING FOR
WORKERS THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
HAVE THE OTHER COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THATARE TRAINING
WORKERS OF SIMILAR SKILLS TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE THOSE THOSE JOBS.
AND ALSO IN TERMS OF COMPETING
FOR STUDENTS WE ACTUALLY THINK
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE TRACKING.
STUDENTS THAT MIGHT THAT
COULDN'T WOULDN'T FIND THEIR
WAY TO A REGULAR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE A BRICK AND MORTAR
COLLEGE IN THAT. IF THEY IF
THEY- FIND US IN A AND THEY'RE
ABLE TO. GET GET ACCUSTOMED TO
GOING BACK TO SCHOOL AND TO AND
LEARNING AND LEARNING THINGS TO
HELP THEM MOVE UP THE LADDER
THAT THEY- MIGHT BE INTERESTED.
IN GETTING A DEGREE AND WE'RE
DELIGHTED TO HAVE FOR THOSE
STUDENTS- INTO A PIPELINE TODAY
TO THEIR LOCAL ANY COLLEGE. AND
THE LAST REASON IS THAT IT
NEEDS TO BE SEPARATE IT'S
REALLY A VERY FOCUSED-
ORGANIZATION. CAN THEY CAN TAKE
CHANCES EXPERIMENT LEARN NEW
THINGS- AND- AND THEN. AS A
MASTER AT THE- THE TECHNIQUES
WE CAN SHARE THAT WITH ALL THE
OTHER COLLEGES THAT- YOU KNOW
WE ARE PART OF THE SYSTEM A
HUNDRED FIFTEEN AS I SAID I. I
OVERSEE BOTH AND I YOU KNOW I
AM ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED OUR
WHOLE BOARD IS THAT. THE
CALVARY WILL CONTRIBUTE TO THE
TO THE WELL BEING ALL THE COULD
BECAUSE OF. I BOTH SEMI IT BILL
LEARNING THAT BE THE CHIEF WELL
IT BY. BEING IN. WHY FIGURE IT.
CAN'T MAKE IT IN. A ROW TO
COMMUTE. AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I WANT TO SAY HER FOR
THE PRESS X. DO WHAT FOR UP ON
LAST FROM SAN DRAWS FIRST AND
THEN I HAVE OTHER AS WELL SO.
THIS ISSUE ABOUT THREE A
SEPARATE ENTITY AND A AND THE
MAY BE A OF WHAT SOME QUESTION
LOMA POWERFUL BUT I DO HAVE A-
BECAUSE THE WAY IT'S STRUCTURED.
AND NOW IT'S CONCERNS FOR PASS
BUT YOU KNOW GOVERNOR THAT WAY.
IS THAT THIS ENTITY THIS NEW
COLLEGE WOULD BE DIRECTLY UNDER
THE GOVERNANCE OF THE STATE
WIDE ME COLLEGE TOWARD. WHICH I
PRESUME MAYBE A PRISON WRONG I
THOUGHT HAD CERTAINLY ENOUGH
WORK TO DO TO OVER SELL TO DO
THE GUIDANCE CORNY BETWEEN ALL
THE OTHER COMMITTEE COLLEGE
WITH THEIR ON THE PEDAL BOARDS
AND DISTRICTS. SO CAN YOU SPEAK
TO SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THIS
AND WE YOU KNOW WE ARE HEARING
ABOUT THIS WITHOUT SOME CHANGES
IN LEADERSHIP AT CETERA. WHAT
PROPORTION OF TIME IS OUR STATE
WIDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARDS
SPENDING ON THIS ONE ENTITY.
VERSUS OVERSEEING THE ROOM YOU
KNOW OUR ACTION OVERSEEING THE
RIGHT WORD BECAUSE THEY ARE
DEAL DIFFERENT DISTRICTS BUT-
DOING THEIR- WORK TO DATE ALSO
BEEN CHARGED TO DO TO
COORDINATE BETWEEN ALL THE
OTHER ENTITIES- SO. BECAUSE
THIS IS DIRECTLY UNDER THE
STATEWIDE SO- CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THE- AMOUNT OF WORK THAT THIS
IS. BEING NOW PUT ON THE STATE
WHAT HE SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON
THE STATE AND NOT JUST ON ONE
SPECIFIC COLLEGE. WELL I FEEL
THE PAIN OF THIS. BECAUSE I DO
HAVE TO CONFESS I'VE SPENT AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF TIME ON ON
CALIBRATE- OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS- IT YOU KNOW AS
A START UP IN AND- WITH THE
LEADERSHIP CHANGE IT'S IT HAS.
IT HAS BEEN TIME CONSUMING BUT-
AND IT FALLS I THINK MUCH MORE
ON ME THAN ANY OTHER MEMBER THE
BORE WE HAVE FORMED AN
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE A
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE BOARD TO-
TO OVERSEE CALIBRATE ON ON A
MONTHLY BASIS- THE FULL BOARD
DOES MEET EVERY. EVERY TWO
MONTHS- I CAN SAY UNEQUIVOCALLY
IT HASN'T INTERFERED WITH THE
GOVERNANCE. TIME IT MAY BE
SPENDING MORE TIME THAN I
WANTED TO BUT IN THIS BUT- BUT
I HAVEN'T SEEN WITH OUR OUR
VICE PRESIDENT WHO'S IN THE
AUDIENCE TODAY TO AND WHO AND
SHE AND I HAVE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME BUT- BUT- WE ARE. YOU KNOW
I THINK OF ANYTHING IT'S BEEN
HELPFUL FOR ME TO BE ON THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES OF AN
INDIVIDUAL COLLEGE. IN AN X. ME
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW WHAT THE
OTHER COLLEGES ARE ARE ARE ARE
ALSO THINKING ABOUT AND I'VE
ALSO THOUGH IT JUST TO SEE YOU
KNOW I'VE- I'VE MADE A REAL
EFFORT I'VE BEEN TO. THE
COLLEGES I'VE BEEN ALL OVER THE
STATE I'VE MET WITH ALL THE
LEADERSHIP STUDENTS THE FACT TO
THE CLASSIFIED STAFF EVERYONE.
AND SO I YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
IT'S AN OFFICIAL FOR US TO BE.
SERVICE MORTGAGE STEVE ONE
COLLEGE. ST I'M AYE AYE DON'T
ANY OF THE- BIRTH YOU THEY HAVE.
LIKE THE IN ANY WAY THE UP
THERE A STEWARD OF THE OF ALL
THE UNIQUE. WELL FIVE. THAT I
APPRECIATE PEOPLE'S FEELINGS.
MAYBE I WAS WRONG ABOUT THE
BOARD BEING BUSY BEFORE- BUT I.
ONLY I'M- ABOUT. THE YEAH ON
THE OVERSIGHT OF THIS THE OTHER
THING IS YOU KNOW HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP BUT THIS ONE
COLLEGE STAND OTHER ONE AND HOW
THAT MIGHT IF YOUR TO MAKING I
THINK IS A YOU KNOW A
GOVERNMENT'S CONCERN SO I
THINK- SO- SO I JUST WANT TO
PUT THAT OUT THERE FIND OUT THE
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE- AND I
THINK WE TENANTS EQUITY BOND
SENATOR. THE NEXT PERSON AND
ENDS AND I WOULD CERTAINLY YEAH
YOU. TO HAVEYOU RESPOND. SO I
MEAN I THINK THAT'S I MEAN IT'S
SOMETHING THAT. I THINK IS
IMPORTANT TO MONITOR- AND BUT I
DO HAVE AT HAND BEFORE I STILL
HAVE AN ACTUALLY THE MORE I
HEAR ABOUT YOU KNOW THIS THIS
IS GOING ON. THAT CONCERN IS
ACTUALLY GROWN. ABOUT THE BUT
YOU SHOULD BETWEEN THE
STATEWIDE BOARD AND ONE
PARTICULAR COLLEGE VERSES THE
REP THEIR REMAINING NOW THE
OTHER. PARTS OF THE SYSTEM AS
WELL SO- TO CHANCELLOR PLEASE
I. CUT YOU OFF BUT- IT IS QUITE
RIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME I'LL BE BRIEF- I
UNDERSTAND- BUT THE CONCERN
YOU'RE DESCRIBING THAT WAS
CERTAINLY APPOINTED DISCUSSION
WHEN CAL BRIGHT WAS ACTUALLY
CREATED. IN STATUTE JETS OR A
COUPLE OF THINGS AND- NOT TO
DEBATE THE ISSUE BUT JUST TO
BRING OUT WHAT WHAT WAS
DISCUSSED INITIALLY. WHAT IS.
THAT THERE WAS- A REAL
DESCRIPTION BETWEEN LEGAL
COUNSEL'S BOTH FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. AS WELL AS INTERACTION
WITH SOME OF OUR- LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS ABOUT WHAT WOULD
BE THE PREFERRED. THERE WAS
DEBATE WHAT WOULD THE MODEL SO
THIS. THIS CREATION WAS A
COMPRA. THE TIME WITH ALL THE
CONSTITUENT GROUPS ABOUT WHAT
WOULD BE THE BEST MULLIN A
MODEL THAT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD DIRECTLY INTERACT WITH-
ONGOING. THE SECOND IS. NOT
UNLIKE THE UC IN THE C. ISSUES
BOARDS- OF THEIR **** TO
CONTINUOUSLY OVERSEE OTHER
ENTITIES SO FOR EXAMPLE MY OWN
EXPERIENCE IN THE UC- THEY
OVERSEE THE NATIONAL LABS THEY
OVERSEE A NUMBER OF OTHER
ENTITIES OR SEPARATELY
INCORPORATED- AND IT DOES
REQUIRE A LOT OF TIME- SO. THE
STRUCTURE IS. ULTIMATELY UNIQUE
BUT I DO I DO APPRECIATE. THAT
THIS HAS TAKEN A LOT OF TIME OF
THE BOARD MEMBERS ALSO IT IS
NOT UNUSUAL FOR THE BOARD OF
NURSING HAVE A SEPARATE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IT HAS A-
TIME. IN OVER. COME TO BECAUSE-
THE CITY PURCHASED OKAY BECAUSE.
IT PROVIDING TO OVERSIGHT FOR
OVER OF THE BROUGHT TO COME
BECAUSE- SO IT DOES HAVE THAT
EXPERIENCE ANY CAN CONTINUE TO
DO THAT WITHOUT HAVING A
CONFLICT. FOR THE OVERALL
HEALTH OF THE OF THE SYSTEM BUT
I DO BELIEVE IS A FAIR QUESTION
IT AND SOME THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD CONSIDER APPRECIATE I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT AT YOU SEE
WHICH WERE I WAS FORMALLY
FACULTY MEMBER. THE NATIONAL
LABS ARE DIFFERENT AND THE
INDIVIDUAL EDUCATIONAL CAMPUSES
SO YES I GET THAT BUT WHICH SO.
I'M NOT SURE. EXACTLY THE SAME
THIS IS A DESERT ADDITIONAL
EDUCATION INSTITUTION. VERSUS
THAT SO THAT'S IN. COMPETITIONS
RIGHT WORD BUT CERTAINLY. MAYBE
I ATTENTION THE DUPLICATION OF
THE OTHER ONES- AS AND WE WON'T
REHASH TO DUPLICATE AN ISSUE-
THE OTHER THE OTHER SO THE
OTHER QUESTION I HAVE- SEVEN
LISTEN CAREFULLY RAISING WILL
WHY THIS IS A SEPARATE COLLEGE.
RIGHT AND- SO ONE THAT AT ONE
POINT THAT WAS EMPHASIZED QUITE
A BIT. WAS AND I MESSAGES FOR
THE NEXT PANEL FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE TO ANSWER. IN TWO. WELL
THIS THAT YOU CAN DO YOUR OWN.
AT SO FORTH YOU KNOW THAT
DIDN'T HAVE TO HAVE A TIME AND
IT BUT I STILL DON'T QUITE
UNDERSTAND WHY A YOU HAVE TO
CREATE A WHOLE SEPARATE COLLEGE
BILL DO THIS WHY CAN'T THE
EXISTING COLLEGES DO THAT IS
THAT SEEMS TO BE THE MAIN
ARGUMENT. AS TO WHY WE NEED TO
HAVE A SEPARATE COLLEGE AND
HAVE SEPARATE COURSES BECAUSE-
WE CAN'T WORK ON A COMMITTEE ON
A SEMESTER SYSTEM AND PEOPLE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO UNDER OWN
PACE. AND THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE. AND MAYBE I MISUNDERSTAND
AND SOME OUT BARRIER TO. MY
COURSES BE DONE THROUGH OUR
OTHER. COLLEGES SO THAT WE HAVE
TO CREATE A WHOLE SEPARATE
COLLEGES TO DO THAT. IT'S A
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGY IT'S A
DIFFERENT CURRICULUM- IT'S- IT
IT REQUIRES DIFFERENT CONTRACTS
WITH- WITH FACULTY BECAUSE
THEY'D BE TEACHING SO I JUST
THE BECAUSE AND I APOLOGIZE-
BUT JUST AS WE GET TO THE POINT
SO USING THE FACULTY REFUSING
TO DO THIS- I'M I'M NOT SAYING
THAT I'M JUST. SAYING WHAT
DISTINGUISHES. YOU KNOW IT AND
WHY IT'S DIFFERENT THE AND
ALSO. YOU KNOW IT DOES IT'S A
FAST CHANGING FIELD IT GIVES US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO EXPERIMENT IN
A IN A WHOLLY FOCUSED WAY WITH
IT WITH MINISTRATION IT'S- YOU
KNOW LEADERSHIP OF THE COLLEGE
FOCUSED ON. ALL THOSE AT THE-
AN ABLE TO A- REACHED STATEWIDE
CAN EMPLOYERS. AND STUDENTS IN
A IN A WAY THAT A THAT A LOCAL
DISTRICT IT WOULD HAVE MORE
MUCH MORE DIFFICULTY. AND HE
THE- END IT IS A IN A IS A-
FOR THE STUDENTS THAN THAN WHAT
MOST COMMUNITY COLLEGES- OFFER
TODAY. ALL RIGHT IT'S OKAY I
GOT YOU.GOT THAT BUT I JUST
WONDERED WE NEED TO HAVE A
WHOLE SEPARATE COLLEGE FOR THAT
SO. BECAUSE WE'RE SPENDING A
LOT OF TIME IN I MEAN. THE
EFFORT AND WE CAN SEE THIS
REPORT HOW MANY YEARS IS GOING
TO TAKE ITS AT OUR- AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE HAD A
HUNDRED MILLION AND ALLEN
TWENTY MILLION EVERY YEAR- AND-
AT NIGHT I GUESS. I'M STILL
LIKE IT SO. I STILL UNDERSTAND
WHY. EXISTING PROGRAMS CAN'T DO
THE SAME THING- THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAVE IS THAT- AND I
KNOW THAT THERE'S YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO PREPARE.
FOR JOBS BUT WHAT I HEARD
YOU'RE SAYING ALTHOUGH IT. IN
THE REPORT I SEEM TO GET SOME
EXPRESS IT IS. THE PART OF THIS
COLLEGE. NOT THE GROUP. IT'S
REALLY ABOUT THE CERTIFICATE
THAT YOU CAN GET SO WE'RE NOT
LOOKING A FULL DEGREES SO.
ALTHOUGH I THOUGHT THERE WAS
SOME GOAL TO ESTABLISH DEGREES
SO THAT SEEMS TO BE ALONE
CONFLICT HERE- THAT THIS WAS A
WHILE THE REST OF THE COLLEGES
OF FOLKS SOME PEOPLE GETTING
THEIR DEGREES ARE ALTHOUGH WE
DO KNOW THAT MANY OF ACTUALLY
MANY PEOPLE GO TO THEIR LOCAL
COMMITTEE COLLEGE NOT FOR
DEGREES BUT- OKAY. THAT THEY'RE
MORE FOCUSED DEGREES THIS ONE'S
MORE ABOUT CERTIFICATE. AND IN
MANY WAYS I GUESS THE
CLARIFICATION IS THAT IT'S NOT
SO MUCH I MEAN MAYBE THEY'LL
HELP THEM GET A NEW JOB.
BECAUSE YOU TALK ABOUT THIS FOR
PEOPLE ARE WORKING A READY. I
ASSUME THIS WOULD PERHAPS BE
MORE FOCUSED ON HELP PEOPLE
HAVE FIGURE SKILL SETS FOR
PROMOTIONS THAT MAKE THEIR
MEASURE THAT AND SAYING BECAUSE
THREE WORKING RIGHT NOW THEY
COULD BE PREPARING FOR A NEW
CAREER THAT'S- WHAT AND- SO I'M
JUST TRYING TO CALL. IS THIS.
GET TO THE ENTERING YOU FEEL
THEIR TREE OR IS THIS ASSERTIVE
TO THAT'LL YOU TO PROGRESS
WITHIN YOUR OWN CAREER THAT
PERHAPS YOU CAN'T BECAUSE WELL
THEY SAY WE NEED ANOTHER
CERTIFICATE OR SOMETHING ELSE
IN ORDER FOR YOU TO BE OF THE
ADVANCE PROMOTED OR WHATEVER
ELSE SO- SO I'M JUST IT IS ON
THIS YEAR'S TALKING ABOUT IT. I
WON'T BE SURE WERE USING THE
RIGHT METRIC TO MEASURE WHAT IS
SIXTY THE SUCCESS OF THESE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS ARE
PROPOSING- BECAUSE IF IT'S-
YEAH. IT TIME TO WRAP YOU CAN.
ANSWER THAT ALL ANSWERED FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF. WHY WE
CREATED THIS AND WHAT WERE THE
EXPECTATIONS LAID OUT ON DAY
ONE- ONE- THIS IS NOT ABOUT A
CASUAL IN AN OUT TO DETERMINE
TO GET SOME CERTIFICATE THAT
ALLOWS YOU. TO GET- A BETTER
WAGE IF YOU'RE ALREADY LEARNT
EARNING A GOOD WAGE THIS IS
ABOUT A GROUP OF CALIFORNIANS-
THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND BY
THIS ECONOMY A GROUP OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE NOT
ALWAYS ABLE TO ACTUALLY I JUST
THAT I'VE HEARD THAT WE THIRDS
OF THE MULTIPLE TIMES CAN YOU
JUST GET TO THE POINT SO WHO IS
IT FOR. EXAMPLE I MEAN WE ARE
ARE THIS POPULATION WHAT IS
GOING TO CHANGE FOR THEM FORGOT
THIS COP VERSUS BUT STATE OR
LOCAL COLLEGE WILL. IS AT ONE
VETERAN ONE OF SUCCESS. IS
MOBILITY IS WAGE GAIN THAT IS
UNLIKE ANY OTHER HUNDRED
FOURTEEN COLLEGES ALL RIGHT SO
I APPRECIATE YOU SAYING THAT SO
I HOPE FOR MEASURING THAT YES
OKAY SO THAT'S GONNA ELECTRIC
IS WAGE GAME OKAY NOW
APPRECIATE THAT AND THEN-
BECAUSE I THE ONE SOME CLARITY
THERE RIGHT BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING. SO AND SO WE SHOULD BE
COMPARED IT TO WAIT IN A FEW GO
TO IT RIGHT COMMUTER REGULAR OF
THIS SHOULD X. THE WAIT PEOPLE
GO TO THIS COLLEGE. SHOULD
EXCEED THE WAGE GAIN OF PEOPLE
GO TO TRADITIONAL COMMITTEE
COLLEGE THAT SHOULD BE THE
METRIC. THE METRIC SHOULD BE
PEOPLE WHO ARE. AT OR BELOW
LIVABLE WAGES TO SAYS GIVE HIM
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR INCREASED
ECONOMIC MOBILITY. BECAUSE THEY
MAY NOT HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN
ABLE TO ACCESS OR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT SHOULD BE THE
METRIC IN MY ESTIMATION I GUESS
THE ONE OTHER COMMON IN AND NO
I MADE IT- YEARS AGO IN THIS
CAME UP IS THAT. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT SO WHEN YOU'RE
PATHWAYS WELL IT'S TOUGH TO
BILLING CODING IT'S NOT REALLY
HEALTH CARE- IT'S THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PART. BUT AS
SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN INVOLVED IN
THE HEALTH PROFESSIONS
EDUCATION AND- AND WE THINK
ABOUT LOT OF THE OTHER
EDUCATION WHEN THE CONCERNS
AGAIN IS THAT. WE SER THINK
ABOUT EVERYTHING BEING ONLINE
BUT A LOT OF THE- CAREER WHERE
YOU HAVE AN OP. FOR PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING TO ENTRY. LEVEL IS A IN
AND THAT'S AND HEALTH CARE
OTHER PLACE DO REQUIRE SOME
KIND OF. HANDS ON AT SOME POINT
GREAT I MEAN YOU YOU I MEAN
IT'S GREAT YOU CAN. DO THINGS
ON THE COMPUTER AND MAYBE
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS YOU CAN
DO ON THE COMPUTER BUT SOME
POINT YOU MAY ACTUALLY HAVE TO.
DEMONSTRATE SOME PROFICIENCY
HANNAH AND ARE YOU CAN READ
ABOUT IN THE BOOK BUT
EVENTUALLY SHOW YOU CAN DO IT.
AND THE AND SO AND APPRECIATE
THAT NOW CREATE A COLLEGE THAT
HAS TO HAVE RELATIONSHIPS AND
SHOULD HAVE RELATIONSHIPS OF
THE SIX THE PUT THE EXISTING.
VISUAL IDEAS BUT IT SEEMS TO BE
A BIT OF A DUPLICATION ALSO
THAT BECAUSE OF THE THINGS THAT
ONE ADVANTAGES. DO PROMOTING
ONLINE IT. THROUGH EXISTING
STRUCTURE IS THAT. PROBABLY NOT
ALL THERE MAYBE IF YOU EAT ICE
LEAGUE SAMPLES BUT A LOT OF
LEARNING. PROBABLY SHOULD BE A
BLAND RIGHT WE WANT TO TREAT
THE CONVENIENCE AND- PACING AND
SO FORTH AVAILABLE THROUGH. AN
ONLINE MECHANISM BUT ALSO- IT.
AND DEAL AGAIN BM BUT I'D BE
INTERESTED IN HEARING WHAT THE
CUT CONVERSATIONS OVER THE
PLAYERS- THEY ALSO PROBABLY
WANT SOME POINT THEM
DEMONSTRATION THAT THE PERSON
CASH DO SOMETHING. BEYOND JUST
WHAT THEY CAN DO ON A COMPUTER.
AND HOW YOU GONNA DO THAT
LINKAGE SO THAT YOU CAN HAVE
THE KIND OF CERTIFICATES THAT
PLAYER'S VALUE AND- THEREFORE.
AGAIN THAT'S ABOUT. GETTING
PEOPLE MORE. THE LADY PROPERTY
THE END FOR. AT M. YES. ONE
THINGS WERE. THE CITY IS BRING
OUT MORE PATHWAYS SO FOR.
ESPECIALLY WHEN ARE LESS. ABOUT
JUST DOING STUFF ON THE
COMPUTER. IT'S GOING TO BE. YOU
KNOW HOW DO YOU INCORPORATE.
THIS THE TOWN'S UP. AND OF NOT
JUST YET. ABOUT SO OF ELEVATION
THAT MAY BE NECESSARY IN ORDER
TO CONVINCE AN EMPLOYER JUST.
GET OF THE- AND AT LEAST TO THE.
TALK BUT- SO THAT'S MY THAN. I
DO AGREE WITH YOU CENTER I
THINK THAT IS SO A QUESTION
THAT ONE WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THE SKILLS THAT. WORKERS
LEARNERS ARE CHAIN UP TO A
ALLOW THEM ACCESS INTO OTHER
JOBS THAT IS A VERY VALID
QUESTION AND I THINK IT'S ABOUT
A QUESTION ABOUT THE MODEL THE
CALIBRATE WILL BE USING. OKAY
THANK YOU THE SHARING OF WE
INTERRUPTED YOUR LINE OF
QUESTIONING WHICH I VERY MUCH
SUPPORT. THAT'S OKAY SEVEN.
PROBABLY DESERVE TO BE
INTERRUPTED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE I APOLOGIZE IF
SO MY **** QUESTIONS ARE
DUPLICATIVE THIS JOB REQUIRES
US TO SOMETIMES DO TWO THINGS
HOW TO CLONE MYSELF SO. WE'RE
GONNA ON THAT. I HAVE A NUMBER
OF QUESTIONS I THINK THIS MAY
HAVE BEEN ELSE BUT I WOULD LIKE
SOME CLARIFICATION. CAN YOU
EXPLAIN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
CAL RIGHTS COMPETENCY BASED
EDUCATION MODEL. AND
TRADITIONAL ONLINE. COURSES FOR
EDUCATION AT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. A COMPETENCY BASED
MODEL TO CALIBRATE IS USING-
BASICALLY ALLOWS A STUDENT TO-
START AND STOP AT ANYTIME
YOU'RE NOT BOUND BY A SEMESTER
OR QUARTER CALENDAR- IT'S- IT
IS ALSO YOU PROGRESS AT YOUR
OWN PACE AND YOU AFTER YOU'VE-
ABSORBED A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
MATERIAL YOU YOU SHOW THAT
YOU'VE MASTERED THAT COMMON SEE
THEN YOU MOVE UP TO THE- NEXT
LEVEL. I'M AND IT'S DIFFERENT
THAN THE WAY THAT TO THE MOST
TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
COURSES ARE TAUGHT EVEN THE
ONLINE COURSES- GENERAL NEED TO
BE TAUGHT THAT WAY. THE AS I
SAID YOUR OUT OF THE ROOM HOPE
IS THAT BY CALIBRATE LEARNING
THE BEST METHODOLOGY FOR DOING
THIS THAT THEY WILL THEN BE
ABLE TO SHARE THAT- THAT THAT
LOT KNOWLEDGE WITH THE OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THEY CAN
BEGIN TO OFFER. SIMILAR KINDS
OF COURSES THAT CAPITALIZE ON
THE ON THE FACULTY AND THE AND
THE STUDENT. BODY THAT THEY
TRACKED. AT THE PACE I CAN GO
FOUND IF I HAVE TIME I CAN GO
SLOWER IF I NEED MORE TIME.
YEAH AND THEY NEVER HAVE TO GO
TO A BRICK AND MORTAR COLLEGE
AND- AND IT ALSO IS- IS
TARGETED AT SPECIFIC JOBS- THE
NOTION OF CALIBRATED THAT WE'RE
GONNA WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
EMPLOYERS TO MAKE SURE. THAT
WHATEVER TRAINING WE'RE
OFFERING WHATEVER SKILL
BUILDING WE'RE OFFERING IS- IS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO JOBS THAT
EMPLOYERS ARE LOOKING TO FILL.
I THINK. SO I HAVE YOU SET FOR
THE I'M NOT A FAN OF ON.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT HE
INTERACTION INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT BUT I ALSO HAVE. THAT
WE LIVE IN IT PRINT PAGE THEN
WHEN I WENT COOL BEEN WORK. UP
HERE WE- NONE OF THE- MEAL OR
OF US HAVE I DON'T THINK ANY OF
US HERE HAVE LAID OFF OUR JOB.
FOR SELECT YES. YEAH FOR THEM.
I THINK THE YOU KNOW DO HAVE
SOME CRITICS OF HELP MOOD FOR
BUT I DO DON'T WANT US TO THROW
OUT THE BABY WITH THE BATH
WATER AND WE HAVE TO I THINK IF
IT MEETS STUDENTS WHERE THEIR
NEEDS ARE AND IF CALL ME IF I'M
WRONG GET THIS HANDY DANDY WILL
UPDATE THIS MORNING YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED AND TEN- INSTANT
RIPPLED CONTROLS AND- IT PULLED
A PROGRAM PATHWAYS. BACK YES IS
BETTER IN THE SENSE THE I. THAT
THEY WLL MOVE I GREAT INTO OF
THE PATH ABSOLUTELY NO I
TOTALLY GET THAT MY QUESTION IS
WERE ANY OF THESE STE AND IN A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SETTING
BEFORE THEY CAME TO CAL BRIGHT.
I'M AFRAID I DON'T THE ANSWER
TO THAT- WE CAN GET THAT FOR
YOU MY UNDERSTANDING WAS NOW.
IS THAT THESE ARE ALL STUDENTS
THAT WEREN'T DOING ANYTHING AND
TELL THE AND ROLLED AND CAL
BRIGHT SO FOR WHATEVER REASON
THIS APPEALED TO THE STUDENTS.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS AND THE AGES. IT'S
QUITE A VARIETY OF AGES AND
QUITE A VARIETY OF ETHNIC
BACKGROUNDS SO IT DOES SEEM
THAT IT'S SERVING A DIVERSE
POPULATION. SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE AND I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN SOME QUESTION ABOUT- YOU
KNOW THE ENROLLMENT NUMBERS.
BUT HE SAID IT NAM CITY AND YOU
JUST STARTED ROLLING STUDENTS
IN OCTOBER SO I THINK THAT.
IT'S STILL MIGHT FIND THIS THAT
WORKS FOR THEM. SO AS WE MOVE
FORWARD I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
WE AS A COMMITTEE AND AS THE
LEGISLATURE LOOKS AT. AT CAL
BRIGHT THAT WE CONSIDER
EVERYTHING- THAT WE CONSIDER
EVERYTHING SO THAT WE MAKE SURE
WE'RE TRYING TO. DO THE BEST WE
CAN FOR ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
MOVE UP ECONOMICALLY AND THAT
WE CAN'T LET. TRADITIONAL
COLLEGE GET IN THE WAY OF
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT BE NEW AND
HELPFUL TO OUR HARD TO REACH
STUDENTS AND I SEE THE STUDENTS
THAT ARE ENROLLED IN CALIBRATE
AS STUDENTS THAT HARD TO REACH-
AND THEN THERE WAS A QUESTION.
ABOUT WHY DON'T WE JUST DO THIS
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS-
I'VE HEARD SOME YOU KNOW THIS
IS THE A STATE WIDE PROGRAM SO
IT IS SET UP SEARCHABLE
DIFFERENTLY. BUT I GUESS I
WOULD SAY TO CHANCE KLAY DO YOU
THINK THAT CAN CALL US PART
BASED. ELL TO DELIVER. EAST
EDUCATION. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION LEYVA LET ME BEGIN
THAT ANSWER SAYING YOU WILL NOT
FIND A BIGGER CHAMPION OF THE
COMMUNITY CLLEGES THAN ME IS
THE REASON THAT I'M HERE- SO- I
BELIEVE THAT OUR COMMUNICATIVE
DO A TREMENDOUS JOB WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY HAVE THEY
SERVE MULTIPLE MISSIONS- AND SO
ARE THE EQUIPPED TO BEGIN TO
DELIVER COME BASED EDUCATION
PLACE. THIS BARB ANOTHER'S THAT
WE DO OFFER SOME TYPE OF
COMPANY BASED EDUCATION
PARTICULARLY FOR ENGLISH AS A
SECOND LANGUAGE. BUT THESE ARE
COURSES THAT ARE DONE VERY
DIFFERENTLY IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO SCALE THOSE COURSES AND VERY
DIFFICULT- TO PROVIDE A
STATEWIDE RESPONSE TO SOME OF
THE- CHANGES THAT WERE SEEN IT
IN THE ECONOMY- SO. I DO
BELIEVE THAT CAO BRIGHT WILL
HELP OUR COLLEGES BEGIN TO
INCREASE THEIR CAPACITY THEIR
KNOWLEDGE AND THEIR ABILITY TO
SERVE MORE STUDENTS UNDER THE
C. B. E. MODEL BUT IT'S SORT
OF. A CHICKEN AND THE EGG WE
NEED TO HATCH THIS EGG FIRST
AND LET. THE WORK BEGINS SO
THAT ALL OF OUR COLLEGES CAN
BENEFIT FROM. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU AND I AGREE I AM A HUGE
CHAMPION OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES-
MY ALMA MATER MOUNT SAC THE
PRESIDENT IS HERE TODAY I'M
EXCITED TO HEAR FROM HIM BUT
AGAIN I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE REACHING ALL
STUDENTS AND GIVING EVERYONE AN
ECONOMIC ACT OPPORTUNITY. SO
THOSE ARE ALL THE QUESTIONS I
HAVE NOW MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
BOTH FOR BEING HERE. WELL I
GUESS IT'S MY TIME AGAIN. YOU
KNOW I I'VE HEARD THE WORD
EXPERIMENT I WILL POINT OUT
THAT THIS IS A MIGHTY PRICEY
EXPERIMENT AT A HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS AND GOING
UP AND I GET THE FEELING THAT
WE'VE SORT OF PUT THE CART
BEFORE THE HORSE HERE AND THEY
WERE FEELING OUR WAY ALONG IN
THE HOPE THAT THE EMPLOYER.
COMMUNITY WILL COME ALONG AND
THAT WE WILL FIND SUCH A
STUDENT POPULATION ON A
STATEWIDE ASIS SOMEHOW WITH AN
INSTITUTION THAT'S- WHETHER
YOU'RE A BRICK OR MORTAR NOT
CEMENTED IN OAKLAND AND IS NOT
IN HIM IT'S APPLE VALLEY PERRIS
RIVERSIDE SAN DIEGO CHULA
VISTA. OR ANYWHERE NEAR
IMPERIAL COUNTY. AND THEN ONE
OF THE COMMON I HAVE I WANT TO
MAKE AND THEN I WANT TO ASK
SOME QUESTIONS. YOU KNOW. IT
COULD BE ARGUED HERE THAT IN
LISTENING TO THIS IS THAT. THIS
IS A MIGHTY POWERFUL
CONDEMNATION OF OUR EXISTING.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM THAT
THE SYSTEM IN THE INDIVIDUAL
COLLEGES AND DISTRICTS THAT
FORMAT. ARE SIMPLY NOT FLEXIBLE
ENOUGH TO RESPOND TO CHANGES IN
TECHNOLOGY. OR CHANGES IN THE
EMPLOYER COMMUNITY. SUCH THAT
WE NEED TO CREATE A SEPARATE
STANDALONE INSTITUTION TO DO SO.
THAT'S NOT A QUESTION BUT THAT
TO COME AND AT SOME POINT YOU
BE CERTAIN FREE TO RESPOND TO
IT BUT- I THINK THAT'S A
CONCERN THAT MY COLLEAGUE
REFERENCE TO TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED STUDENTS
TO PROJECT. TO HAVE ENROLLED IN.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
TWENTY SIX. QUESTION WHAT'S THE
PROJECTION BASED ON. I'M AFRAID
I DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION-
AT MY FINGER TIPS AND- BUT WE
CAN CERTAINLY GET THAT TO YOU
WHAT DO YOU KNOW WAS THERE A
SURVEY OF HIM AS THE ALL HAS TO
QUESTIONS TOLD THEY'RE ALL IN
LOSS COULD ONLY ASK ONE BUT ALL
IS GOOD COMPOUND QUESTION WHAT
IS A STATE WIDE MARKET FOR THIS.
AND HOW IT HOW WAS THAT STATE
WIDE MARKET. FIGURE DETERMINED.
WAS THERE A SURVEY OF EMPLOYERS
CONDUCTED THAT PRODUCED THE
PROJECTION OF TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED BECAUSE
IT WAS TWENTY TWO THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED NOT TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
AT NINETEEN THOUSAND AT TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND. IT WAS A NUMBER.
SO I WILL NOT SPEAK TO THE
TWENTY TWO THAT FOUR HUNDRED
BUT I WILL SPEAK TO THE
EMPLOYER PART OF THIS HOW WE
DETERMINE THE MARKET WHEN WE
INITIALLY CAME BEFORE YOU OF A
YEAR AND A HALF AGO THAT MARKET
WAS DETERMINED THROUGH
NUMEROUS- EMPLOYER ENGAGEMENTS
UP AND OWN THE STATE I BELIEVE
THERE WERE LIKE TEN FORUMS WITH
IN DIFFERENT REGIONS OF THE
STATE WITH DIFFERENT EMPLOYERS
EVERYTHING FROM HEALTH CARE TO
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING-
LOGISTICS. HEALTH CARE- WE ALSO
HAD ENGAGEMENTS WITH LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS THAT REPRESENT
MANY OF THOSE JOBS FOR EXAMPLE
WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME WITH. A
U. H. W. ABOUT THE HEALTH CARE
ISSUES. TO LEARN WHAT THEIR
NEEDS ARE WE WORK WITH THE
JOINT TRAINING CENTERS- BETWEEN
EMPLOYERS AND LABOR. SO THAT
INITIAL- AGE GROUP TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY FIVE I BELIEVE IT WAS AN
AROUND TWO POINT FOUR TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION STUDENTS WAS HOW
WE GOT TO THAT NUMBER- THAT IS
WHAT WE HEARD FROM EMPLOYERS.
THAT THAT IS- DEMOGRAPHIC OF
WORKERS THAT THEY FELT IS IN
NEED OF SOME. RAPID UPSCALING-
AND SO AS WELL AS WORKING WITH-
THE CHAMBERS AND PLACES LIKE
THE BAY AREA COUNCIL AND
OTHERS. THAT'S FOR THAT INITIAL
NUMBER CAME FROM- I WOULD HAVE
TO ASK THE CAL BRIGHT FOLKS HOW
THE- THEN PROJECTED OUT THEIR
ENROLLMENT TO TWENTY TWO THAT'S
FOUR HUNDRED I'M SURE. YOU'LL
HAVE A CHANCE TO ASK HIM. BUT
WILL ALSO LET ME AS THIS SO IN
YOUR ENGAGEMENT WITH THESE
UNNAMED EMPLOYERS DID YOU ASKED
HIM ARE ARE YOU ARE YOUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS IN
YOUR LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES-
PROVIDING THE SERVICE TO YOU
HAVE YOU CONNECTED WITH YOUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO ENGAGE IN THIS TYPE
OF. NEED THAT YOU'RE A DENTAL
CRYING AS PART OF OUR OUT REACH
PROGRAM ME WAS THERE ANY SORT
OF. BECAUSE I'LL BE HONEST WITH
YOU I HAVE YET TO HEAR THE NAME
OF A SINGLE EMPLOYER I HAVE
QUESTIONS DOWN BELOW THAT I'VE
NOTED. I WILL BE HAPPY TO GIVE
YOU SEVERAL NAMES OF EMPLOYERS
WELL I HAVE SOME. ON A- YES SO
WE GET THE- IS PRESENT QUESTION
DID YOU. YES A BETTER I DON'T I
BE A- I AND IT. HELLO ONE. TO
REACH EMPLOYERS AND COUNTIES IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT I
CAN'T THINK OF THE NAME I DON'T
GET IT AND WHAT I ALSO DON'T
GET IS HOW MUCH IT'S GOING TO
COST. TO MARKET THIS PROGRAM I
WOULD BET IT'S MORE THAN A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. HOW DO
YOU DO IT LET ME UNLESS YOU'RE
UNLESS OVER TALKING ABOUT. ARE
THE AMAZONS THE U. P. S. IS THE
FED EX'S. AND HAD A COUPLE MORE
TO THE STACK. WHO HAVE
CENTRALIZED HR OPERATIONS WHO
CAN PASS THE WORD DOWN TO THEIR
PLANT MANAGERS AND SAY SIGN UP
WITH CAL BRIGHT. LET ME LET ME
ASK FIRST ABOUT THE ERROR
RESPOND TO THE UP TO THE
OAKLAND- HEADQUARTERS THE AND I
DO WANT TO SAY THERE'S JUST-
THAT THE CALIBRATE STAFF IS
SCATTERED- STATEWIDE AND THEY
AND THEY DO A LOT OF THEIR WORK
VIRTUALLY AND THEY'RE AND
THEY'RE- YOU KNOW. HOW OAKLAND
IS THE OFFICIAL HEADQUARTERS
IT'S A WE WORK FACILITY SO IT'S
NOT PERMANENT- AND THAT- AND
THAT A LOT OF THE- A LOT OF
THE- WORKERS WORK REMOTELY AND
CONNECT USING USING TECHNOLOGY.
AND THAT'S FRANKLY HOW REACH
OUT TO STUDENT THROUGHOUT THE
WHOLE STATE YOU KNOW A LOT OF.
EVEN A LOT OF THE ARMS THAT
WE'RE THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
TRAINING BEFORE HE DONE
REMOTELY IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO- YOU
KNOW TO A LOCAL EMPLOYER AND
PROVIDE- WORKERS THERE'S SO
MANY WORKERS WHO NOW WORK
REMOTELY AT LEAST PART OF THE
TIME AND SO- PARTICULARLY IN
THE KIND OF JOBS THAT WERE
TRAINING PEOPLE. OR SO IT'S THE
END OF THE WHO I THINK IT IT
WILL BE ABLE REACH. YOU KNOW
STATEWIDE AND- USING IT BASED
MARKETING IS A LOT OF WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS TO A BILL IN
THE- IS. DOING MORE HANDS ON
WORKING WITH COMMUNITY GROUPS.
AND HAVE A- YOU KNOW WE'RE
THERE WAS A STE WORKFORCE THE-
A TRAIN PEOPLE THAT WOULD THERE
IS NO QUESTION THAT GOING TO
OUT TO. BE COOPER OF EIGHT.
NINE IN THAT. AND THAT WE THE-
THEIR AGE ONLINE IN THE DROPS
EVEN ON THE AFTER THEIR- PLEASE
THREE PROBE THAT YOU CURRENTLY
NO. CODE CYBERSECURITY AND I
TEASE. MAYBE IT WAS A THIRD BUT
CERTAIN. BLEW PAST ME FOR THESE
PRO SELECT. DID AMAZON SO THEY
NEED. EVEREST HERO SUPPORT AND
THEY NEED FOR HUNDRED AND OF
THE AND SO YOU FIGURE PRODUCE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SERVICES I
TISA BY DID DO. REGIONAL JOBS
AND JOB IS SAYS AND VERSION IN
THE STATE TO DID BECAUSE I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT THAT FIGURE
DOES NOT EXIST NLESS YOU DID
IT. DID YOU DO REGIONAL
ASSESSMENTS OF JOBS AND JOB
SKILLS BY REGION IN THE STATE
TO DETERMINE WHAT SPECIFIC JOBS
AND WHAT'S SPECIFIC SKILLS ARE
REQUIRED IN INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN THE NORTHERN PART OF
THE INLAND. OF INLAND
CALIFORNIA TO DETERMINE HOW TO
STRUCTURE YOUR PROGRAMS. THAT'S
A QUESTION OF THE FOLLOW UP
WOULD BE. IF NOT- WE SIMPLY
DESIGNING A PROGRAM AND HOPING
THAT THE JOBS COME. I THINK IF
IT WAS A LETTER SENATOR YOU
NEED TO CLOSE THIS THING THEM-
IF THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING
THEN THEN THAT'S NOT WHAT IT
WAS BUILT TO DO IT WAS BUILT TO
DO THE OPPOSITE. DID TO THE
FORMER WHICH IS TO CREATE
DIRECT PARTNERSHIPS THE REASON
THAT MEDICAL CODING IS WHERE IS
LISTED AS A PROGRAM. IS
SPECIFICALLY IN THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WERE HAD
WITH THE UNITED HEALTHCARE
WORKERS DIGNITY HEALTH AS WELL
AS AS SUTTER HEALTH. THAT
THAT'S WHERE THAT PROGRAM
PATHWAY CAME FROM AND IT WAS
INTRODUCED IN THIS ROOM IN
FRONT OF THE LEGISLATURE WHEN
ASKED. WHAT PROGRAM WOULD YOU
BEGIN ITH AND WHY AND SO- THIS
IS EITHER THE SAME WORKERS THAT
ARE NOW ACCESSING SIMILAR
EDUCATION FROM SALT LAKE CITY
THROUGH UNIVERSITY CALL WESTERN
GOVERNORS UNIVERSITY. AND IF
THE SALT LAKE CITY CAN REACH
CALIFORNIANS I'M SURE OAKLAND
TO REACH CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE
THEY ARE REACHING THEM NOW- AND
I ASSURE YOU THOSE FACULTY ARE
NEVER GOING TO BE ORGANIZED-
OPERATE FACULTY WILL- SO. THIS
IS NOT A CONDEMNATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND I KNOW YOU YOU MADE THAT
COMMENT THIS IS A CONDEMNATION
OF THE DAY THAT WE ARE THINKING
ABOUT THIS PROBLEM- A AND I
WERE LETTING OTHER INSTITUTIONS
PRIDED SALT FOR CALIFORNIA
THAT'S WHAT DROVE ME CRAZY BUT
BUT WE DON'T KNOW THAT THOSE
OF. PRINCE TO BE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME IN CRITICS IS NOT SOME OF
THAT THIS IS MY JUSTIFIED AND
PERHAPS ISN'T. DEPENDING ON THE
INSTITUTION IN THE- BUT- TO
SHOW. BUT WAS IS CHOSEN AT THE
OTHER BETTER NOW TIED TO JOB
BUT SOUL SO YEAH USES. DIGNITY
HEALTH NAY FOR MAY CODE PEOPLE
RIGHT DO WE THIS THING DOWN NO.
MEDICAL CODING IN OF ITS- WILL
SOON BE AUTUMN. AS WELL. BUT
MEDICAL CODING ALLOWS FOR MANY
WORKERS TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
THIS CANNOT BE A TERMINAL
CREDENTIAL IN ANY SHAPE OR FORM
OUR HOPE IS THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE NOT
PREVIOUSLY ACCESS CALIFORNIA
GIVE ME COLLEGES OR ANY HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTION. AS A WAY
NOW AN ENTRYLEVEL AN ON RAMP
TO THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IS SOON IS THAT
STUDENT IS COMPLETED THEIR
MEDICAL CODING. CERTIFICATION
YEAH I WOULD EXPECT THAT
CALIBRATE BEGIN TO HELP
STUDENTS UNDERSTAND WHAT ARE
THE CREDENTIALS THAT WILL ALLOW
YOU FURTHER ECONOMIC MOBILITY
WORKING WITH THE COLLEGES IN IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY TO CONNECT
THEM IF THEY'RE LIVING IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO HOLD OFF ON THAT
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT MANY
INSTITUTIONS. HAVE OF THE. THAT
THE ME THE DIFFERENCE HERE IS.
THE YOU HAVE A OPPORTUNITY TO
HOLD THE AND TWO ACCOUNT. TO
THOSE OUT FOR BOB WHAT WHAT
WOULDN'T ME AS ANOTHER SO. IN
THE ANNOUNCED IN THIS AND STUFF
THAT I READ TO GET PREPARED FOR
THIS SINCE I WASN'T REALLY. IN
THIS POSITION CERTAINLY IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. I BELIEVE
THERE'S A REQUIREMENT TO THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND
THE AND THE DVD DE DETERMINE
WHETHER THESE PROGRAMS THAT THE
ONLINE COLLEGE PROPOSES TO
OFFER OUR WATER THE WORDS HAVE
JOB MARKET VALUE TO CALIFORNIA
INDUSTRIES WAS THAT
DETERMINATION MADE IN ADVANCE
AND IF IT WAS WAS IT
MEMORIALIZED IN SOME FASHION.
I'M NOT AWARE THAT IT WAS
MEMORIALIZED BUT CERTAINLY AS
WE WENT AS ALL THREE PATHWAYS
WERE DEVELOPED THERE WAS DIRECT
COMMUNICATION AND IF A AND R.
AT SE IF YOU RECALL BUT AT THE
TIME- THE DIRECTOR OF THE
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT STATE
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARD DID
SYFY. BEFORE THIS BODY IT'S THE
EDUCATION CODE REQUIRES YES
THAT'S RIGHT AND I THINK THAT
WORKS A WISE MOVE- I DON'T KNOW
THAT T'S BEEN MEMORIALIZE
SINCE THAT TESTIMONY WHEN THESE
FIRST THREE PAF WHICH WERE
DEVELOPED BUT CERTAINLY I CAN
TO I CAN ASSURE YOU. THAT A-
THANK YOU BE IN CONTACT WITH
THE NEWS LABOR TO THE SUIT TO
IN THAT SHE GETS WHAT SHE NEEDS
AND HER ENTIRE ORGANIZATION
FROM CAL BRIGHT WHAT THEY NEED
NOW THEY ARE REORGANIZING-
THEIR AGENCY AND WE HAVE BEEN
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THAT AGENCY
AND I WOULD EXPECT THAT CAL
BRIGHT RESPOND TO AND WORK WITH
OF THAT AGENCY IS REQUIRED BY
EDUCATION CARP I MEAN I JUST
THE BUSINESS PLAN SEEMS. FLOOD
HERE. AND I SAID KERR BEFORE
THE HORSE FULLY BELIEVE CART
BEFORE THE HORSE TO ME WE HAVE
PROGRAMS. THE EDUCATION CODE
REQUIRES AN ANALYSIS BY THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND
EDIE ORGANIZATIONS ON JOB
MARKET. VALUE THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS THEMSELVES MY
PERSONAL OPINION HAVE ISSUES
BECAUSEWE DON'T HAVE ANY
REGIONAL JOB. SKILL JOB VACANCY
JOB NEED ANALYSIS IN THE STATE
IN ANY REGION ANYWHERE ANYTIME
AND THAT'S ESTABLISHED IN SOME
OF THE STATISTICS THAT ARE IN
SOME OF THE MATERIALS AND THEN
THE MILESTONE REPORT FOR
EXAMPLE I'VE GOT A QUESTION ON
ONE OF THOSE. SO I DID
SHOULDN'T THERE BE AN EVIDENCE
BASED DETERMINATION OF JOB
MARKET VALUE BEFORE WE SPEND A
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON PROGRAMS. I WOULDN'T
DISAGREE WITH THAT SENATOR. CAL
BRIGHT HAS TO WORK IN ALL OF
OUR COLLEGES HAVE TO WORK
WITHIN THE EXISTING NOW
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS. WHETHER IT'S
ET DE- DEPARTMENT OF LABOR-
THIS IS THE INFORMATION THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE WE ALSO WORK
WITH. OUR CENTERS OF EXCELLENCE
THAT PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT DATA WE
ALSO WORK WITH- THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF TREASURY WE WORK
WITH ORGANIZATIONS- THAT DO
THIS. OF FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- BUT I WOULD AGREE
WITH YOU THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT THE BEST-
IT IS OUR HOPE THAT THROUGH THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES
CAN INFORM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HOW TO IMPROVE THAT.
IT IS OUR IT IS IN OUR
STRATEGIC PLAN DIVISION FOR
SUCCESS THAT WE BEGIN TO
MEASURE ECONOMIC MOBILITY IN
TERMS OF WAGE GAIN IN TERMS OF
REGIONAL LIVABLE WAGES. THAT IS
WHAT WE WANT TO DO AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT NO OTHER SYSTEM
OF HIGHER EDUCATION DEBTS. IN
CALIFORNIA- BUT WE DO NEED THE
LEGISLATURE'S HELP IN THE
GOVERNOR'S HELP TO IMPROVE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE I WILL CERTAINLY
AGREED WE DON'T SEEM TO PAY A
LOT OF ATTENTION IN EDUCATION
TO. OF THE EXPECTATION OF OUR
CUSTOMER. AND IN THIS CASE
CUSTOMERS ARE STUDENT AND IN
MOST CASES WHAT THEY REALLY
WANT OUT OF THIS EXPERIENCE.
YOUR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. YOUR CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE BECAUSE SYSTEM ISSUE
YOU SEE A GOOD PAYING JOB AT
THE END OF THE DAY YES BUT BUT-
ENOUGH OF. WHAT I SEEM TO THINK
QUESTION. DOES CALIBRATE HAVE.
AGREEMENTS WITH EMPLOYERS FOR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS BECAUSE
I ASSUME AND YOU CAN INCLUDE
THIS IN THE RESPONSE. THAT THE
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE OR
WHATEVER IT IS STUDENTS ARE
CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN
CALIBRATED OF AN EXPECT X. AS
HAVE AN EXPECTATION AT THE END
OF THE PROCESS. THAT THEY WILL
MOVE INTO AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM AND THAT CERTAINLY IN
YOUR BUSINESS PLAN CORRECT IT
IS IN OUR BUSINESS PLAN WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY AGREEMENTS
CONSUMMATED YET THERE HAVE BEEN
A LOT OF- EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS WHERE- CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC THAT BY THE TIME
THIS THIS GROUP OF. STUDENTS IS
COMPLETED THAT WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ON THE JOB
TRAINING AND ULTIMATELY FULL
TIME JOBS. AND WE ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY TOWARD THAT WE HAVE
A TEAM THAT'S OUT THERE EVERY
DAY. HOW ABOUT- EMPLOYMENT IN
GENERAL DOES CAL BRIGHT HAVE
ANY AGREEMENTS WITH ANY
EMPLOYERS. IN CALIFORNIA TO
ACCEPT. STUDENTS WHO COMPLETE
THE KELP BRIGHT PROGRAM
ANYWHERE- THERE IN NO AGREEMENT
YET I MEAN IS THAT WE YOU KNOW
THAT I THINK I'M PLAYERS ARE
STILL. WATCHING TO SEE. HOW IT
PROGRESSES AND WE YOU KNOW I
ONLY HAVE A COUPLE HUNDRED
STUDENTS THAT ARE. IN THE
PIPELINE IN AND I THINK YOU HOW
NEW WE ARE THERE THE YOU KNOW
THERE CERTAINLY OBSERVE HOWARD.
BUT THEY EITHER ALSO EXCITED
ABOUT IT I MEAN THE FACT THAT
THAT THEY'VE BEEN WILLING TO
HAVE MULTIPLE MEETINGS WITH US
INDICATE THAT THEY THINK THAT
THERE'S- REAL POTENTIAL IN
CALIBRATION SEVERAL EMPLOYERS
HAVE SUBMITTED LETTERS TO THE
RECORD HERE TODAY SAYING THAT
WE THEY THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT- OF L'IMPORTANCE STEP
AS AS TO SEVERAL- EMPLOYER
ORGANIZATIONS VERY COUNCIL
ELLIE CHAMBERS SO. WE'RE YOU
KNOW WE'RE OPTIMISTIC THAT IF
WE CAN BEGIN TO SHOW- THAT- THE
STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING-
EXCELLENT TRAINING AND THAT-
SOME EMPLOYERS WILL BE ABLE TO
BE OUR OUR FIRST TO EXPERIMENT
WITH US I KNOW YOU. MAY BE
SHOULDN'T USE THE WORD
EXPERIMENT ANYMORE BUT- THE- TO
START WITH US AND RAN
EXPERIMENT. AND THE AND THEN
WILL YOU KNOW I AND IT'LL GROW
FROM THERE I MEAN I YOU KNOW
ITS- IT. IT IS. A BRAND NEW-
YOU KNOW ON AND- THE UNTESTED
ENTITY AND INK IN CALIFORNIA
BUT IT'S- IT'S A PUBLIC OPTION
AT AT LOW COST AND HIGH QUALITY
AND HIGH INTEGRITY- FOR- FOR
THE WORKERS OF. CALIFORNIA THAT
NEED THIS KIND OF HELP AND- AND
WE FEEL VERY COMMITTED TO THE
MISSION THAT THAT THIS IS- THIS
IS CREATING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE THAT MIGHT OTHERWISE NOT
HAVE THEM. WELL I HAVEN'T HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO READ THE
LETTERS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT INTO
THE RECORD BUT- HAVE HAVE OUR
STUDENTS IN CALIBRATED LED TO
BELIEVE THAT THE ROLE AT THE
BEEP. AND SHIPS OR JOBS OR- OR
BOTH AT THE END OF THE PLAN FOR
THEM. THEY BEEN. TELL THAT
THEIR THAT THERE BE TRAINED THE
FOR JOBS THAT EXIST AND THAT
WE'RE GONNA MAKE EVERY EFFORT
WE CAN TO- TO CONNECT THEM WITH
THOSE JOBS IN THAT WERE WORKING
DILIGENTLY EVERY DAY AND HAVE
HAD GOOD CONVERSATIONS WITH
EMPLOYERS THAT COULD- THEY
COULD BE THOUGH THE-
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM BUT WE
STILL WE STILL A FEW MONTHS- AS
I SAY WE JUST WE JUST START-
BUT WE'VE GOT YOU KNOW PROBABLY
TWO OR THREE MORE MONTHS TO
CLOSE SOME OF THESE THESE
ARRANGEMENTS. AND BE ABLE TO
GET THE- ON THE JOB TRAINING
YOU KNOW I THINK- THAT THE
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO NEED AND
THAT WILL HOPEFULLY LEAD TO A
FULL TIME JOB FOR THEM BUT I
WAS GOING TO QUESTION GIVEN THE
FACT THAT THIS IS COMPETENCY
BASED ASSESSMENT. IN A MOVE
PRETTY QUICKLY AND YOU HONOR
BUT TWO TO THREE MONTHS TIME.
HERE YEAH I MEAN BUT IT WOULD
NOT WE'RE STARTING FROM SCRATCH
I MEAN THESE. CONVERSE BEEN
GOING ON FOR THREE FOUR MONTHS.
YOU AND I'M SURE YOU UNDER.
IT'S A VERY CRITICISM THAT WE
LAUNCH SHOULD THE- FOR PROFIT
INDUSTRY. PUSHING PEOPLE OUT
WITH CERTIFICATES AND THEN AT
THE END OF THE DAY THEY DON'T
HAVE A JOB YEAH WE'RE
COMPLETELY DETERMINED FOR THAT
NOT TO HAPPEN IT'S A DIFF
TOTALLY DIFFERENT MODEL OUR
MODEL IS TO. IS TO HELP THE
STUDENTS SUCCEED AND THAT'S AND
WE HAVE. WE ALSO HAVE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO HELP THEM ONCE
THEY FINISH THEIR- THEIR THEIR
CERTIFICATE WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO OFFER THEM GUIDANCE
AND COUNSELING AND- AND
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY LAND. IN IN A
POSITION THAT WILL HELP THE
MOVE UP THE ECONOMIC LADDER.
AND MOVING INTO A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT AREA I WAS FASCINATED
WHEN I READ THE MILESTONE
REPORT THAT IT APPEARS THAT CAL
BY IS PROPOSING TO MOVE. SORT
OF OUTSIDE THE EDUCATIONAL
ARENA AND TO WHAT I WOULD
DESCRIBE AS THE- EMPLOYMENT
AGENCY STAFFING SERVICES.
MILIEU BY SERVING AS AN
EMPLOYER OF RECORD FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND- OTHER
LIABILITIES AND THEN CHARGING
JOB PLACEMENT FEES. FOR
STUDENTS WHO MOVE IN TO- THE
EMPLOYMENT. OPPORTUNITIES WE
CERTAINLY HOPE WERE ABLE TO
SECURE BY AGREEMENTS WITH
EMPLOYERS SOMEWHERE. WHAT WAS
THE REST OF FOR THAT IN. IS
THAT. WHAT WAS THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS WITH TO THE- A
DECISION I AM MOVING THE
DIRECTION. THAT WAS THAT WAS I
THINK A GOAL OF THE COLLEGE
UNDER A PRIOR LEADER I THINK
ARE FROM A BOARD PERSON WE WANT
TO- PROVIDE THE KIND OF SERVICE
THAT THAT EMPLOYERS WANT TO
NEED WE THINK IT MIGHT BE
DIFFERENT WITH EVERY EMPLOYER
WERE. NINETY TWO SEPARATING A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL FOR- FOR ALL
THE EMPLOYERS THAT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE AGREEMENTS WITH AND- THAT
WE ARE YOU KNOW BRINGING IN A
NEW LEADER TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT THOSE KIND OF ARRANGEMENTS
AND DETERMINE IF WE NEED TO
MAYBE- YOU KNOW OFFER A NUMBER
OF FLEXIBLE OPTIONS FOR
EMPLOYERS WHICH SHOULD BE MY
INSTINCT AND DIRECTION. IF I
CAN AT SENATOR THAT IS
SOMETHING WE DO NOW AS A MATTER
OF FACT- CAL THE FOUNDATION FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- HAS AN ARRANGEMENT
WITH MANY OF OUR COMPLETE
COLLEGES ACTS AS THE EMPLOYER
RECORD TO. THIS TO NAY FOR WORK
LEARNING IS NOT IN HERE IT BY
THE X. EMPLOYERS SOME HAVE OVER
THE COST. OF KNOWING THIS TO
OPERATE IN THIS AN. SO I THINK
IT SOMETHING THAT CAL BREAKING
LEAN ON AND WORK WITH
FOUNDATION WE ALREADY HAVE SOME
CA. IN THE CITY BUT BUT BY THE
WAY THE ARE THE- KERR STUDENTS
SERVING DOUBLE TO HIM. OF THE
IN. AND OF W. TWO IN OF YOU AND
WORK AND WORK. THEY ARE. THE
EMPLOYMENT OF THE FOUNDATION
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IT ALLOWS THEM TO BE
TO COVER THE COST OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION FOR THOSE STUDENT
WORKERS. ALLOWS THEM ACCESS TO
JOBS THAT THEY DIDN'T OTHERWISE
HAVE- SO THAT IS A MODEL THAT
WE CURRENTLY USE IN THOSE IN
THOSE STUDENT WORKERS ARE PAID
THROUGH. THE FOUNDATION NOW.
THE FOUNDATION CHARGES EMPLOYER.
FOR THE COSTS OF THOSE
EMPLOYEES BUT A CAR LABOR SING
WHAT'S BECAUSE RELEASING. THAT
YOU HAVING SERVICES YES
ALTHOUGH YOU KNOW FOR US WE
WANT EVERY OPPORTUNITY FOR
STUDENTS TO GAIN ACCESS TO SOME
SORT OF WORKPLACE LEARNING AND
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU SENATOR
BOTH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WELL FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PARTICULAR HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
CUT FUNDING. FOR WORKPLACE-
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
OF OUR EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
SO WE HAVE TO FIND CREATIVE
WAYS TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS CAN GET. INTO
INTERNSHIPS AND BE PAID
INTERNSHIPS- WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
SOME SORT OF WAGE. I SUPPOSE
THAT'S A SUBJECT FOR A
DIFFERENT HEARING IN. I HAVE
ALL SORTS OF QUESTIONS ON HOW
YOU DEAL WITH WORKPLACE SAFETY
AND ALLOF THE OBLIGATIONS OF
THE W. TO EMPLOYER WOULD HAVE
INS HAVING EMPLOYEES IN
SOMEBODY ELSE'S WORKPLACE BUT-
THAT'S PERHAPS FOR ANOTHER
COMMITTEE. MY REPORT I ALSO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A
LOOK AT ONE POINT I THINK IT'S
ON PAGE TWENTY NINE SITES TO
LIST OF OCCUPATIONAL
QUALIFICATIONS IN A CATEGORY
LABELED ANNUAL OPENINGS AND
IT'S A LIST AND JUST I WAS JUST
LOOKING AT THE FIRST ONE AND
WAS COMPUTER USERS SUPPORT
SPECIALIST AND INDICATES ANNUAL
OPENINGS IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN OF SEVENTY NINE
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND SIX.
AND MY QUESTIONS IS I LOOKED AT
THIS. PRICE ONE I ASSUME THIS
IS IN CALIFORNIA DOESN'T SAY.
BUT WHO WHO MADE THE
DETERMINATION AND ON WHAT BASIS
WAS THE DETERMINATION MADE THAT
THERE WOULD BE SEVENTY NINE
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND SIX
OPENINGS FOR COMPUTER USERS
SUPPORT SPECIALISTS. IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN IN WHAT INDUSTRIES
AND WHAT REGION'S. WE GET BACK
TO ON THAT. ABSOLUTELY BUT I
COULD TELL YOU SENATOR THAT YOU
KNOW THROUGH THE GENEROUS
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATURE WE
FIND WHAT WE CALL CENTERS OF
EXCELLENCE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT LOOKS AT
PARTICULAR INDUSTRIES AND
DETERMINES THE AMOUNT OF JOB
OPENINGS FOR PARTICULAR
INDUSTRIES THIS IS FUNDED TO
THE STRONG WORK FORCE
INITIATIVE. SO WHILE I DON'T
HAVE DIRECT KNOWLEDGE EXACTLY
WHERE THAT NUMBER CAME FROM WE
DO HAVE ACCESS TO THAT DATA NOW
THAT THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
FUNDS THROUGH STRONG WORKFORCE
INITIATIVE AND THAT DRIVES MANY
OF THE- DISCUSSIONS AND-
DETERMINATIONS AND HOW TO USE A
STRONG WORK FORCE DOLLARS
BECAUSE WE ARE TRYING TO RELY.
ON DATA IN ADDITION TO
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS- ARE CENTERS OF
EXCELLENCE TO PROVIDE OUR
SYSTEM DATA SPECIFICALLY IN JOB
CATEGORIES. AND I HAVE ISSUES
THE DATA COLLECTION GENERALLY
IN THE STATE IS YOU KNOW SO I
WON'T BELABOR THAT LET ME
RETURN TO THE DECISION TO.
ESTABLISHED A SEPARATE COLLAGEN
AND MY UNDERSTANDING FROM
READING YOUR REPORTS WAS THERE
WERE FOUR OPTIONS AND ARE NO
SUSPECT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THAT THERE WERE FOUR
OPTIONS THAT WERE CONSIDERED.
CREATE THE ONLINE PROGRAM ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS WITHIN AN
EXISTING COMMUNITY COLLEGE ONE
OF THEM. TO CREATE THE PROGRAM
IS A CONSORTIUM OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PRESUMABLY THOSE THAT
WERE ACTIVE IN THE ONLINE
EDUCATION. ARENA HOSTED BY ONE.
THREE THE ONE THAT WAS SELECTED
CREATE A NEW COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT TO DO SO FOR CREE TO
PROGRAM WITHIN THE EXISTING
ONLINE EDUCATION INITIATIVE.
AND OF COURSE NUMBER THREE WAS
SELECTED BUT WHY. WHY WAS THE
DECISION MADE. TO NOT USE THE
CONSORTIUM APPROACH WHICH WAS
OPTION TWO. OR TO CREATE THE
PROGRAM INSIDE OF THE EXISTING
ONLINE EDUCATION INITIATIVE
GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
THAT WE HAVE DIRECTED AND
CONTINUE TO DIRECTED INCREASED
RATE TO THAT WE I EFFORTS. SO
THERE WERE SEVERAL REASONS-
AND- THERE WAS A LOT OF
DISCUSSION- ONE WITHIN- YEAH ON
A YEAH I IS NOT. AN END TO SEE
PER SE IT IS- A FUNDED
ORGANIZATION UNDER THE AUSPICES
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANGES OFFICE AS WELL
AS CONNECTED TO THE FORT HILL
THE ANSWER COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. THAT IS TRYING TO
AGGREGATE. THE DIFFERENT
ONLINE- LEARNING OPPORTUNITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND BEGIN
TO PULL THEM TOGETHER SO THEY
DON'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
TO PROVIDE- THE BACK OFFICE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNANCE- DEVELOP
OUR UNION AGREEMENTS THAT WOULD
BE NEEDED SO THAT'S WHY
COULDN'T EXIST UNDER YEAH
BECAUSE- YEAH I ITSELF DOESN'T
GOVERN ITSELF IT IS GOVERNED-
IN AT LEAST TWO DIFFERENT WAYS
UNDER FOR HEALTHY ANSWERED ME
BECAUSE DISTRICT AND THE
CHANCES OFFICE WE HAVE THE SAME
PROBLEM WITH THE NEW ONLINE.
OPERATION WE HAD TO ESTABLISH A
GOVERNANCE MODEL WE HAVE HAD TO
GO TO YES A DIFFERENT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT TO. TO ACQUIRE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO DO PAYROLL TO
HAVE POLICIES- IN A VARIETY OF
OTHER THINGS RIGHT ACTUALLY NO
THE SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY
COMMITTEE COLLEGES DOES NOT
PROVIDE ANY OF THAT- THE WHEN
CAL BRIGHT WITH ESTABLISHA
UTILIZED THE FOUNDATION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
TO PROVIDE THE BACK OFFICE
SUPPORT DIRECTLY UNTIL WHAT IS
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SO THE REASON OUR
POLICIES FROM SOUTHERN COUNTY
RIGHT THE REASON THAT- IN
STATUTE WE WERE REQUIRED IF YOU
READ THE STATURE REQUIRES A
CHANCE OR TWO TABLETS ANIMAL
YOU. LOCAL DISTRICT. THE
RELEASE FOR THAT WAS TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS A LOCAL DISTRICT
HAS LISTING BURKE UNIT SINCE
THAT. AND WHEN. UBER. HERE'S
FOR. CLASS STAFF BEFORE THEY
THEM OR- ALLOWS THEM AT THIS TO
A EXISTING. UNIT AS WELL AS PER.
A NEW. AVENUE TO BEGIN TO WORK.
WITH THE COMMUNITY DISTRICT- TO
SHARE- INFORMATION- WHAT CAL
BREDS DOING TO CREATE PROGRAMS
ALIGNED DIRECTLY- SO THAT WAS
THE INITIAL REASON WHY- IN
STATUE WERE **** TO SET UP THAT
ARRANGEMENT AS WELL AS- THERE
WAS A VERY IMPORTANT DISCUSSION
IT WAS HAD AT THE TIME THE WAY
THAT'S THE SAME. AS MY POINT
ISN'T IT YOU HAVE WE HAVE TO DO
THIS FOR THE ON LINE IF THERE
WERE ADJUSTMENTS THAT NEED TO
BE MADE IN THE ONLINE EDUCATION
INITIATIVE. BUT THE ONLY
EDUCATION INITIATIVE HAS NO
EMPLOYEES OTHER THAN A CORE
STAFF- THOSE EMPLOYEES THOSE
FACULTY OF THE FACULTY OF THE
OTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGES HELP
RIGHT DIDN'T EITHER UNTIL WE
YES. RIGHT MY POINT THE OTHER
POINT IN IS A VERY IMPORTANT
POINT AND YOU KNOW- I CANNOT
SPEAK FOR THE BERMAN
ADMINISTRATION BUT THERE WAS A
LOT OF NEGOTIATION. WITH MANY
OF THE LABOR ORGANIZATION SINCE
CAL AND IT'S INCORRECT HIGHER
TO ENSURE THAT CAL I JUST LOOK
LIKE A CHARTER. UP ANOTHER
DISTRICT. IN THE DIRECT DIRE
ENSURE THAT THE CAL BRIGHT
BOARD REPRESENTED STATEWIDE-
INTERESTS AND THAT WAS
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION TO A
LEGISLATURE. THAT WAS A BIG
DRIVER OF WHY WAS STATUS WE
QUITE FRANKLY YOU KNOW I COULD
HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT A LOT OF
OTHER. THINGS TO DO A LOT. FOR
THAT. BUT IS A IT BUT TO SOME.
GOVERNOR BUT THERE WAS A LOT OF
BEING CONCERNED. THAT. LOOK.
PREVAILING ISSUES AS TO WHY WAS
ESTABLISHES WAY WHAT GIVEN THE
FACT THEY WERE ALMOST TWO YEARS
DOWNSTREAM IN GIVEN ALL THAT
HAS HAPPENED- WOULD YOU MAKE
THE SAME DECISION OR MAKE THE
SAME RECOMMENDATION TODAY IN
TERMS OF THE STRUCTURE. OUR I
WOULD. AGREE AS OPPOSED TO
OPTION ONE TWO OR FOUR I THINK.
I THINK WE PICKED THE RIGHT
OPTION IF I WAS TO DO THIS
DIFFERENTLY I THINK THERE WOULD
BE MORE CLARITY AND WHAT THAT
OPTION LOOKS LIKE AND WHAT THE
EXPECTATIONS ARE AND HOW THEY
SHOULD BE ORGANIZED AND IS
THERE A TIME LINE- TO GO TO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT BUT- IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO IMAGINE HOW
THIS COULD HAVE BEEN. DONE AND
HOW YOU SELECTED DISTRICT- HOW
DO YOU MANAGE TO COMPETING-
BARGAINING UNIT AGREEMENTS THAT
WOULD NEED TO BE CREATED- HI
YOU DEVELOP. THE
INFRASTRUCTURES QUICKLY IS A
HAVE- I MEAN ONE IMPORTANT
ELEMENT HERE IS FOR EXAMPLE. OF
ALMOST ALL OF OUR COLLEGES ARE
UNDER THE LEARNING MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM CALLED CANVAS. IN CANVAS
IS A STATE WIDE THAT YOU
LEGISLATURE OF CALIBRATE COULD
NOT. ALTHOUGH THEY TRIED HAS
NOT BEEN ABLE TO OPERATE UNDER
THE CAL CAMPUS MODEL BECAUSE
CANVASES NOT PROVIDE- THE TOOLS
NECESSARY TO DELIVER COUNTY
BASED EDUCATION FOR THIS ALLOWS
CALIBRATE WHAT'S THAT MEAN
BECAUSE IS A LEARNING
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM UP LATER I
KNOW THE LEARNING MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM. IS WHAT THE BASICALLY
THE SHELL THE STUDENTS OPERATE
IN. TO RECEIVE INSTRUCTION AND
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR COURSES
SO WE HAVE GENERALLY- 98% OF
OUR COLLEGES OPERATE UNDER ONE
LEARNING MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
CALLED CAN THAT THE COMPANY-
AND SO THAT WAS A GREAT A GREAT
ACHIEVEMENT- FOR COMPANY BASED
EDUCATION- WHO. STUDENTS HAVE
TO OPERATE IN A DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENT ONE THAT IS OPEN
ACCESS ONE THAT DOESN'T HAVE A
TRADITIONAL ACADEMIC CALENDAR
CAMPUS COULD NOT AT THAT TIME
PROVIDE CAL BRIGHT WITH THAT
MODIFICATION BUT HAS COMMITTED
TO TRY TO DO THAT FOR THIS
STORM. SO THIS ALLOWS CAO
BRIGHT TO WORK WITH OTHER
LEARNING MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS
HELP BETTER INFORM CANVAS OF
THE CHANGES THAT ARE GONNA NEED
TO BE MADE FOR GOING TO SCALE
THIS- STATEWIDE SO THIS PUSH
AND PULL IS AN IMPORTANT
ELEMENT OF WHY IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR CAL BRIGHT TO BE OPERATING
IN THIS WAY BECAUSE- NOW WE
HAVE. FACT FACULTY AND STAFF
SOLELY DEDICATED TO TRYING TO
SOLVE THIS ISSUE AROUND HOW TO
BEST DELIVER SCALABLE COMES
BASED EDUCATION- SO I REALIZE.
IT'S A COMPLICATED WEB OF
DIFFERENT REASONS. BUT
ULTIMATELY- AGAIN IF I WAS TO
DO THIS OVER AGAIN- I THINK I
WOULD ASK FOR MORE TIME FOR
CALIBRATE TO ESTABLISH ITSELF.
MORE TIME FOR IT TO. DEVELOP
PROGRAMS- AND MORE TIME TO
DETERMINE ITS WAY FOR
ACCREDITATION BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK RIGHT NOW- ACC JC THE
REGIONAL CREDITOR FOR
CALIFORNIA IS RIGHT A CREDITOR
FOR CALIBRATED- BUT THAT WAS
THE DESIRE OF THE LEGISLATURE
AT THE TIME. SO THAT WAS. WHAT
WE RESPONDED TO WELL UNDER THE
STANDARD YOU DON'T EVEN QUALIFY
FOR ACCREDITATION UNDER THAT.
NOT UNLESS CAL RIGHT DEVELOP AN
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE AND OTHER
THAN ALWAYS A POINT OF DEBATE.
YES AT LEAST ONE. NOW ACC JC IS
LOOKING AT CHANGING SOME OF ITS
STANDARDS AND WE WILL WORK WITH
THEM. AS IT AGAINST YOUR CREDIT
MORE MORE CBA CB INSTITUTIONS-
BUT THAT'S IT'S AN ISSUE FOR
ANOTHER DAY FOR NOW THERE IS AN
ACCREDITING. A COMMITTEE. THAT
COULD CREDIT RIGHT SHOWING I
THINK THEY'RE THEY'RE- SO IT
THE LEAD I HAVE ONE OTHER
QUESTION FINAL. ONE IS GOING TO
BE FINE IF. YOUR THING IN. ONE
YES WE BE IF THIS LAW. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE A MINISTRY
DECIDED TO PIVOT AWAY FROM THE
CURRENT MODEL. OPTION THREE TO
A CONSORTIUM OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HEAVILY INVOLVED IN
ONLINE EDUCATION WITH THE
INSTRUCTION AND OF COURSE THE
FUNDING THAT GOES ALONG WITH
THAT TO. INSURE THAT THE ONLINE
OFFERINGS. OUR OPEN ACCESS OR
COMPETENCY BASED WITH DIRECT
ASSESSMENT AT LEAST A CERTAIN
PORTION OF THEM AT LEAST THREE
OF THEM. THAT THE OFFERINGS BE
MARKETED. STATE WIDE THROUGH
VARIOUS ONLINE PLATFORMS THAT
EITHER ARE ALREADY AVAILABLE TO
THE CONSORTIUM. THROUGH THEIR
OWN INDIVIDUAL EFFORTS OR ARE
DEVELOPED AGAIN WITH FUNDING.
WHAT DIFFICULTY WITH THAT. IN
TALE FOR THE SYSTEM AT THIS
POINT. WELL. AGAIN YOU KNOW- I
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT THE MODEL
CHOSEN WHAT'S THE BEST GIVEN
THE CHOICES AVAILABLE CERTAINLY
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION S. CHANCES
OFFICE TO BUT WE WILL DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S SUCCESSFUL THE
CHALLENGE WITH THE MODEL IS
THAT- DISTRICTS ARE GOVERNED
LOCALLY- THEY HAVE COMPETING
INTERESTS- AND THEY HAVE A
MYRIAD OF MISSIONS THAT THEY'RE
ALREADY TRYING TO FULFILL- THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY CAN'T DO
IT I BELIEVE IT WOULD JUST TAKE
MUCH MORE TIME. TO BUILD THE
CAPACITY NECESSARY TO SERVE AT
SCALE THE WORKERS THAT WERE
TALKING ABOUT- AND SO IT'S ALSO
VERY DIFFICULT- YOU DETERMINE
WHO ARE WHO ARE THE DISTRICTS
BEST POSITION TO DO THIS
BECAUSE WE HAVE MANY DISTRICT
THEY'RE DOING PARTS OF THIS I
DO BELIEVE THAT IS SIMPLE FOR
COPYRIGHT TWO IS BUSH FOR LACK
OF A BETTER TERM AN INNOVATION
ALLIANCE WITH CALLED THAT YOU
JUST DESCRIBED. TO SHARE IN THE-
CREATION OF THE CONTENT IN THE
DIRECTION OF CAL BRIGHT AND I
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS STILL
POSSIBLE- AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE
CALIBRATE TO FORM THAT. KIND OF
INNOVATION ALLIANCE WITH
COLLEGES AND I BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE COLLEGES TODAY THAT
WOULD BE WILLING TO DO THAT.
ONE FINAL QUESTION I'M SURE
YOU'RE TIRED OF ME. THE
IMPLEMENTING A BE FOR THIS
WHOLE PROCESS- RECORD THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE YOUR
OFFICE. IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
BY JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY
NINETEEN TO RECOMMEND TO THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS. WAYS OF
MAKING ONLINE AND COMPETENCY
BASED PROGRAMS EASIER AND MORE
ATTRACTIVE FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO DEVELOP AND OPERATE
INCLUDING WAYS TO STREAMLINE
THE PROCESS SEES FOR ONE.
FUNDING NONCREDIT COMPETENCY
BASED PROGRAMS AND TO OFFERING
ON LINE COURSES UNDER A
FLEXIBLE CALENDAR THE VERY
THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT. THAT GO TO THE CORE OF
CALIBRATE AND THE VERY ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN USED TO
DISTINGUISH CALIBRATE FROM.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I ASSUME
THAT YOUR OFFICE DID THAT AND
CONTINUES TO DO THAT- WE ARE
HAVE WE HAVE A VERY DELIBERATE
TO PROCESS IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGES WE ARE
WORKING WITH OUR STATEWIDE
ACADEMIC SENATE THROUGH THE
COMMITTEES THAT ARE.
APPROPRIATE TO THIS ISSUE TO
DEVELOP TITLE FIVE REGULATIONS
THAT WOULD ALLOW. ALL OF OUR
COLLEGES AWAY TO OFFER COUNTY
BASED EDUCATION TO CONSIDER THE
CHALLENGES TO THE CURRENT
CALENDAR TO CONSIDER MANY OF
THE OTHER CHALLENGES SO THAT IS
HAPPENING NOW. AND WE FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL WORKING
WITH THE STATEWIDE ACADEMICS
AND BE ABLE TO DELIVER A SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS AND THIS GOES TO AN
EARLIER POINT I MADE AND SORT
OF MY- CONFUSION ONE AND
CONCERNED AND WE DON'T LOOK
ORGANIZED. IT AND THIS IS SORT
OF A RHETORICAL QUESTION BUT
I'LL LET YOU RESPOND TO IF
THERE IS A QUESTION SOMEWHERE
IN THERE BUT IF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS OR OR IN FACT
ABLE TO OFFER NON CREDIT
COMPETENCY BASED. PROGRAMS AND
THEY DO START OF FLEXIBLE THIS
OPEN ACCESS WITHOUT TERMS THAT
ARE. BEGINNING AND AN END. THEN
WHY PARALLEL TRACK THIS PROCESS
AS WITH BROUGHT. TO DO EXACTLY
THE SAME THING. SO CENTER I
THINK THAT THAT IS A FAIR
QUESTION AND A CRITICAL
QUESTION. IN A QUESTION WE
DON'T REALLY SPEND A LOT OF
TIME TALKING ABOUT- BECAUSE ON
ONE HAND AS YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER IT'S ALMOST COMES
ACROSS AS A CONDEMNATION OF THE
CURRENT SYSTEM AND I CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT MY COMMENTS COME
ACROSS AS A CONDEMNATION. MY
COMMENTS ARE. YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
DE UM. STATES IN A
COMMUNICATIVE TRICK HAS SEVERAL
COLLEGES TO DO WONDERFUL WORK
TO TRY AND SERVE THE NEEDS OF
THE GREATER FRESNO AREA. BUT
THEY ARE LOOKING TO ADD ONE
MORE COLLEGE THE REASON IS NOT
BECAUSE THE OTHER COLLEGES.
CAN'T SERVE STUDENTS WHO MADERA
IS BECAUSE THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS
IN MADERA THAT WOULD BE BEST
SERVED BY A COLLEGE SOLELY
FOCUSED ON THE NEEDS OF THAT
COMMUNITY. AND SO THIS IS A
MECHANIS THAT WE'VE USED TO
GROW INTO THE CAPACITY THAT WE
HAVE. AND SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WHILE WE CAN
ARGUE AS TO WHY WE BELIEVE THAT
THESE THIS GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
AN BE ANSWERED BY A CURRENT
CAPACITY- I THINK. THAT HAVE
BEEN A GROUP OF FACULTY AND
STAFF SOLELY DEDICATED. TO
SERVICING THEM NOT AS A BY
PRODUCT OR IS A SUB MISSION OF
ANOTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUT
THE SOLE MISSION OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND THEN BE ABLE TO
OFFER. ON RAMPS TO OTHER
COMMITTEE CALLS ACROSS THE
STATE I THINK IS THE BETTER
ANSWER BECAUSE I WILL ONLY
SPEAK FROM MY EXPERIENCE OF
LONG BEACH CITY COLLEGE MY
PREVIOUS COLLEGE- WE HAVE A
VERY HAD. THEY STILL HAVE A
VERY ROBUST. NON CREDIT
PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY IN
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE
THEY TRAINED. THOUSANDS OF
REFUGEES PARTICULAR FROM
CAMBODIA AND FROM VIETNAM THAT
CAME OVER AFTER THE VIETNAM WAR
THEY DID AN AMAZING JOB. THAT
IS A LOCAL MEET. WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT NOW FOR
CALIBRATED SO SKILLED STATEWIDE
NEED IN A RAPIDLY CHANGING
ENVIRONMENT. EVEN IF WE SCRATCH
THE SURFACE OF THE NUMBER THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO AND A
HALF MILLION A MILLION WHATEVER
EVEN IF WE TOOK 2% OF THAT THAT
IS STILL A HUGE INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT WE
WOULD NEED TO SERVE. A SO
THAT'S WHY I THINK IT IS BEST
TO CREATE AN ENTITY SOLELY
FOCUSED ON THAT AND CAN BE
CLEARLY ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
MEASURABLE OUTCOMES THAT WE
EXPECT FROM IT WHEN YOU BURY IT
FOR BLACK OF A BETTER TERM IN
ANOTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGE. CAN
BE VERY DIFFICULT TO TEASE OUT
OUTCOMES AT SPECIFIC CHARGE.
ELEVEN ANY QUESTION FINAL
QUESTIONS ARE CLOSING REMARKS
BEFORE I CLOSE AT THE PANEL
THANK YOU. FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT I THINK THAT'S VERY
FORWARD THINKING THAT WE ARE.
WE NEED TO DO THIS AND SCALE IT
STATE WIDE AND THAT WAS KIND OF
GOES TO THE POINT I WAS TRYING
TO MAKE IT MAYBE DIDN'T DO A
GOOD JOB OF IT. IS THAT WE NEED
TO THINK DIFFERENTLY THE YOU
KNOW THOSE OF US HER MAKING
THESE DECISIONS. WE DIDN'T GO
TO SCHOOL WE DIDN'T GO TO
COLLEGE LIKE MANY OF THESE
LEARNERS NEED TO GO TO COLLEGE.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION- ABOUT THE
PRESS TENT AND THE PRESIDENT
WHO'S NO LONGER AT CAL BRIGHT.
I MY UNDERSTANDING IS HER
SALARY WAS ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND IS THAT
ACCURATE. THAT'S CORRECT. OKAY
SO I WOULD JUST LIKE TO ASK.
THAT IS. DO NOT BE SOMEONE ELSE
THAT KIND OF MONEY. IF THE
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA MAKES
TWO HUNDRED AND TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND I WOULD SAY HE IS A
PRETTY BIG IT'S STRESSFUL. UP
DON'T KNOW THE ONE RUNNING
PROGRAM TO MAKE UNDER NINETY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PAID WITH
TAXPAYER MONEY. MY OWN PERSONAL
VIEW. THE LEAGUE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND- I JUST HAVE ONE
FINAL QUESTION- RELATED TO
ACTUALLY AND ANSWERS GIVEN TO
SOME OF THE- SIR ROTS QUESTION
SO- SO WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- THE GRADUATES ARE AT
THAT THE OTHER STUDENTS IN THE
ONLINE COLLEGE YOU TALKED
ABOUT- BECAUSE WE TALKED ABOUT
WELL WHAT HAPPENS AFTERWARDS
WHAT KIND OF SUPPORT WE'RE
GIVING GUIDANCE COUNSELING SO
FORTH. SO CAN YOU. SO IS THIS
ALL GOING TO BE ONLINE I MEAN
COUNSELING. IN BE PARTIALLY
DONE ONLINE BUT SO HOW HOW DO
YOU PLAN TO PROVIDE THIS
ASSURANCE THAT HE WOULD YOU
KNOW PEOPLE ASK ABOUT WILL TO
GET A JOB AND SO FORTH IS IT
WILL GIVE THEM A LOT OF SUPPORT
TO GET THE JOB. OKAY SO I GUESS
NOT DEFINITELY JOB I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU CAN THIS IS A PROMISE
THAT ALL THE HOPE WE HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT. WILL LEAD
TO THAT- BUT HOW. SO HOW WE CAN
DELIVER THIS GUIDANCE AND
COUNSELING THROUGH CAL BRIGHT-
THIS IS JUST GONNA BE ONLINE
OURS ARE GOING TO BE A PERSONAL
TOUCH. BECAUSE I DON'T SEE HOW
COUNSELING WORKS THAT WELL JUST
ONLINE. THERE THERE WILL BE
TELEPHONE ACCESS THERE ALREADY
IS AND THAT THAT WILL CONTINUE
EVEN AFTER THEY'VE COMPLETED
THERE'S THEIR CERTIFICATE. AND
WHAT SORT OF RATIO OF
COUNSELORS TO STUDENTS DO YOU
ANTICIPATE STAFFING FOR. UP TO
PRIDE THIS. TELEPHONE GUIDANCE.
I DON'T HAVE THAT AT THE TIPOF
MY FINGERS BUT I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A OF. A COMPREHENSIVE OKAY
SO YOU WILL PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO MYSELF IN THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY I KNOW I AGAIN
THIS IS A- PART OF BEING A
COLLEGE IS PROVIDING THAT
SUPPORT IT'S AND IT'S JUST NOT
THE COURSES IT'S ALSO THE
SUPPORT AND THE LEVEL SUPPORT.
TELEPHONE I GUESS WHO USES
BETTER JUST ON THE SCREEN BUT
I'M NOT SURE IF THAT'S MISTER
SUFFICIENT BUT THANK YOU. HI I
JUST ME I'M NOT SURE IF IT'S-
TELL DOES TELEPHONE OR SKYPE OR
YOU KNOW THERE'S A ROOM OR
SOMETHING AT THE MAY VERY WELL
BE VIDEOS OKAY WELL. THAT
PRECEDED YOU COULD- WHEN YOU
GET THE INFORMATION PROVIDE
THAT AND AS WELL AS THE RATIO
OF COUNSELORS. THANK YOU.
GENERALIZATION FOR
PARTICIPATING I HOPE YOU. DON'T
TAKE MY QUESTIONS AS INDICATING
ANY SORT OF LACK OF SUPPORT TO
I AM CLEARLY A SUPPORTER OF
INNOVATIVE EDUCATION EFFORTS
SITE. WHEN I HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY SPEAK TO GROUPS I
TELL THEM THAT WE CANNOT IN
CALIFORNIA. DO BUSINESS TODAY
THE WAY WE'VE DONE BUSINESS
OVER THE LAST SIXTY YEARS JUST
BECAUSE- OUR CUSTOMERS YOUR
STUDENTS. THAT DEMANDED ND THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET DEMANDS AT I
DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS THAT
I'VE STATED IN SOME THAT I
PROBABLY HAVEN'T OVER THE- THE
ASSUMPTIONS THE MASSES- THE
PREPARATION IN THE ORGANIZATION
OF THIS EFFORT- BUT I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH YOU. SHOULD THE
ADMINISTRATION CHOOSE TO MOVE
FORWARD IN THE CURRENT
DIRECTION TO WORK THROUGH THOSE
ISSUES IN THIS CURRENT
DIRECTION OR IF THERE'S A PIVOT
FOR ANY ANY REASON TO WORK
THROUGH THOSE WITH YOU ON THE
PIVOT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO DELIVER ON DEMAND
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
EDUCATION TO THOSE CALIFORNIANS
WHO NEED IT WHEN THEY NEEDED SO
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH THANK
YOU BUT SAYS THE NEXT PANEL TO
JOIN US UP HERE IF YOU WILL BE
SO KIND AS TO DO SO. LEAVE IT.
WITH. WELCOME TO WHAT'S MY LINE.
WHEN YOU'RE SITUATED IF I COULD
ASK OF THE PANELISTS TO
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES FOR THE
RECORD STARTING TO MY LEFT
YOU'RE RIGHT AND THAT WOULD BE
YOU SIR. I'M JOHN STANCE
BECAUSE I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE ACADEMIC SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
JUST ASK HIS THANKS FOR JOINING
US MA'AM. EMILY ROSENBERGER
WITH THAT CHAU. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US SIR RENDON HOOKER
FROM THE EDT EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT- GOOD
FOR THANKS FOR BEING A REAL
STRONG AS A PRESIDENT AMOUNTS
SAN ANTONIO COLLEGE. DR
STRUGGLES THANKS FOR JOINING US.
BECAUSE. MR MAILER IT. I AM
GOOD MORNING I'M BOB LANTER
DIRECTOR THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION. THANKS
MISTER LANDER FOR JOINING US
OKAY WHO WANTS TO GO FIRST.
STATUS ARE YOU IT. WE DON'T
HAVE TO WE CAN FLIP A COIN NO
IT'S FINE. I WILL SAY THAT IF.
YOU ARE A LITTLE INTIMIDATING.
ALL NO- SO MY NAME IS JOHN
STANDS BECAUSE I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ACADEMIC
SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- I REPRESENT THE SIXTY
TWO THOUSAND- FULL AND PART
TIME FACULTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN ACADEMIC AND
PROFESSIONAL MATTERS- SO I-
WANTED TO PREFACE THAT OUR- JOB
AS THE ACADEMIC SENATE- IS TO
REPORT OUR RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. ABOUT
EDUCATIONAL POLICIES AND
CURRICULAR DESIGN AND THAT WE
HELP ALL COLLEGES SERVE
STUDENTS AND IT HERE TO THE
LAWS PASSED BY THIS LEGISLATURE
AND THE REGULATIONS CREATED BY
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS. AND
ALSO WANTED TO ADDRESS UP FRONT
THAT SOME OF THE THINGS THAT I
HAVE TO SAY IT MAY SOUND
DIFFERENT FROM THAT REPORTED BY
THE PRESIDENT OF OUR BOARD OF
GOVERNORS AND THE CHANCELLOR
FOR THE- CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THAT WE WORK DIRECTLY
WITH AS PART OF OUR ROLE. I
COMMEND. THE PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS AND OUR
CHANCELLOR FOR DEFENDING OUR
COLLEGES AND ARE DISTRICTS. AND
I WOULD EXPECT THEY WOULD DO SO
FOR ANY OF THEM- AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. I WAS ASKED TO
ANSWER A FEW QUESTIONS AND SO I
WILL TRY TO DO SO TO THE BEST
OF MY ABILITY- FIRST WORDS TO
DESCRIBE HOW WE HAVE WORKED
WITH CALIBRATE- SINCE THE LAW
WAS PASSED- IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WE HAVE- WORKED WITH
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
THEN. THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
THAT IS THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS.
TO A POINT A GROUP OF FACULTY
FROM ACROSS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM THAT CAN SERVE
AS A RESOURCE AND A FACULTY
VOICE. AS POLICIES ARE
DEVELOPED AROUND ACADEMIC AND
PROFESSIONAL MATTERS AS HIRING
NEEDS TO TAKE PLACE AS ANY OF
THE THINGS THAT REQUIRE.
FACULTY IN IN A- ACADEMIC AND
PROFESSIONAL SETTING THAT THEY
ARE ABLE TO ACCESS THOSE
FACULTY- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
REVIEW INITIAL BOARD POLICIES.
THEY WERE ASKED TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT THE
CURRICULUM. THE OTHER PARTS
THAT ARE LISTED AS THE JOB OF
THE ACADEMIC SENATE ABOUT
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT- ABOUT CREATING-
HIRING POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
THERE THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
UTILIZED AS MUCH. I'M ALSO IN A
ROLE WE HAVE TRIED TO GO TO ALL
OF THE BOARD OF TRUSTEE
MEETINGS OR HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE THERE AND
JUSTICE WE WOULD AS ANY
ACADEMIC SENATE WOULD FOR ANY
LOCAL DISTRICT HE WOULD EXPECT
YOUR ACADEMIC SENATE PRESIDENT
TO BE PRESENT. AND TO PROVIDE
FEEDBACK AND ADVICE TO THE
BOARD WE HAVE TRIED TO FILL
THAT ROLE AS WELL UNTIL SUCH A
TIME AS THE COLLEGES ABLE TO
ITS OWN- INFRASTRUCTURE AND
FACULTY ORGANIZE THEMSELVES IN
THAT WAY. THE SECOND QUESTION
YOU ASKED WITH TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE ONLINE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE IN THE
WORK THE ACADEMIC SENATE HAS
DONE WITH THAT- WE OFTEN WORK
WITH THE- III IN A STATE MY
CAPACITY TO COLLABORATIVELY
INSURER STANDARDS IN PROCESS
APPROVAL. MUCH OF THE INITIAL
IDEAS OF WHAT ARE THE STANDARDS
FOR OFFERING ONLINE EDUCATION
WERE DONE COLLABORATIVELY. THE
ACADEMIC SENATE MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT THAT THE
WE AYE- EXT TOOK ALL OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND CREATED THE
STRUCTURE THAT EXISTS TODAY IN
THE WAY I. WE ALSO TALK ABOUT-
LOCALLY SUPPORTING THE
CURRICULAR DESIGN THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
STANDARDS AND PARTICULARLY THAT
DEVELOPMENT OF THE C. T. E.
ONLINE PATHWAYS THAT WAS FUNDED
BY THE LEGISLATURE TWO YEARS
AGO. UP FOR THAT THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING AND I'LL TALK ABOUT
THAT A LITTLE MORE. I IN A
SECOND. THE THIRD QUESTION.
ASKED WAS TO DESCRIBE OUR
QUESTIONS REGARDING LEFT
LEGISLATIVE CLARIFICATION ON
DUPLICATION AND ACCREDITATION.
SO WE HAVE A WE HAVE WRITTEN
YOU LETTERS WHICH IS WHAT WE
HOW WE PREFER TO INTERACT WITH
YOU. AND NOT THIS WAY. I'M
TRYING TO CLARIFY- SOME OF OUR
CONCERNS YOU REFERENCED EARLIER
THE AUGUST REPORT- FROM
CALIBRATE TO THE LEGISLATURE
WHERE THEY FIRST- TALKED ABOUT
HAVING DEGREES AND THAT
PROMPTED OUR FIRST LETTER IS
THAT WAS PREFACED ON THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THEY NEEDED TO
ACHIEVE- TO EIGHT. THE TASTY
SEE THROUGH THE ACCREDITOR. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THEY HAVE
CHOSEN TO PURSUE A DIFFERENT A
NATIONAL ACCREDITOR WHERE A
DEGREE IT'S NOT REQUIRED- SO
SOME OF THAT HAS BEEN
ALLEVIATED BUT THERE IS LACK OF
CLARITY IN THE LAW ABOUT WHAT
THE LEGISLATOR X. BACK DID IN
TERMS OF ACCREDITATION- BEYOND
JUST BEING ACCREDITED AND THERE
IS A DISTINCTION BETWEEN.
NATIONAL ACCREDITATION AND
REGIONAL ACCREDITATION. THE
SECOND TENT FOR ANY- ISSUE RE
IS REGARDING- THE DUPLICATION
OF PROGRAMS- AND WE HAVE
OUTLINED OUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
DUPLICATION OF PROGRAMS- AND
PROVIDED EXAMPLES. AT. IT'S A
LITTLE CONCERNING THAT- THE
EDUCATION CODE LOOKED REALLY
CLEAR. TO MOST OF THE FACULTY
IN THE ACADEMIC SENATE ABOUT
WHAT DUPLICATION OF PROGRAMS
MEANT AND THE EXPLANATION
PROVIDED BY CALIBRATE BY THEY
ARE NOT DUPLICATING. WOULD BE
TRUE FOR ANYTHING THEY WANTED
TO DO. BY USING THAT STANDARD
THERE IS A STANDARD IN TITLE
FIVE- IN THIS SECTION OF THE
REGULATION THAT GOVERNS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT IS
APPROVED BY THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS THAT DEFINES A
PROGRAM. AS A AS AS BEING
DEFINED BY THE OUTCOMES OF THE
OF THE COURSES AND CONTENT. IT
DOESN'T SAY ANYTHING ABOUT
WHETHER IT'S ONLINE OR FACE TO
FACE WHETHER IT IS NON CREDIT
OR CREDIT OR ANYTHING ELSE
ABOUT WHAT THE PROGRAM IS AND
THAT IS THE DEFINITION THAT THE
REST OF THE SYSTEM HOUSE TO
USE. IN TERMS OF PROGRAMS AND
SO WE WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
SOME CLARITY IF THIS IS A
DIFFERENT DEFINITION OF
DUPLICATING A PROGRAM- I AM AND
WHERE THAT LINE IS BECAUSE WE
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THE
ASTOR TATIAN. THE ASSERTION OF
CALIBRATE AROUND DUPLICATION. I
DID WANT TO TALK TO YOU- A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION. A
PIECE OF THAT ARE BECAUSE WE-
OFFER COMPETENCY BASED
EDUCATION THAT IS THAT IS THE
BASIS OF NON CREDIT NON CREDIT
IS DESIGNED IN STATUTE THAT IT
CAN BE A OPEN ENTRY AND OPEN
EXIT. THAT IT CAN BE- EITHER
TRANSCRIPT DOUBLE OR NOT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO TRANSCRIPT IT IT
DEPENDS ON WHAT THE STUDENT
WANTS OUT FROM THAT AND WE
OFFER NON CREDIT PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. NOT AS
MANY OF THEM ARE ONLINE AND
THERE ARE REASONS FOR THAT THAT
ARE STRUCTURAL TO THE SYSTEM WE
APPRECIATE THE REPORT THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE I RECENTLY
SENT TO YOU ABOUT COMPETENCY
BASED EDUCATION. BECAUSE IT
HIGHLIGHTS. HOW IN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF OUR SYSTEM WE
AS WE OF DISINCENTIVE IZED.
THAT WE HAVE MADE THAT LESS
APPEALING IN TERMS OF HOW WE
FIND THE COLLEGES- AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
CONSIDER. I DID WANT TO SAY.
ALSO THAT. THAT THE LAST
QUESTION WAS HOW CAN THE STATE
BETTER SUPPORT FACULTY IN
COLLEGE AS AN OFFERING ONLINE
EDUCATION AND I HAVE A FEW
RECOMMENDATIONS. THE FIRST IS
THE- ACCESSIBILITY STANDARDS
THE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AND THE TECHNICAL SUPPORT
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT THE
ONLINE- EDUCATION AN ISSUE TO
THE COURSE EXCHANGE AND CROSS
ENROLLMENT. RIGHT NOW- IS BEING
EXPANDED- THROUGHOUT A COLLEGES
TO TRY TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
STUDENTS TO ACCESS THAT. YOUR
CORRECT RIGHT NOW THERE ARE
FIFTY SEVEN- COLLEGES IN THE
CONSORTIUM- I THINK THAT NUMBER
IS. MOVING TO SEVENTY BY THE
END OF THE YEAR. THAT'S AND%
THAT THAT HAS BEEN A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS THAT IS
HAVE INPUT FROM MANY
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT HOW TO SERVE
STUDENTS BOTH REGIONALLY AND AS
A STATE. I DID WANT TO SAY THAT
MOVING AWAY FROM OUR CURRENT
FUNDING STRUCTURE WHICH IS
BASED ON WEEKLY STUDENT CONTACT
AROUND WHAT THE CALENDAR HAS TO
LOOK LIKE. CURRENTLY ADVANTAGE
IN FUNDING THE FACE TO FACE
COURSE THAT IS A FULL SEMESTER-
FOR CREDIT. WE ARE ABLE TO
OFFER DIFFERENT WAYS OF
INSTRUCTION THAT WOULD MEET THE
DEMANDS THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
CLEARLY IDENTIFIED NEED TO BE-
PROVIDED TO CALIFORNIA. TO DO
THAT BUT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
EXAMINE THAT FUNDING. STRUCTURE
TO DO THAT. AND THE LAST THING.
I WILL CLOSE WITH I KNOW YOU
WERE ASKED ME TO SPEAK FOR
THREE MINUTES AND I HAVE LIKE
FIVE HUNDRED OTHER THINGS
WRITTEN DOWN HERE SO I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS. BUT IF
YOU EVER WANT TO LOOK. AT WHAT
IS AVAILABLE- THROUGH THE
CONSORTIUM YOU JUST HAVE TO
TYPE IN CVC DOT EDU. AND IF YOU
SCROLL DOWN HERE. TO THE NEXT
THING AND CLICK ON. ONLINE
CERTIFICATES OF ACHIEVEMENT.
THESE ARE NOT DEGREES THESE ARE
ONLINE CERTIFICATES OF
ACHIEVEMENT FULLY ONLINE AND
YOU CAN FIND ALL THREE OF THE
PROGRAMS OFFERED BY CALIBRATE
HERE. THANK YOU. YOUR OF YOUR
VISION YES YEAH THAT'S FINE
WITH ME I'M GONNA LEAVE IT UP
TO YOU SPEAKS FIRST DR PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU. SO
CALIBRATE IS A AT AN ONLINE C.
T. A. C. C. T. CAN COMPETENCY
BASED- IN AN EMPLOYER ALIGNED
COLLEGE. ASOS MOUNTS ACT AND
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU HOW WE DO
SOME OF THE SAME THINGS THAT-
CAL BRIDE HAS IN IN ITS MISSION.
WE BEGIN WITH ONLINE CONTACT
OFFERS EIGHT ONLINE CTP
PROGRAMS FULLY ONLINE- THEY ARE
PROGRAMS LIKE- COMPUTER
ASSISTED INSTRUCTION AND- HUMAN
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT BUT THERE
ARE PROGRAMS THAT- BOTH THE
DIDACTIC THAT IS THE BOOK
LEARNING AS MY DAD WOULD CALL
IT AND- HANDS ON- A WORK CAN BE
DONE ON A COMPUTER BASED SYSTEM
THEREFORE. THERE FULLY ONLINE.
WE OFFER A WIDE VARIETY OF
ADDITIONAL FULLY ONLINE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE AIMED AT
ACADEMIC AND TRANSFER PROGRAMS
AND IS ONE OF OUR FASTEST
GROWING AREAS YEAR OVER YEAR WE
GREW 32% LAST YEAR SO NOW- OF
NON SECT STUDENTS EIGHT
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND%
NINETY TWO STUDENTS. TOOK
ONLINE CLASSES LAST YEAR SO IT
IS A TREMENDOUS GROWTH MARKET
IN OUR REGION AND STATE WIDE.
WE ALSO OUR FOUNDING MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA VIRTUAL CAMPUS
CAMPUS ONLINE EDUCATION
INITIATIVE- AND SO THROUGH THAT
PROCESS WE ARE ON OUR PART OF
THE COURSE EXCHANGE KNOWN AS-
THE. I'M LOSING THE WORK WORD
RIGHT NOW- FACT THAT FINISH
FAST PROGRAM. I'M I'M ALSO
AWARE THAT THAT'S WHAT THE
ABILITY TO HAVE THIS COURSE
EXCHANGE WAS ONE OF THE REASONS
WE WERE SLOW IN IMPLEMENTING
YOUR FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THE FIRST ATTEMPTS WE HAD WERE
CHALLENGING BUT NOW A STUDENT
REGISTERED IN ANY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAN REGISTER IN A
COURSE AT MOUNT SAC OR ANY
OTHER PARTICIPATING- WE AYE
COLLEGE WITH A BASICALLY A
SEAMLESS. PROCESS THAT'S
SPURRED A LOT OF ADDITIONAL
POSTING OF COURSES IN THE
ONLINE CATALOGUE MOUNT SAC NOW
HAS OVER FORTY CLASSES THAT'S
BEEN POSTED IN THAT EXCHANGE
AND WE REGULARLY EXCEPT- YEAH-
FOR CREDIT HANFORD DEGREE
COMPLETION COURSES TAUGHT
ONLINE AND OTHER COLLEGES. IN
THE AREA OF EMPLOYER CONTACTS
FOR A WE OFFER. SIXTY FOUR TWO
YEAR ASSOCIATE DEGREES IN C. T.
E. AREAS AND A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX SHORT TERM- CITY
PROGRAMS AND IS THERE A YEAR OR
LESS. SO WE'RE A MAJOR- CTP
PROVIDER THE LARGEST IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. FOR ALL OF
THOSE PROGRAMS WERE REQUIRED TO
HAVE AN INDUSTRY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WE MEET REGULARLY
WITH EMPLOYERS WHO ADVISES ON
CURRICULUM ON- BEING UP TO DATE
ON WHAT THEIR JOB
SPECIFICATIONS ARE THE
COMPETENCIES OUTCOMES AND THEY
HELP WITH EMPLOYMENT. THOSE
PROGRAMS WERE ESTABLISHED BY
LABOR MARKET DEMAND YOU HEARD
THE CHANCELLOR TALK ABOUT THE
CENTERS OF EXCELLENCE MOUNT SAC
HOSTS A CENTER OF EXCELLENCE
FOR LOS ANGELES AND ORANGE
COUNTY. AND WE GET THAT LABOR
MARKET AT DATA THROUGH THE
QUESTION EARLIER AS HOW IS BY
CONTRACTING WITH EMS AND- THE
SECOND ONE WILL COME BACK TO ME
LATER- BUT TO BE CONTRACTED
SERVICES THAT PROVIDE US THAT
DATA- WITH THE INFORMATION WE
GIVE THEM ABOUT THE SEARCH
SERVICE AREA AND PARTICULARLY
LOS ANGELES COUNTY FOR ME. IT
AS WE DO THOSE PROGRAMS WE
ALSO- INTERACT WITH. THE
REGIONAL EMPLOYMENT MARKET
THROUGH THE CENTER FOR
COMPETITIVE WORK FOR SAID DOES
RESEARCH ON EMERGING- JOB
SPECIFICATIONS AND SO ON SO WE
TRY TO DESIGN PROGRAMS THE MEET
NOT JUST CURRENT LABOR MARKET
NEEDS BUT EVOLVE THOSE IN AREAS
LIKE AUTOMATION AND A I'D- THEN
WE ALSO ARE EXTENSIVELY
INVOLVED IN. INTERNSHIPS AND
APPRENTICESHIPS THESE ARE
CLASSES THAT WE OFFERS OF THEIR
CREDIT TRANSFERABLE CLASSES FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE UP FOR IT IN
THE CASE OF INTERNSHIPS ARE
NEAR THE END OF THEIR TRAINING
PROGRAM AND THEIR ASSIGNED IT
IT ON A WHIM THE WORK SITE-
WITH A EXPERIENCE A LEARNING
EXPERIENCE- AN OB THE JOB
TRAINING IF YOU WILL THAT'S
RELATED TO THE COURSE OF STUDY
WHETHER SUPERVISED BY. SOMEONE
ON AT THE WORKPLACE AND
COORDINATED WITH ONE OF OUR
CREDIT FACULTY MEMBERS TO
ACHIEVE THE LEARNING OUTCOMES
WE HAVE SIX HUNDRED STUDENTS
PARTICIPATING IN THAT SOME AS
VOLUNTARY SOME IS PAID WORK. IN
ADDITION WE WORK WITH EMPLOYERS
TO BE SURE THAT FEEDBACK FROM
THAT EXPERIENCE WERE RIGHT ON
THE GROUND WITH EMPLOYERS
LOOKING AT THE JOB
SPECIFICATIONS IT'S A GREAT
SOURCE OF INTERACTION WITH
EMPLOYERS TO KEEP US CURRENT
WITH SOFT SKILLS AS WELL AS
HARD SKILLS. WE PARTICIPATE IN
THE STATE'S A- PROGRAMS THAT
FUNDING YOU MAY KNOW MOVED FROM
K. TWELVE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. APPRENTICESHIPS ARE
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE TYPICALLY
OUR GRADUATES WHO ARE ALREADY
WORKING AND NEED ON THE JOB
TRAINING TO GET UP TO SPEED ON
WHAT THE EMPLOYER NEEDS. SO
THEY'RE PAID BY THE EMPLOYER
BUT RELEASED. TO WORK WITH US
ON WHAT'S CALLED RELATED
SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION. A LOT
OF WAYS THAT WE KEEP ON TRACK
OF ALIGNMENT WITH EMPLOYERS.
FINALLY I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
OUR NON CREDIT- COMPLY. A
COMPETENCY BASED VOCATIONAL
PROGRAMS. THESE ARE NON CREDIT
SO AT THIS PARDON ME IF YOU'VE
HEARD THIS BEFORE BUT NON
CREDIT FIRST OF ALL THERE ARE
NO FEES FOR NON CREDIT IT'S
FREE. FOR THIS TYPE OF NON
CREDIT IT'S PAID AT THE SAME
RATE AS CREDIT PROGRAMS BUT THE
WAY WE COLLECT THE HOURS OF
THAT WOULD BASICALLY WE BILL
FOR IS DIFFERENT IT'S CALLED
POSITIVE ATTENDANCE SO IN
COMPETENCY BASED WORK YOU
PROVIDE THE INSTRUCTION BOTH
THE DIDACTIC- BOOK LEARNING AND
THE- PERFORMANCE HANDS ON WORK.
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF HOURS OF
INSTRUCTION THE TO STUDENT
NEEDS TO REACH THAT COMPETENCY
LEVEL AND THE COMPETENCY LEVELS
ARE AT A DEVELOP TO THROUGH THE
SAME WAY FOR THESE NON CREDIT
C. T. PROGRAMS AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WORKING WITH EMPLOYERS.
AND THE SAME FOR LABOR MARKET
DEMAND BUT THE DIFFERENCE IS
THAT WHEN THE STUDENT HAS
COMPLETED THE COMPETENCIES
SATISFIED THE PERFORMANCE THESE
ARE MEASURABLE PERFORMANCE
OBJECTIVES SOME ARE- CLASSROOM
BASED SO MARK PERFORMANCE-
ACTUALLY DOING THE WORK THAT
THEY'LL BE EMPLOYED IN. THEIR
DONE- WE'RE ONLY PAID FOR THE
ACTUAL HOURS OF INSTRUCTION
THAT THE STUDENTS PARTICIPATE
IN THE VISION. CORD OR STOP OUT
AND BACK. WE GET PAID LESS
HOURS SAME HOURLY IS BUT LESS
HOURS THAT'S THE BASIS OF
COMPETENCY. EXAMPLES IN THE
HANDOUT THAT I GAVE FOR EXAMPLE
OUR EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TECHNICIAN EMT AMBULANCE
AMBULANCE DRIVERS. SO WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A CLASSROOM
PORTION OF THIS WHERE WE TEACH
THE PRINCIPLES OF BEING AN EMT
WORKING WITH THE HEALTH HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. BUT WE ACTUALLY
BOUGHT THE BACK END OF AN
AMBULANCE THAT SITS IN A LAB AT
THE COLLEGE SO THEY ACTUALLY
GET THE ON THE JOB TRAINING OF
HOW TO WORK WITH SCENARIOS THAT
THE- IMP EMPLOYERS. TWO TYPES
OF EMPLOYERS THE FIRES- OF. THE
FIRE INDUSTRY AND HOSPITALS
ABOUT THE TYPE OF THINGS THEY
WOULD INTERACT WITH ON THE ON
THE RESCUED THE TRUCKS OR THE
AMBULANCES. SO AGAIN MOST OF
THESE SHORT TERM VOCATIONAL
PROGRAMS ARE SIX MONTHS OR LESS
THEY'RE BASED ON CERTIFICATION.
FOR EXAMPLE A CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANT GETS THE COMPETENCIES
PASSES THE LICENSE EXAM AND
GOES TO WORK. OUR PASS RATES ON
INDUSTRY AND STATE
CERTIFICATIONS ARE ALWAYS ABOVE
90% SINCE WERE BASICALLY
TESTING THEM ON WHAT THEIR
COMPETENCIES WILL BE AND THESE
EXAMS. AND THE EMPLOYMENT RATES
ARE ALSO THAT HIGH. WE LOOK FOR
A MERGING OCCUPATIONS SO WE
ADDED ONE FOR- AIRCRAFT
DISPATCHERS THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO TALKED TO THE AIRPLANE WHEN
YOU'RE ON SOUTHWEST AND THEY
SAY I'M SORRY WE'VE GOT A
MAINTENANCE PROBLEM HOLD UP.
THAT'S THE DISPATCHER WAS
TALKING TO THEM WE HAD OUR
FIRST COURTED TWELVE PEOPLE
PASSED THIS FAA CERTIFICATION
IN A 100% EMPLOYMENT. YOU CAN
SEE HOW THESE TYPES OF C. T. E.
R. COMPETENCY BASED BUT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE HANDS ON WORK THEY
DON'T LEND THEMSELVES TO
ONLINE. WE'RE WORKING ON THE
GRANT SYSTEM THAT'S OUT THERE
FOR ONLINE- NOT CREDIT SEAT HE
PROGRAMS PERHAPS CAN HAVE A
DIDACTIC. PROGRAM ON THE LINE
AND HAVE THE CHANCE WERE DONE
WHERE DO IT NOW. WE NEED TO THE
ELEMENTS THAT CAL. AS A WE SEE
THAT THE THIS LEVEL ONLINE
WOULD BE. AN A USEFUL. WITH US
BUT I BILL. THAT OUR ECONOMY IS.
AND COMPLEX ENOUGH THAT A STATE
WIDE ONLINE SOLUTION IS NOT
GOING TO CAPTURE THAT RANGE OF
PROGRAMS IT MIGHT WORK IN
WISCONSIN WHICH HAS A PROGRAM
LIKE THIS. BUT I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THE FULL RANGE OF WHAT IS
EXPECTED FOR CALIBRATE WILL BE
APPROPRIATE TO THE TO THE
AUDIENCE THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. THESE SHORT TERM
VOCATIONAL PROGRAMS HAVE THREE
MARKET SEC THE WE REACH OUT TO
THOSE WHO ARE OUT OF THE WORK
FORCE AND THAT DOESN'T MEAN
UNEMPLOYED BECAUSE MANY JUST
STOPPED WORKING. AND THOSE WHO
ARE UNDEREMPLOYED THEY'RE UP
SPILLING AND THE THIRD IS THOSE
ARE A NEW TO CALIFORNIA. THESE
TEND TO BE A NON CREDIT THE
ENTRY LEVEL POSITIONS BUT CNA
GOES TO A LICENSED VOCATIONAL
NURSE TO OUR AND ALL OF WHICH
PROGRAMS WE HAVE WE HAVE AN
OBSCURE RATE OF ABOUT THIRTY
EIGHT PERCENT. THE MTV IS A PRE
REQUISITE TO A MEDIC. WHICH WE
ALSO OFFER IN AND CLOSE TO A
100% OF OUR EMTS THEY GO TO
WORK AND THEN AND ROLE IN THE
PART. I AM THIS BOTTLE THE
LOCAL RESPONSE AND HANDS ON
WORK IS NOT IN THE WHEEL HOUSE
COULD BE AT LEAST. CAL. WOULD
HAVE PAID PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL
NINE STATE WHY. BUT THE REGION
NATURE AND THE ON NATURE WILL.
CALL FOR BY COMMUNITY COLLEGES
LIKE MOUNT ST. THANK YOU DOCTOR
YOU KNOW I WAS GONNA WAIT UNTIL
QUESTIONS BUT CENTER JUST TWO
OF US OF ME. OF FOR MY
COLLEAGUE THE SAME COURTESY OF
ME JUST ASK OF THESE ONE
QUESTION ONE OF MY CONCERNS IS
CAL BREDS REACH STATEWIDE WHICH
IS WHAT YOU'VE BEEN I THINK. TO
ADDRESSING AND WITH REGARD TO
THIS COMPETENCY COMPETENCY
BASED EDUCATION- COMPETENCY
BASED INSTRUCTION. WITHIN THE
REGION THAT YOU SERVICE. HAVE
YOU- HAVE YOU RECEIVED ANY
FEEDBACK FROM THE EMPLOYER
COMMUNITY THAT THERE ARE ANY. A
DEFICIENCIES IN IN THE
PROGRAMMATIC OFFERINGS THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST FOR THOSE THAT
ARE EMPLOYED IN NEED UPSCALING
OR THOS THAT ARE COMING IN. TO
THE EMPLOYMENT ARENA AND DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT SKILLS YES WE
CONSTANTLY MONITOR THAT AND WE
FOUND THAT IN OUR ADVANCED
MANUFACTURING PROGRAMS WE
WEREN'T KEEPING UP WITH CURRENT
COMPETENCIES. AND WE WERE A BIT
AT A LOSS SO WE RECENTLY SIGNED
A CONTRACT WITH GOODWILL
INDUSTRIES WHICH IS A PROVEN
INTERMEDIARY WITH INDUSTRY. AND
THAT CONTRACT CALLS FOR THEM
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS TO WORK
WITH MORE THAN FIFTY EMPLOYERS
IN THE GROWING MANUFACTURING
SECTOR IN LOS ANGELES AND DO
EXACTLY WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
TALK TO THEM DIRECTLY GET THE
COMPETENCIES SEE WHAT THE
WORKPLACE ENVIRONMENT IS LIKE
HELP US- WITH. THE CURRICULUM.
I HAVE A POSITION THAT I'M
READY TO FILL WITH THAT BUT I
PUT THE STOP TO THAT TO SAY
WE'RE NOT MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS UNTIL WE HAVE A GOOD WAY
OF RESPONDING. TO THAT AS WELL
THE SECOND ANSWER IS THE CENTER
FOR COMPETITIVE WORK FORCE THAT
WE FUND THROUGH THE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM IS LOCATED IN A
LAYSA PARTNERSHIP. WITH THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT THE AND WORKFORCE
INVEST BOARD AND THE LA CHAMBER
COMMERCE. THEY DO OUT. ON AS I
MENTIONED KEEPING UP WITH THE
EVOLUTION OF SKILLS AND THEY DO
REGULAR REPORTS THEY ARE ONLINE
AND WE USE THOSE REPORTS TO
UPGRADE OUR CURRICULUM ON A
REGULAR BASIS IT'S A CONSTANT
EFFORT. IN THE AREA OF CTV. FOR
YOUR RESPONSE A CENTER LEYVA
I'VE TO TEAR OPEN UP QUESTIONS
FORGERS JUST ONE QUESTION THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THE EIGHT
ONLINE PROGRAMS THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT OUR DO THOSE CAN THOSE
STUDENTS- GET TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
SUPPORT LIKE STUDENTS TO
CALIBRATE CAN. YES WE HAVE
FULLY ONLINE COUNSELING
AVAILABLE AND THEY'RE INTO ITS
INTEGRATED INTO THE PROGRAMS.
AND WE HAVE- THE ABILITY TO
HAVE WE HAVE A TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN- HOTLINE FOR ASSISTANCE A
LOT OF THAT IS JUST TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OF HOW TO INTERACT
WITH. AND THEN WE HAVE BOTH-
SYNCHRONOUS AND ASYNCHRONOUS
CONNECTION WITH INSTRUCTORS
IT'S ACTUALLY WRITTEN INTO THE
CURRICULUM EVERY DISTANCE
EDUCATION. PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE
CURRICULUM PROCESS MUST
ESTABLISH THE EFFECTIVE
INSTRUCTORS STUDENT CON TO
CONDUCT AND THAT'S A FACT LEE
DRIVEN ISSUE RIGHT NONE. AND
THEY- EVER EVERY TIME THE
PROGRAM IS UPDATED OF THE
COURSES UPDATED THE ASSURE THAT
THAT KIND OF SUPPORT WHENEVER
THE STUDENTS NEEDED IS
AVAILABLE EITHER SYNCHRONOUSLY
OR ASYNCHRONOUSLY. ALONG WITH
THE COUNSELING IN THE TECHNICAL
SUPPORT AVAILABLE ONLINE MOSTLY
SINCE THAT'S THE MECHANISM OF
MATH OF CANVAS THAT WE USE TO
INTERACT WITH STUDENTS SO TWO
AM I PICK UP THE PHONE BONE
THEIR SOME OF THEIR FOR ME TALK
TO. TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND ASYNCHRONOUS YOU
SEND A MESSAGE OUR STANDARD IS
RESPONSE WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS BY THE FACULTY MEMBER AND
IN THAT'S A COMMITMENT THAT
FACULTY ENJOYED MEETING. GOOD
THANK YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH
WHOSE NAME TIME I COULD GET A
GREAT. HI MY NAME IS BRENT
HOOKER I'M A SENIOR RESEARCH
SPECIALIST ON THE LABOR MARKET
INFORMATION DIVISION WITHIN THE
ET DE THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. I'M
GOING TO BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT
LABOR MARKET VALUE. AND THE
DATA AVAILABLE IN OCCUPATIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ACADEMIC
COURSEWORK WE DISCUSSED TODAY
ON MEDICAL CODING IT SUPPORT.
AS WELL AS COMPUTER INFORMATION
SECURITY OCCUPATIONS. THE EASY
USES A VARIETY OF WAYS OF
ASSESSING LABOR MARKET VALUE WE
USE ADMINISTRATIVE DATA- TWO
EXAMPLES OF THAT OR THE
QUARTERLY CENSUS OF EMPLOYMENT
AND WAGES WHICH IS BASICALLY A
COMPREHENSIVE TABULATION OF
EMPLOYMENT AND WAGES. FOR ALL
WORKERS THAT ARE COVERED BY
CALIFORNIA'S UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE LAWS WE ALSO GET DATA
FROM THE EDIE'S A BASE WAGE
FILE WHICH GETS DATA FROM THE
QUARTERLY REPORTS FROM
EMPLOYERS THAT REPORT ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS TO BE EATING.
THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES AND
THEIR ASSOCIATED WAGES. THE ONE
KEY RIGHT ARM PERSONAL%
IDENTIFIER THAT WE USED TO LINK
ALL OF THESE DATA SETS IS THE
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER. AND IF
WE'RE GOING TO ANALYZE IT ON A
PROGRAM COMPLETION BASIS WOULD
GET THE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS
OF PROGRAM COMPLETE EARNERS SO
THEN WE CAN DO A LONGITUDINAL
STUDY WHICH WOULD INCLUDE
EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES. EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOMES WHICH WOULD BE-
WHETHER THEY WERE EMPLOYED IN
CALIFORNIA. INDUSTRY THEY'RE
EMPLOYED IN AS WELL AS THE
WAGES THEY'VE GARNISHED OVER
THAT PERIOD OF TIME WHEN
COMPLETING THE PROGRAM. ANOTHER
METHOD WE YOU. TO ANALYZE
EMPLOY DEMAND ACTUALLY IS A
SOFTWARE TOOL ONLINE WE LOOK AT
ONLINE JOB ADS AS A MEASURE OF
EMPLOYER DEMAND AND WE USE A
SOFTWARE TOOL- THROUGH THE
CONFERENCE BOARD BURNING GLASS
HELP WANTED ONLINE DATA SET.
THIS DATA SAID ACTUALLY-
SCREENS OVER FIFTY THOUSAND JOB
DOMAINS THE TRADITIONAL JOB
BOARDS AS WELL AS THE CORPORATE
JOB BOARDS AS WELL AS THE
SOCIAL MEDIA SITES SO IT'S A
COMPREHENSIVE VIEW OF EMPLOYER
DEMAND ONLINE. WHEN WE GET A
LINK BETWEEN ON WHEN WE'RE
ANALYZING THE SKILLS THAT ARE
IN DEMAND OF PROGRAM COMPLETE-
SO WHAT THEY HAVE IN THIS CASE
MEDICAL CODING CYBERSECURITY
AND IT SUPPORT. WE LOOK AT THE
JOB AT AND SEE IF THERE'S AN
FOR ALL MATCH AND THEN WE MAKE
GENERAL ASSESSMENT IF A PROGRAM
HAS LABOR MARKET VALUE. ANOTHER
DATA SOURCE WHO USES THE EDIE'S
EMPLOYMENT PROJECTIONS WHICH
ESTIMATES EMPLOYMENT CHANGES
OVER TIME ON THE INDUSTRY IN
OCCUPATIONAL LEVELS. AND THESE
CHANGES CAN OCCUR THROUGH-
INDUSTRY GROWTH WITHIN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGES. I'M I'M
GONNA GO THROUGH THE SIMPLE
PROCESS IS THAT WE USE YOU CAN
GET A MORE A BETTER FEEL FOR-
HOW WE COME TO THESE OVERALL
THE TERMINATIONS. IN TERMS OF-
THE PROCESS WERE USING WE LOOK
AT THE THREE PROGRAM AREAS AND
AGAIN THOSE MEDICAL CODING I.
T. SUPPORT AS WELL AS COMPUTER
INFORMATION SECURITY. AND WE
LINK THAT TO THE SIP CODE AND
THE ZIP CODES ARE WHAT THE IS
ACTUALLY THE CLASSIFICATION OF
INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAMS. AND
THEY ACTUALLY LINK A SPECIFIC
CODE TO AN ACADEMIC AREA OF
STUDY SO YOU CAN ANALYZE
PROGRAM ACTIVITY IN PROGRAM
COMPLETIONS AND MORE. IN A MORE
SYSTEMATIC IN UNIFORM MANNER.
WHEN WE HAVE THE ZIP CODE WE
CAN LINK IT TO A SOCK CODE IN
THE SOCK CODE IS BASED ON THE
STANDARD OCCUPATIONAL
CLASSIFICATION SYSTEM. WHICH IS
THE FEDERAL STANDARD FOR-
LINKING WORKERS TO A PARTICULAR
OCCUPATION BASED ON THE TYPE OF
JOB THEY DO. THAT ONCE WE HAVE
THE SOCK CODE WE CAN LINK THIS
TO OTHER OCCUPATIONS SO NOW IT
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT AN-
ACADEMIC AREA OF STUDY WE CAN
LINK IT TO OCCUPATION SO
MEDICAL CODING. THINK OF
OCCUPATIONS SUCH AS MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE AND MEDICAL RECORDS
TECHNICIANS WHO WERE LOOKING AT
COMPUTER INFORMATION SECURITY
THINK ABOUT OCCUPATION SUCH AS
IT SECURITY ANALYST AS WELL AS
DATA SAID MINISTRY- AND WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT I. T. SUPPORT-
CURRICULUM LOOK THINK ABOUT
OCCUPATION SUCH AS COMPUTER
SUPPORT SPECIALIST. WE TOOK
THIS OCCUPATIONAL INFORMATION
THIS DIRECT AND GRANULAR LEVEL
OCCUPATIONAL INFORMATION AND
LINK IT TO OUR EMPLOYMENT
PROJECTIONS ARE EMPLOYMENT
PROJECTIONS THAT WE USED. IN
ANALYZING THESE COURSES WAS A
TEN YEAR OCCUPANT EMPLOYMENT
PROJECTIONS THAT WENT FROM
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. RIGHT HANDER HAVE BEEN FOR
YOU. THE PEACE TO. AND SOME
DETAILS FROM IT'LL GET INTO.
AND YOU'LL NOTICE THAT OVER THE
PERIOD OF TIME SEE GROW THREE
FOR THE I KEEP RAY FROM POINT
TWO PER. TO TWENTY NINE TWO PER.
HE ALSO SEE THAT IN TERMS OF
THE OVERALL WAGES NEARLY ALL OF
THEM ARE IN EXCESS OF THE
STATEWIDE MEDIAN IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND THEN WHEN WE WERE
LOOKING AT AN ADDITIONAL
COMPONENT THAT WAS ACTUALLY
DISCUSSED TODAY ABOUT THE TOTAL
JOB OPENINGS. WHEN WE'RE
ANALYZING THEM WITH OUR EDT
EMPLOYMENT PROJECTIONS IT'S THE
SOME OF THREE DIFFERENT AREAS
THE NEW JOBS CREATED BY
EMPLOYERS. THE NUMBER OF JOBS
CREATED FROM WORKERS EXITING A
JOB SAY DUE TO RETIREMENT. ALSO
THE NUMBER OF JOBS CREATED FROM
EMPLOYEE TRANSFERS OUT OF THE
JOB. SO THOSE ARE THE IT'S A
IT'S A SUM UP ALL THREE OF
THOSE IS THAT'S THE DATA THAT
YOU'RE SEEING RIGHT THERE. IN
TERMS OF BREAKING IT DOWN INTO
THE THREE SPECIFIC AREAS. WE
SAW THAT OVER THE TEN YEAR
PERIOD A HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED TOTAL JOB
OPENINGS WERE RELATED TO
COMPUTER INFORMATION SECURITY.
EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED TOTAL JOB OPENINGS
RELATED TO IT SUPPORT. AND A
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED JOB OPENINGS
RELATED TO MEDICAL CODING WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE OVERALL
GROWTH RATES ARE THE WAGES
ASSOCIATED IN THE JOB OPENINGS
WE CAN GENERALLY STATE- THAT
THE COURSE OFFERINGS TO HAVE
LABOR MARKET VALUE. ANOTHER
COMPONENT THAT WE LOOK AT THEN
I DESCRIBE BRIEFLY WAS THE A
JOB AT ANALYSIS WE DID A JOB AT
ANALYSIS OVER THE SIXTY DAY
PERIOD ENDING ON FEBRUARY
EIGHTH USING THE COMFORTS BOARD
BURNING GLASS HELP WANTED JOB
DATA. FOUND THAT THERE WERE
NINE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE CYBERSECURITY THE
COMPUTER INFORMATION SECURITY
JOB ADS STATE WIDE. FIVE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN MEDICAL CODING
JOB ADS STATEWIDE. FIVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY SEVEN IT SUPPORT JOB AT
STATEWIDE SO WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE OVERALL EMPLOYER DEMAND
IN TEACHING IT IN A DATA DRIVEN
MANNER WE'RE SEEING THAT THIS
COURSE WORK DOES HAVE LABOR
MARKET VALUE. AND IN CLOSING OF
DVDS HELLO MY DE CAN CONDUCT
ALL LONGITUDINAL OUTCOME
STUDIES THAT ARE DESCRIBED
BEFORE USING THE QUARTERLY
CENSUS OF EMPLOYMENT AND WAGES
IN THE BASE WAGE FILE BUT THE
KEY TO ACTUALLY DOING THIS DATA
IS HAVING THAT GRANULAR LEVEL
ALSO SECURITY NUMBER AS A
PERSONAL IDENTIFIER THAT LINKS
ALL THREE. SO L. U. D. DOES
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO CONDUCT
ALL TO THREE FORMS OF ANALYSIS
THAT I LAID OUT. IN WE COULD DO
THAT IF YOU NEED ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION WHAT DID HE DE DE
PERFORM THE JOB MARKET ANALYSIS
PER THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THESE
THREE PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE WAS CAL
RIGHT. I THINK WE ARE WE DOING
IT TODAY. THEY THEYWE'VE DONE
THIS ANALYSIS THAT YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU WITH THIS THIS
HANDOUT HERE- ALL THIS KIND OF
DATA WE WERE ASKED TO DO THIS-
ANALYSIS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
WORK FOR SPORT. BUT I HAVE NO
INDIVIDUAL KNOWLEDGE OF
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN THE EDT
AND CAL BRIGHT COLLEGE WELL
THEN MY OTHER QUOTE I'VE
ACTUALLY I'VE GOT A COUPLE BUT
THIS ANALYSIS IS STATEWIDE DO
YOU DO YOUR DOES YOUR SYSTEM
HAVE THE ABILITY AND DO YOU.
BREAK THIS DOWN BY REGION YEAH
WE ACTUALLY BREAK IT DOWN BY
METROPOLITAN STATISTICAL AREA
WHICH IS A COMBINATION OF
VARIOUS COUNTIES SO THERE BE A
SACRAMENTO MSA ALSO WE HAVE THE
METROPOLITAN DIVISION AREAS. IN
THESE ARE ALL FEDERAL STANDARDS
FOR- BREAKING DOWN INFORMATION
ON A REGIONAL LEVEL. BECAUSE
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
EDUCATION AND CERTIFICATES AND
EMPLOYABILITY. IT'S ONE THING
TO TALK ABOUT A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM. IT'S ANOTHER TO TALK
ABOUT YOUR STATEWIDE STATISTICS
BUT SOMEBODY WITH A CERTIFICATE
WHO LIVES IN HEMET CALIFORNIA.
IF THE JOB IS IN THE BAY AREA.
AND THEY HAVE A FAMILY MAKES IT
A LITTLE DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
FILL THE JOB SO SOME TO AT SOME
POINT THIS WHOLE PROCESS NEEDS
TO BE. REGIONALIZED WHICH
PROBABLY SPEAKS TO. WHAT LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS DO
VIS A VIS THE CALIBRATE PROGRAM
BUT- THAT'S NOT THAT'S JUST
ANOTHER PANEL. THE RIVER OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
FOR MOTION SIR. SIR COULD I
JUST INTERJECT THAT THIS IS THE
KIND OF DATA THAT WE EXPECT
COLLEGES TO DO TO LOOK AT THE
REGIONAL DATA IN TERMS OF
EMPLOYMENT. EMPLOYABILITY IN
THE LEVEL OF ATTAINMENT OF
SKILL IS A IS A CERTIFICATE
OKAY IS IT JUST ONE COURSE. IS
IT- A DEGREE OR ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT GLORIA TO CREATE THEIR
DIFFERENT LEVELS THERE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE- SEPT CODE.
THAT IS USED TO FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS AND SO THIS IS WHAT WE
EXPECT. OF CURRENT CURRICULAR
PROCESSES OF THE COLLEGES. MS
ROSENBERG IS ISSUE ME OKAY.
WELL ABOVE AN ISLAND BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN SUPPORTIVE
OF THE PROGRAM BUT- I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIRS FOR INCLUDING
US IN A CONVERSATION. WE'RE
ALWAYS HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO OUR WORKERS EXPERIENCE
AND PERSPECTIVE- AS YOU MAY
KNOW SEIU REPRESENTS SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA- WE GAUGE
ON AN ISSUE IT IS WITH THE
INPUT OF ALL SEVENTEEN OF OUR
LOCALS. THROW ONE VOICE
APPROACH OUR INVOLVEMENT HOW
BRIGHT IS NO DIFFERENT- I'D
LIKE TO CLARIFY BEFORE I DIVE
IN THAT- SCA YOU WORK WE'RE
PROUD ADVOCATES AND WERE STRONG
ADVOCATES- EMPLOYEES AND
STUDENTS OF THE ONE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
COLLEGES ARE SUPPORT FOR THE
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN MINUTES
CALIBRATE. IS BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT IT FILLS A UNIQUE
AND LARGELY ON MATT ROLE IN THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION SEVERE- S.
YEAH YOU INITIALLY BECAME
ENGAGED IN A CONVERSATION AFTER
LOCAL UNITED HEALTHCARE WORKERS
USE W. SUGGESTED WE CONSIDER
THE PROPOSAL. THERE'S A HUGE
SHORTAGE OF ALLIED HEALTH CARE
WORK CALIFORNIA AND THAT
SHORTAGE IS GROWING AT A PIECE
OF THE STATE IS NOT MEETING-
WHEN WE BROUGHT THE PROPOSAL TO
OUR LEADERSHIP HOWEVER WE LEARN
THE EVERY SINGLE ONE OF OUR
LOCAL. HASA DEMAND FOR SHORT
TERM SHORT FOR TREATING AND
CERTIFICATION THAT THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO ME THEY'RE LOOKING TO
PRIVATE SECTOR TED TO SECURE
THAT EDUCATION AND- THAT THE
DEMAND IS OUTPACING OUR ABILITY
TO FILL IT- SO FOR INSTANCE OUR
CHILD CARE WORKERS THEY REQUIRE
A NUMBER. OF TICKETS IN
TRAINING US DOES THE EARLY
LEARNING CERTIFICATE AND LEAD
TEACHER TRAINING WE'VE HAD TO
UTILIZE PRIVATE PROGRAMS TO GET
THAT RECKLESS TRAINING OUR
CLASS OF THE WORKERS AT THE
NEED A BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTION.
TATIAN TRAINING- THAT'S OFTEN
REQUIRED WITH IT PEAS WE WERE
ABLE PART WITH L. U. S. D. TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES FOR A PILOT.
AND THAT SMALL IT'S LIMITED
IT'S- ONLY LOCALIZA CERTAIN
PARTS OF LA AND ULTIMATELY HOW
TO UTILIZE A. SAMPLES I CAN
PROVIDE BUT I FOR THE SAKE OF
TIME LIMITED THAT- WE CURRENTLY
DON'T HAVE A PARTNERSHIP WITH
CALIBRATE WE'RE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM AS IT WAS
ENVISIONED- THE OPPORTUNITY WE
SEE IN COBB RIGHT IN THE
SUPPORT WE HAVE GIVEN TO THE
CONCEPT. IS THAT IT IS A
DIFFERENT STRUCTURE FROM THAT
OF THE ONE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
AND WE KNOW THAT SOME COMMUTING
COLLEGES ARE WE UNDERSTAND IF
THEY OFFER THAT TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION- AND THAT THE
YEAH I MIGHT HAVE A SIMILAR
PROGRAM AS WELL BUT- OUR LOCALS
OF EXPRESS THAT THEY NEED A
MORE EXPENSIVE. A MORE
ACCESSIBLE IN A TARGETED
EDUCATION PATHWAY BY SUPPORTING
HOW BRIGHT WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
DIMINISH THE TRADITIONAL
COLLEGE STRUCTURE OR THE- WE I
PROGRAM. WE SUPPORT STUDENTS
ARE PRACTICALLY EVERY
TRADITIONAL COLLEGE AND- III
BUT THERE CONTINUES TO BE
WORKERS LEFT BEHIND BECAUSE NOT
ENOUGH PROGRAMS MEET WORKERS
WHERE THEY ARE AND THAT
INCLUDES THAT WE AYE PROGRAM.
AND WILL KNOW IT SINCE THE
CONVERSATION AROUND COPY AND-
YEAH I AS VASTLY IMPROVED WE
DON'T THINK THAT'S A
COINCIDENCE- MANY OF OUR LOCALS
HAVE EXPRESSED ABOUT. ARIENS AN
EXPANSION OF PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAH I AND WE DO
APPLAUD THOSE EFFORTS
ENCOURAGING AND HOPE FOR
CONTINUED INVESTMENTS- BUT
ULTIMATELY WHAT OUR LOCAL HAVE
INDICATED THAT THEY'VE EXPAND
THE USE OF YEAH I IS STILL FOR
PRE REQUISITES AND STILL FOR
TRADITIONAL TWO AND FOUR YEAR
DEGREES- SO AGAIN WE DON'T SEE
EVEN IF THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF
OVERLAP. THE TRACKS ARE USUALLY
PRETTY DIFFERENT WITH THEIR
LOOKS SEEKING HOW BRIGHT AND
WHAT THEY'RE SEEKING IN THE ON
THE BRICK AND MORTAR AND- WE I.
DID THE CURRENT OF COMMITTEE
CALLED INCIDENT ON BOTH IT
DOESN'T ALLOW FOR A STREAMLINED
APPROACH FOR PARTNERSHIP- NOT
ONLY STATEWIDE BUT EVEN
LOCALLY- FOR INSTANCE YOU AGE
YOU WHICH IS JUST NUMBERS.
BECAUSE AS I OVER HUNDRED AND
TEN. TAX WHEN. CAN'T TURN HIGH.
PROSTOCKS NEXT TO FORCE THE
MAN'S DOES DUE TO TIME YOU
WOULD WAS ON TO PARTNER WITH
CAL RIGHT FOR THEM PROBE BUT WE
ARE MOVING WITH THE DEATH
TRAINING PROVIDER WHICH I KNOW
A I'M HASN'T ABOUT G. ILL THEY
A PROGRAM RUNNING OFF GROUND WE
WERE YU FINDS A CENTER WORKERS
TO PRIVATE INTO FOR PROFIT SO
WE THOUGHT- A NONPROFIT LARGER
PROGRAMMING WAS STILL A BETTER
ALTERNATIVE ULTIMATELY WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE A PUBLIC OPTION- WE
KNOW THAT HOW BRIGHT HAS
MEDICAL COOKING UP AND RUNNING
AND IF WE COULD. COURTNEY
EFFORTS I DON'T THINK WE WOULD
ROLL OUT UTILIZING THEM. WE ARE
SELLING GAUGING AT U. H. W.
SPECIFICALLY- IS WORKING WITH
THEM TO SEE IF THERE'S A BETTER
PATHWAY TO MOVE FORWARD- YOU
KNOW OUR CONVERSATIONS ARE
ONGOING WE BELIEVE THAT
COOPERATE IN THE CONCEPT BEHIND
THEIR INSTITUTION IS A NEEDED
ONE WITHIN OUR WORK FORCE- AND
MY CLOSING DOES TIE BACK TO
WAY. DR PAN RAISED AND WHAT THE
ET SPOKE TO WHICH I FIND
TROUBLING- AND HAS BEEN
DIFFICULT FOR US IS THAT WHEN
WE FIRST DISCUSSED HOW BRIGHT
WE LOOKED AT EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF OUR LOCAL THEM WHAT THEY
NEEDED. AND WE PROBABLY
REPRESENT LOW WAGE WORKERS THEY
DO WHAT JOB THAT'S NEEDED- AND
THEY ALSO DESERVE OPPORTUNITIES
AND THEY DESERVE- TO FIND
AFFORDABLE PUBLIC OPTION RATHER
THAN HAVING TO TURN TO PRIVATE
SECTOR- BUT THE SUCCESS METRIC
METRICS THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING.
THEY LEAVE THEM OUT. SO WITH
THE FOR INSTANCE THE CLASSIFIED
WORKER AT THE WOULD RECEIVE A
5% SALARY INCREASE THAT WOULD
MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE. BECAUSE
THEY ARE LIVING. ON THE CUSP OF
POVERTY WAGES SO 5% WOULD BE A
MORE STABLE HOME LIFE FOR THEIR
FAMILY. IT ALSO WOULD BE IN
HOUSE A LOT OF WORK FOR
CONTRACTING OUT. SO YOU KNOW
THAT'S JUST A GOOD INVESTMENT
PUBLIC DOLLARS THAT ALSO IS A
GOOD INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC AFTER
WE WOULD IT HURRY NEARLY. SIX
MONTHS YOU ALSO CA. IS THE
EMPLOYER A GOOD EMPLOYER ARE
THEY A PULP. EMPLOYER ARE THE
EMPLOYEES REPRESENTED DO THEY
HAVE BENEFITS. THERE'S A LOT OF
FACTORS THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED- AND NOT JUST WE
JUST ALONE ALTHOUGH WE DO THINK
LEADERS ARE STRONG INDICATOR-
SO WE URGE THAT THE GOAL SHOULD
ACTUALLY BE FOR GOOD MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS. WE ARE SUPPOSE BUT
WE ARE SUPPORTED BE COLLEGES
AND WERE SUPPORT ABOUT. BECAUSE
WE REALLY THINK THAT USED TO BE.
WORKERS AND MEETING. THEY ARE
HOWEVER. IS MISINTERPRETED I
THINK THERE IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE MEET WORKERS WERE THERE.
AT THE WE- SURE THAT WE GIVE
WERE HEY UP. THEMSELVES BOTH
FOR THEMSELVES IN THEIR AND
WHAT WE NEED TO DO THINK SOME
THE ISSUE. IS HOW WE STRUCTURE
THIS. AND WHETHER WE SPEND
TWELVE MONTHS. OUT WHO THE
PRESIDENT IS AND HIRING THIRTY
ONE ADMINISTRATORS OR WHETHER
WE SPEND OUR TIME PUTTING
COURSES ON THE GROUND AND
LINING UP EMPLOYERS- I THINK
THE IDENTITY OF THE EMPLOYERS.
IS STILL AN ISSUE OBVIOUSLY WE
KNOW WE'RE SCA USE INVOLVED IN
SCA THOSE CONTRACTS YOU KNOW
YOUR PLAYERS ARE. AND WE KNOW
IF A LABOR ORGANIZATION CAN
GATHER UP WORKERS WHO NEED.
ADDITIONAL TRAINING OR UP
SKILLING. AND CAN WORK WITH THE
EMPLOYER THAT THEY WORK WITH ON
A DAILY BASIS. THERE'S SOME
CONNECTIVITY THERE WHAT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT IN ADDITION TO
THE OTHER COMMENTS I MADE. IS
THE LACK OF CONNECTIVITY WITH
THOSE WHO ARE REPRESENTED BY
SEIU. WHO DON'T HAVE EXISTING
CONTRACTS BETWEEN LABOR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR
EMPLOYER. CAN CONNECT THEM.
WITH THE CERTIFICATE TO SOME
NEW. A SKILLED JOB AND I THINK
WE NEED WE NEED A LITTLE WORK
ON THAT THE QUESTION IS DOES
THE CURRENT STRUCTURE DO THAT.
THEN THE PATH READING DOWN AS
SHE THAT OR DO WE NEED TO PIVOT
AND DO SOMETHING ELSE AND I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
MY POSITION ON ALL THIS IS
CLEAR BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR HELP AND YOUR INVOLVEMENT.
AS UUAL BUT I MAKE A BRIEF
COMMENT ABOUT THE LOW WAGE
WORKERS ABSOLUTELY SIR OR ARE
SHORT TERM- VOCATIONAL PROGRAMS
THAT ARE NON CREDIT COMPETENCY
BASED NO FEES. OFTEN TARGET THE
ENTRY LEVEL POSITIONS AND SOME
OF THEM ARE IN HIGH DEMAND LIKE
HOME HEALTH CARE WORKER AND-
CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANT. BOB
BUT WE SEE THAT THOSE WHO COME
TO THOSE PROGRAMS ARE- DOES
YOUR MID LIFE- MAYBE HAD NOT
HAD ANY FORMAL TRAINING.
THEY'RE IN A SITUATION WHERE
THEY'RE THERE THEY WANT TO ADD
A WAGE TO A FAMILY INCOME THAT
RIGHT MAKES THE FAMILY INCOME
LIVABLE WAGE. AND IN LA COUNTY-
IT'S OFTEN THE CASE THAT IT
TAKES MULTIPLE FAMILY MEMBERS
TO PRODUCE A LIVABLE WAGE. A SO
WE FEEL THAT- THE RESPONSE
WE'RE GETTING FROM THOSE WHO
ARE EMPLOYED IN THOSE JOBS.
FIRST OF ALL THAT THEY ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO THE FAMILY
INCOME. IT'S THE PRICE OF
HAVING A JOB IN CONTRIBUTING TO
THE FAMILY IN THE COMMUNITY AND
SECONDLY THEY DO COVER THEM
TELLS THE PARTY TO LEARN THAT
THEY MAY HAVE NEVER ENCOUNTERED
BEFORE. AND AS I MENTIONED MOST
OF THESE ARE ENTRY LEVEL BUT
THE CAN CALL PROVIDE AND STEP
IN THE LAN AND WE- KILLED RATE
OF ABOUT 8% I WOULDN'T NEGLECT
THE SKILL WORK. IN THE TO.
PROTOCOL WITH SEEM TO BE AT A
LITTLE WEIGHT FOR THIS JOB.
BEING A ACE OF A OF THE OLD. US
I'M GOING FROM GOING FOR- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR FOR AN
INVITING US TO BE HERE TODAY-
I'M BOB WINTER CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION DIRECTOR-
WE REPRESENT THE FORTY FIVE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
ABOUT ANOTHER SEVENTY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN ADVANCING AND
SUPPORTING LOCAL AND REGIONAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND JOB
TRAINING. THE JOB SEEKERS THAT
COME TO THE CAREER CENTER
SYSTEM OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE MANY OF THE
FOLKS WERE TALKING ABOUT HERE
TODAY THEY REPRESENT TARGET
POPULATIONS FROM. VETERANS AN
EX OFFENDERS AND FOSTER YOUTH
TO LONG ERM UNEMPLOYED AND
PEOPLE ON PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
AND- THE MORE THAN 20% OF OUR
POPULATION LIVE AT OR BELOW
POVERTY LEVEL. MANY OF THOSE
WHO ARE THE WORKING POOR I WAS
ASKED TODAY TO DESCRIBE
RELATIONSHIPS AND- EFFORTS
BETWEEN LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARDS
AND LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SO. I'M GONNA COVER FIVE AREAS
OF THE STATE I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. HERE IN THE
CAPITAL REGION. LOS RIOS
COLLEGE. HAS INVESTED IN THE
SACRAMENTO EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
ADMINISTRATION THE WORK FORCE
BOARD HERE UNDER THE STRONG
WORK FORCE INITIATIVE. TO PAY
FOR PROVIDE THREE COACHES FROM
THE SACRAMENTO WORKFORCE BOARD
ON SITE AT LOS RIOS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THOSE COACHES FOCUS ON
CONNECTING CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PATHWAYS STUDENTS AND
GRADUATES. DIRECTLY TO
EMPLOYERS AND DEMANDED ST
OCCUPATIONS BOTH BEFORE THEY
START THE PROGRAM AND AFTER
COMPLETION SO THEY DO THE
PLACEMENT FUNCTION ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
ADDITIONALLY THE WORK FORCE
BOARDS IN THE REGION HERE ALONG
WITH THE REGIONAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. I INVESTED IN AND
SUPPORTED- THE CREATION OF THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY MANUFACTURING
INITIATIVE. WHICH WORKS WITH
EDUCATORS AND INDUSTRY PARTNERS
PROACTIVELY DEVELOP. VOCATIONAL
EDUCATION WORKFORCE INITIATIVE
PROGRAMS LEADING TO FOR FILLING
MANUFACTURING CAREER PATHS
THROUGH THE REGION HERE.
CURRENTLY THEY'RE WORKING ON A
CNC MACHINIST APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM WHICH UTILIZES
CURRICULUM CERTIFICATES
DEVELOPED IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE MANUFACTURER ASSOCIATION
HERE IN THE REGION AND THE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. BUT SAID TO
THE EAST BAY. IN THE EAST BAY
REGION THE CITY OF OAKLAND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
PARTNERS WITH LANEY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. ALONG WITH THE OAKLAND
IN THE ALLIANCE AND WHOLE FOODS
AND A ALTERNATIVE EDUCATION
HIGH SCHOOL FROM THE OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT CALLED
RALPH J. BUNCHE SHE ACADEMY. A
CULINARY CAREER PATHWAY PROGRAM
FOR OPPORTUNITY YOUTH STUDENTS
RECEIVE PRE APPRENTICESHIP
TRAINING AND INTERNSHIPS AND
UPON COMPLETION OF THE PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM THEY
ENTERED THE CULINARY
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. LAINEY
COLLEGES THE EDUCATION AND TO
EIGHT AND THE OAKLEY INDIA THE
OAKLAND INDIA ALLIANCE IS AN
ORGANIZATION COMPRISED OF OVER
EIGHTY RESTAURANTS WHICH ARE
THE EMPLOYER SPONSORS FOR THE
REGISTERED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM. IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
YOUR AREA. THE WORK FORCE
BOARDS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE ARE
PART OF THE STRONG WORK FORCE
LAUNCH WHICH STANDS FOR LOCAL
APPRENTICESHIPS UTILIZING A
NETWORK OF COLLEGES AND HIGH
SCHOOLS IT'S A BIG ACRONYM
LAUNCHES THE INLAND EMPIRE'S
APPRENTICESHIP NETWORK IT'S A
GROWING NETWORK OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HIGH SCHOOL AND
INDUSTRY PARTNERS WHO ARE
COMMITTED TO TAKING THIS A
SYSTEM WIDE APPROACH. IN
OFFERING APPRENTICESHIP
OPPORTUNITIES ACROSS THE
REGIONS I THINK THE QUESTION IS
WHY REGIONAL WELL FROM OUR
EXPERIENCE BUSINESSES AND JOB
SEEKERS COMMUTE AND WORK AND
RECRUIT TALENT REGIONALLY. THE
LAUNCH INITIATIVE- AND THE WORK
FORCE BOARD RECEIVE FUNDING
FROM THE JAMES IRVINE
FOUNDATION AND A COUPLE THIS
WITH THEIR STRONG WORK FORCE
INITIATIVE IN THE TITLE ONE
DOLLARS. TO BUILD THIS LAUNCH
INITIATIVE. ADDITIONALLY THE IN
TECH CENTER- PAT CHAFEE COLLEGE
WORKS WITH THE WORK FORCE
BOARDS TO DEVELOP PRE
APPRENTICESHIP AND
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS FOR
INDUSTRIAL MAINTENANCE
TECHNICIANS- AND THEY SERVE THE
MANUFACTURING COMPANIES IN THE
REGION- REGIONAL PLAN
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDS WHICH IS
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS. UNDER THE
WORKFORCE RATIONS AND
OPPORTUNITIES ACT HAVE BEEN
USED TO SUPPORT CHAFEE COLLEGE
TO EXPECT A NUMBER OF COHORTS
THAT ARE BEING TRAINED IN IN
TECH CENTER. IN THE LA BASIN.
THE LOS ANGELES WORKSOURCE
CENTERS ARE LOCATED THROUGHOUT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES
INCLUDING LA TRADE TACK LA CITY
COLLEGE AND THE LA VALLEY
COLLEGE HEALTH CARE SECTOR IS
BIG AND LOS ANGELES VALLEY AS
IT IS IN THE REST OF THE STATE.
ORDINATOR IN CASE MANAGERS WERE
IDENTIFIED AS A PRIORITY
SPECIALTY AREAS IN LOS ANGELES
AND VENTURA COUNTY TO ADDRESS
THIS NEED THE BOARDS IN LA AND
INVENTOR A LED BY THE SOUTHEAST
LOS ANGELES WORKFORCE BOARD
COLLABORATED WITH THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES REGIONAL
DIRECTOR FOR HEALTH CARE AND
THE EIGHT COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
LA. TO DEVELOP A COLLABORATIVE
FOR CARE COORDINATION SKILLS
ALLIANCE THE ALLIANCE DEVELOPED
CARE COORDINATION PATHWAY
TRAININGS THAT ARE NOW
ARTICULATED TO THE PUBLIC. AND
THEIR TRAINING AND THREE LEVELS
PATIENT NAVIGATOR CARE
COORDINATOR AND CARE MANAGEMENT.
ADDITIONALLY I WOULD BE REMISS
IF I DIDN'T POINT OUT THE SOUTH
BAY WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARD
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS
PARTNERED WITH WEST LOS ANGELES
COLLEGE GENERAL FIVE THOUSAND
APPRENTICES. AND PRE
APPRENTICESHIP AT PRE
APPRENTICES INTO THE ADVANCED
MANUFACTURING OCCUPATION
SERVING THE AEROSPACE AND
BIOSCIENCE SECTOR. UPON
RECEIVING A TWELVE MILLION
DOLLAR GRANT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR FOR OVER
FOUR YEARS THE WORK FORCE FOR
THEIR WORK WITH EL CAMINO
COLLEGE IN THE COLLEGE OF THE
CANYONS. ALONG WITH THEM
PLAYERS AT THE TABLE WHICH
INCLUDE AEROJET ROCKETDYNE.
IMPRESS AEROSPACE IBM LOCKHEED
MARTIN NORTHROP GRUMMAN TESLA
AND PANASONIC ENERGY. FINALLY
THIS HAPPENS- ALSO IN RURAL
AREAS OF OUR STATE- UP IN THE
GREAT MOTHER LODE- THE MOTHER
LODE JOB TRAINING- ASSOCIATION
WHICH IS THE WORK FORCE FOR
THEIR- FORMED A CO LOCATION
AGREEMENT A PARTNERSHIP CALLED
THE AMADOR PROSPERITY CENTER.
IT'S A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
AMADOR COUNTY CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THE AMADOR COUNTY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AGENCY THE
TOURISM COUNCIL AND COLUMBIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. THE
WORKFORCE BOARD THEY'RE LOCATED
THEIR CAREER CENTER RIGHT IN
THE PROSPERITY CENTER AT
COLUMBIA COLLEGES OFFERING
CLASSES AT THE CAREER CENTER-
AT THE PROSPERITY CENTER. THEIR
FOCUS CURRENTLY IS THE HEALTH
CARE SAID AND THIS IS THE
HEALTH CARE SECTOR AND THEY'RE
WORKING WITH THE FOUR HOSPITALS
IN THE REGION. AND THEN FINALLY
THE COLLEGE OF THE REDWOODS UP
IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY HAS WORKED
WITH THE HUMBLE COUNTY
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO
WORK WITH HIM VARIOUS EMPLOYERS
AND DEVELOPING TRAINING AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS TO MEET
INDUSTRY DEMAND. AND THESE
INCLUDE TRAINING PROGRAMS AND
WORKPLACE SAFETY PHLEBOTOMY
TRUCK DRIVING CERTIFICATION
PRODUCTION TECHNICIAN. MANY
THESE FUNDS HAVE COME TO THE
AREA THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S
DISCRETIONARY MONEY AS LAW AS
WELL AS A STRONG WORK FORCE
INITIATIVE. SO THOSE ARE JUST
FIVE OF MANY EXAMPLES THAT I
HAVE THROUGHOUT THE STATE I'D
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE PARTNERSHIP TO WORK
FOR SPORTS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- SO IN TECH IS IN THE
HEART OF MY DISTRICT AND WE
LOVE IN TECH WE DO A LOT OF
WORK WITH THEM. MY QUESTION IS
ABOUT WHOLE FOODS WHAT IS YOUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM AND- WHAT
WERE YOU DOING WITH THEM SO THE
WORKFORCE BOARD IN- OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA. IS WORKING WITH-
WHOLE FOODS. AS ONE OF THE
PARTNERS IN IN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM FOR- THE CULINARY
APPRENTICESHIP CELL WHOLE FOODS
SITS ON- THE EMPLOYER SPONSORED
PART OF THAT JOINT
APPRENTICESHIP COMMITTEE THEY
OVERSEE THE CURRICULUM
DEVELOPMENT MAKE SURE THE
CURRICULUM MEETS THEIR NEEDS.
AND MY IMPRESSION IS THAT
THEY'RE ONE OF THE OVER EIGHTY
RESTAURANTS AND FOOD SERVING
ORGANIZATIONS THAT THEN HIRE
PEOPLE INTO THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM BUT I COULD DOUBLE BACK
AROUND TO FIND OUT FOR YOU JUST
CURIOUS COMING OUT OF-
ORGANIZED GROCERY I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE SOMEONE ISN'T
SPENDING TIME. GETTING A
CERTIFICATE OR WHAT NOT TO WORK
AT WHOLE FOODS WHEN YOU COULD
GO WORK FOR UNION EMPLOYER WALK
IN AND HAVE. A GOOD WAGE
BENEFITS AND A PENSION SO
THAT'S JUST MY POINT. THAT'S.
JIM MILLER I'M PRESIDENT OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COUNSEL FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS I'M ALSO A FACULTY
MEMBER AT SAN DIEGO CITY
COLLEGE- SO I THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING AIDS MUCH
LIKE GREATLY APPRECIATED ALSO
WANTED TO THANK THE STAFF FOR
THE REPORTS AND MATERIALS THEY
PROVIDED FOR THE HEARING IT'S
FANTASTIC ANY OBJECTIVE PERSON
THAT WOULD JUST READ THROUGH
THE MATERIALS WOULD SEE NO NEED
FOR CAL BRIGHT I THINK IT JUST
MAKES THE CASE ON ITS OWN JUST
BY READING THROUGH IT- AND
WE'VE BEEN POSED TO CALIBRATE
SINCE IT WAS FIRST DISCUSSED
AND WE'VE BEEN VERY VERY
VOCALLY OPPOSED. TO IT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS- I
WANTED TO DISPEL A FEW MINUTES
THAT WERE- MENTIONED EARLIER
TODAY ON THE LEGISLATURE REALLY
PER SUPPORTED CAL RIGHT EITHER
WHEN IT WAS IN CONCEIVED
LOBBIED FOR THE LEGISLATURE AND
OF THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
LEGISLATORS WE WERE NEVER ABLE
TO FIND ONE PERSON IN SUPPORT
REASON IT CAME INTO BEING IS
GOVERNOR BROWN. ALBRIGHT OUT
AND SO PUT IT IN THE BUDGET
BILL. AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE IT
NOW IT WASN'T BECAUSE THEY WENT
THROUGH REGULAR POLICY
COMMITTEE HEARINGS LIKE. NORM
NORMALLY BILLS WOULD AND IT'S
MY GUESS HAD THAT BEEN THE CASE
IT WOULD HAVE PROBABLY DIED IN
THE FIRST HEARING WHICH IS WHY
I END UP IN THE BUDGET BILL. SO
WE'RE STUCK WITH SOMETHING THE
GOVERNOR BROWN REALLY WANTED
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SAY THAT THE LEGISLATURE REALLY
WANTED IT OR EVER SUPPORTED AT
ANY POINT IN TIME- I WANTED TO
TALK ON. TOUCH ON THE ISSUE OF
DUPLICATION. IT'S A BIG POINT A
BONE OF CONTENTION AMONG US
MOMENTS FACULTY OF THE SENATE
AS WELL- THE STATUTES SUPER
CLEAR. THAT YOU SHOULDN'T BE
DUPLICATING THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS. WE DON'T THINK THAT
THAT NEED A LOT OF EXTRA
DEFINITION AS TO WHAT THAT
REALLY MEANS AND- WHEN WE PRESS
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ON THIS
THE BEST WE CAN GET BACK FROM
THEM WAS. WELL IT'S A TERM OF
ART. WHAT IS THAT MEAN.
DUPLICATION IT'S A PRETTY
SIMPLE WORD TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THAT MEANS IN. A TO GIVE YOU A
SET THAT SIMILAR EXAMPLE WE
HAVE A- MODEL BACCALAUREATE
PROGRAM IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND PART OF THEIR-
STATUTE OR THERE ARE.
RESTRICTIONS THAT THEY CAN'T
DUPLICATE ANY PROGRAMS AND SEE
AS YOU ARE YOU SEE AND GUESS
WHAT. NOT THEY'VE GOT THIRTEEN
UNIQUE PROGRAMS AREN'T BEING
RUN ANYWHERE ELSE. SO THESE
THREE PROGRAM MEDICAL CODING.
CYBERSECURITY AND FORMATION
TECHNOLOGY. THERE ARE FIFTY ONE
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT
OFFER THOSE PROGRAMS. OF THE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN ACCREDITED
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FIFTY ONE.
SO IT'S NOT JUST A LITTLE BIT
OF DUPLICATION IT'S A LOT OF
DUPLICATION AND THE REASON WHY
THOSE FIFTY ONE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE OFFERING THOSE
PROGRAMS. IS BECAUSE THEY'VE
DONE THE RESEARCH THAT MR
HOOKER- ALLUDED TO THAT THERE'S
JOBS THERE THAT THE IT DOES OUR
FIELDS WHERE WE NEED TO YOU
KNOW TRAIN STUDENTS TO GET.
JOBS WE DON'T OFFER PROGRAMS IN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES IF
WE DON'T SEE. ANY NEED FOR THEM
RIGHT WE DO THESE RESURGENT
DOCTORS GASKETS MENTION THIS AS
WELL DOCTOR SCROGGINS THAT WE
DO THIS RESEARCH LOCALLY WE
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE JOB MARKET
ARE AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO. AND
WHAT PROGRAMS WE NEED TO PUT
FORWARD TO ADDRESS THE STUDENT
NEEDS WERE DOING THAT ON A
REGULAR BASIS IT'S WHAT WE'RE
GOOD AT. IT THERE'S A REASON
WORK CALLED COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BECAUSE WERE CONNECTED TO OUR
COMMUNITIES- THE OTHER POINT
ABOUT. FOR PERHAPS THE STUDENTS
YOU KNOW MAYBE THEY'RE NOT
ANYWHERE NEAR OF ONE OF THOSE
FIFTY ONE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND WANT TO TAKE THIS PROGRAM.
FROM SOME RURAL AREA OR SOME
REMOTE AREA OR SOMEPLACE
OUTSIDE A CALIFORNIA EVEN. ANY
PROGRAM BE ACCESSED BY ANY
STUDENT ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
THERE AREN'T GEOGRAPHICAL
BOUNDARIES FOR ONLINE AT ANY
STUDENT CAN TAKE ANY ONLINE
COURSE FOR MANY COLLEGE. NO
MATTER WHERE THEY HAPPEN TO BE
LOCATED. SO THERE'S NO BARRIER.
AMONG THE CURRENT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM. BASED ON
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION OF
POTENTIAL STUDENTS THAT JUST
DOESN'T EXIST. THE POINT WAS
MADE ABOUT ACCREDITATION IF YOU
RECALL SOME YEARS BACK WE HAD A
BIG FIGHT AMONG IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITH THE ACC
JC. WHEN THERE ARE A CREDITOR
BEFORE THERE WAS A CHANGE IN
LEADERSHIP BECAUSE WE THOUGHT
THEY WERE UNFAIRLY YOU KNOW
SANCTIONING SOME OF OUR
COLLEGES AT CETERA. AND NOW WE
HEAR AND AT THE TIME THERE WAS
A MOVEMENT TO MOVE TO A
DIFFERENT A CREDITOR TO GET
OUTSIDE OF THE CJC AND WE WERE
TOLD NO ALL THE SYSTEM HAS TO
BE IN WINE ACCREDITING BODY WE
COULDN'T HAVE A DIFFERENT ONE
OR TWO DIFFERENT CREDITORS. AND
NOW HERE THE ONLINE COLLEGE
THEY'RE GOING TO FIND ANOTHER
WAY THEY'RE GONNA GET THEIR OWN
A CREDITOR SO NOT ONLY DO THEY
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE ABOVE THE LAW
AND IN IN OTHER AREAS BUT NOW
ITS ACCREDITATION AS WELL IF
YOU READ THROUGH THE PACKET.
THEY WEREN'T IN COMPLIANCE WITH
A 50% LAW NO WE DON'T THINK
THAT WE HAVE TO COMPLY WITH
THAT BUT NOW THEY DO HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH THAT SO THROUGHOUT
THIS PROCESS AS WELL AS THEM
JUST. YOU KNOW BALLING
DISREGARDING WHAT DISPATCH
STATE THERE'S A SENSE THAT THE
ONLINE CALLS FOR SOME REASON
DOESN'T HAVE TO FOLLOW ALL THE
SAME RULES THE REST OF US
FOLLOW AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHERE THAT COMES FROM. OR NO
WAY BUT THE BASIS IS ON THAT-
CONTRACT WAS MENTIONED. WE CON
THROUGHOUT THE CAN CALL DOES AS
WE SO FELT WE ALSO A FAN A- WE
GONNA SET THAT UP THE PARTY
COMPANY. ON SOME TAKE TRAINING
PROGRAM IT'S NOT IN OUR- YOU
CURRY. LET TO SAY YOU GOT A BY
COMPANY AT ONE TO. DO SOME
EXTRA TRAINING FOR THEIR
CHEMISTS WE DO THAT WE THAT NOW
WILL SEND A CHEMISTRY FACULTY
MEMBER AND WILL WORK OUT A
CONTRACT WITH THE PROGRAM WILL
PROVIDE THAT TRAINING MAYBE
IT'S A WEEK MAYBE IT'S TEN
WEEKS WHATEVER TIME THE COMPANY
WANTS. AND WE YOU KNOW A KIND
WITH THEM TO BRAND WE'RE OUT
AND WE'VE PROVIDED THAT SERVICE
TO THAT WORKPLACE WE DO THAT ON
A REGULAR BASIS. THROUGHOUT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEMS I'M-
AND IF YOU ALSO LOOK THROUGH
THE- HANDBOOK THEIR- WERE OF
THE MID. HERE PER. WE THIS
ONLINE AND INITIATIVE THAT'S
BEEN IN PLACE FOR SEVERAL YEARS
THAT'S VERY SUCCESSFUL BUT
UNDER FUNDED IF WE COULD PUT
MORE MONEY INTO THAT. WE COULD
GROW THAT AND MAKE THAT INTO A
MUCH MORE ROBUST PRO PROGRAM.
AND NO ONE MENTIONED THE ENGINE
A LITTLE BIT THE NUMBERS BUT I
JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THEM.
THAT EVEN WITH THE NEW NUMBERS
THAT WE WERE TOLD THIS MORNING
THIRTY EIGHT STUDENTS ENROLLED
IN THE- CAL BRIGHT COLLEGE. AND
MAYBE A COUPLE HUNDRED IN THE
PIPELINE TOWARDS ENROLLMENT
THERE- KEEP IN MIND WHEN WE'RE
IN THE REGULAR TRADITIONAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. WE
DON'T GET TO COUNT OR GET
FUNDED FOR STUDENTS THAT DON'T
ENROLL IN A CLASS SO FOR
STUDENT TAKES A- KOREAN I'D
TAKES A- PLACEMENT EXAM OR GOES
TO AN ORIENTATION SESSION. OR
MEET WITH A COUNSELOR AND THEN
THEY DON'T ON ROLE WE DON'T GET
ANY REIMBURSEMENT FOR THAT WE
DON'T GET ANY MONEY FOR THAT
THE ONLY STUDENTS WE COUNT. ARE
THE ONES AND ROLLED SO IF YOU
COUNT THE ONES AND ROLLED AND
CAL BRIGHT. THIRTY EIGHT. IT'S
THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS PER PERSON WERE
SPENDING FOR THOSE THIRTY EIGHT
STUDENTS. AND AS YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER CHAIR ROTH. WE HAVE A-
YOU KNOW NOMENCLATURE OF FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS WHICH
IS HOW ARE FUNDING ACTUALLY
ROLLS OUT. SO IF YOU CONVERT
YOU KNOW THAT'S JUST ONE CLASS
AT THEY'RE TAKING. ON AN FTL.
IT'S A THIRTY SEVEN BILLION.
PER FULL TIME. AND MONEY LET'S
PULL ONE TIME MONEY OUT IT'S
STILL FIVE THREE MAY. DOLLARS
PER FTS THAT WE'RE SPENDING
THERE. SO THE COLLEGES GET
ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
A THOUSAND TIMES LESS. PER FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENT IN THE
CALPERS GETTING. SO IF YOU
COULD JUST LIKE DOUBLE OUR
RESOURCE WE WOULD BE IN GREAT
SHAPE. RIGHT NOT WE ARE ASKING
THAT YOU RAISE A BY A THOUSAND
TIMES JUST DOUBLE THAT AND THEN
WE'D BE IN GREAT SHAPE BECAUSE
IF YOU COMPARE THE FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO UC'S CSU.
AND PRISONS WERE WAY AT THE
BOTTOM EVERYONE GETS MORE
FUNDING THAN WE DO PER PUPIL
SO. THAT'S REALLY THE ROOT OF
THIS PROBLEM. IT'S THE DRAMATIC
UNDER FUNDING OUR DRASTIC
UNDERFUNDING OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM IF THERE WAS
MORE MONEY IN THE SYSTEM WE
COULD EXPAND IN ALL OF THESE
AREAS. AND JUST WITH THE
LIMITED RESOURCES WE HAVE AND
WE ARE YOU SEE ON THIS PAPER
THAT IN THE PACKET. NINETY NINE
THOUSAND STUDENTS ARE ALREADY
BEEN SERVED THROUGH THAT
PROGRAM AT A FRACTION OF THE
COST. AND IF YOU READ THROUGH
THE- OTHER OVERVIEW ON PAGE
SEVENTEEN IT TALKS ABOUT
BECAUSE I'M FROM SAN DIEGO SAN
DIEGO CONTINUING THAT. WE'VE
PUT TOGETHER PRETTY MUCH THE
EXACT SAME PROGRAM. AS CAL
BRIGHT FOR FRACTION OF THE COST
THE SAME OPEN ENTRY OPEN EXIT
IT'S FREE TO EVERYBODY. SAME
TYPES OF DEGREES AND
EVERYTHING CAL BRIGHT IS DOING.
IN HOUSE AND AS WE SAID SINCE
THE VERY FIRST MEETING ON THIS.
THERE'S NO REASON TO HAVE THE
SEPARATE ENTITY IT'S NOT
SERVING ANY PURPOSE THAT WE
CAN'T ALREADY SERVE WITHIN THE
EXISTING SYSTEM. SO WE THINK IT
WOULD BE WISE. TO TAKE THESE
RESOURCES AND REDEPLOY THEM IN
SUCH A WAY. THAT WE GET. WE
HAPPEN TO THE ALREADY A- MY
MORE. SINCE IN THAT HAVE IN
PLACE. THROUGH THE OTHER
HUNDRED AND FOUR. AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN THIS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THINK IT GOES TO
THE QUESTION SEVENTY ASK AT THE
VERY BEGINNING OF THIS PROCESS
TO AND- TO DO IT WOULD. IT AND
UNDERSERVED. BEEN OUT THERE IF
THE RESEARCH POPULATION IN OUT
STRUCTURE. BUT YOU CAN AND SET
UP THIS OF OBJECTIVES AND
METRIC SO WE CAN MEASURE
SUCCESS IF THERE IS AN
UNDERSERVED POPULATION AND YOU
SPREAD THE MONEY OUT THEN THE
QUESTION IS IMMEASURABLE AND
CAN WE DETERMINE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE USE OF OUR
FUNDS SO THERE'S SEVERAL
DIFFERENT. QUESTIONS BUT ALL OF
THEM FINAL BACK TO THE FIRST
POINT WHICH IS THERE AN
UNDERSTAND UNSERVED OF CADRE
OF- POTENTIAL STUDENTS FOR
STUDENTS OUT THERE THAT ARE NOT
BEING SERVED BY THE CURRENT
SYSTEM. CAN THIS CURRENT SYSTEM
MODIFIED TO SERVE THEM OR WE DO
WE NEED TO SET UP AN AS WE HAVE
A DIFFERENT STRUCTURE TO DO SO.
SORT OF COMPLICATED ALL OF US I
THINK HAVE THE SAME GOAL AND
OBJECTIVE OVERALL WHICH IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE TAKE
EDUCATION TO STUDENTS WHERE
THEY ARE AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
AT THE END OF THE DAY THEY GET
A PRODUCT THAT MEANS SOMETHING
TO THEM. ALL ALL IF NOT ALWAYS
IS A GOOD PAYING JOB SO.
OBSERVE QUESTIONS AUGUST
ANYTHING FURTHER PANELISTS WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELLO SIR
WE COULD I COMMENT ON THE
ACCREDITATION YES SIR. TWO JUST
SO YOU YOU HEARD US TALK
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE. NOW AND
READ. ACCREDITATION BUT WE
NEVER REALLY TOLD YOU WHAT THE
DIFFERENCE WAS COMPLETELY. THE
MY UNDERSTANDING IS IT'S ONE OF
THEM IS OF WHETHER YOU HAVE A-
GOOD OF. A DEGREE IN SOMETHING
OTHER THAN GENERAL STUDIES. IS
THAT CORRECT ACTUALLY IT'S A
LITTLE MORE COMPLICATED THAN
THAT I FIGURED. THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IS THE-
ENTITY THAT RECOGNIZES
NATIONALLY CREDITORS. ND THEY
THEY ARE SPECIALIZED CREDITORS
PROGRAM BASIC CREDITORS FOR THE
MOST PART THERE IS ONE THAT HAS
THE SOLE MISSION TO A CREDIT.
ONLINE CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION COLLEGES THROUGHOUT
THE NATION WISCONSIN HAS ONE.
THAT NATIONAL ACCREDITATION
CREW IS WHAT CHANCELLOR OAKLEY
WAS TALKING ABOUT THAT
PARTICULAR- AGENCY SO WOULD NOT
NOT BE A REGIONAL IT WOULD BE-
AT A US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
DEALING WITH THE REGULATIONS
AND PROCESS THE LIMITATIONS ON
NATIONAL VERSUS LOCAL. IS THAT
THE CREDITS EARNED BY CAL BRIDE
ARE NOT TRANSFERABLE TO ANY
OTHER COLLEGE IN CALIFORNIA NOT
CSU NOT UC NOT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WE CAN ONLY ACCEPT
UNITS FROM REGIONALLY EC
ACCREDITED- COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. SO IF SOMEONE
DROPPED OUT OF THAT CODING
CLASS. AND WANTED TO USE THE
CREDITS THAT THEY HAD EARNED
TWO COMPLETED AT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IT WOULDN'T BE
PERMISSIBLE. COULD TALKING BUT
STRANDED CERTIFICATE HOLDERS AS
OPPOSED TO SIMPLY STRANDED
WORKERS YES THAT'S THAT'S
CORRECT THE CURRENT. MODEL IS
NON CREDIT. NO BUT THAT COULD
THEN BE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
ACCREDITATION ROOM RIGHT. SO
IT'S COMPLICATED. ASSEMBLY BUT
NON CREDIT UNDER CURRENT LAW
AND REGULATIONS DOESN'T RESULT
IN ASSOCIATE DEGREE WHICH
ATTRACTS THE DIRECTION YOU GAVE
THE COLLEGE IF IT IS AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE YOU WOULD HAVE
TO. AND HAVE TO BE A CREDIT
DEGREE YES RIGHT YES BUT THAT
ISN'T THE- SO WITH THAT WITH A
SPECIFIC CONCENTRATION IS ABOUT
THAT'S RIGHT SO. WITH NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION AND THE LIMITS ON
TRANSFER OF CREDIT BAD CREDIT
ASSOCIATE DEGREE WOULD ALSO BE
A STRANDED DEGREE. SO THE
ACCREDITATION IS MY PRESENTS
MORE COMPLICATED- LIMITATIONS
ON CALIBRATE THAT. SOME OF
WHICH TO LIMIT ITS ABILITY TO
ACHIEVE WHAT'S IN- THE BUDGET
ACT. JUST WANTED TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT THIS THERE'S NO
ASSOCIATE DEGREES WITH NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION THANK YOU
DOCTRINES OR CREDIT WENT TO.
JUST JUST QUICKLY I THINK THIS
IS VERY HELPFUL IN MUDDYING THE
WATERS- SO THIS IS A
CONVERSATION MAYBE FOR ANOTHER
DAY- WITH VERY CLEAR WE KNOW
THAT ALL OF THE PANEL EXCEPT
KIMBERLY I AM IN YOUR BOAT
KIMBERLY- THINK THAT WE SHOULD
TRY AND MOVE FORWARD AND DO
SOMETHING TO MEET STUDENTS
WHERE THEY ARE I WILL ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH. THE CHAIRS
COMMENTS ABOUT TRYING TO FIGURE
THIS OUT BUT I THINK THAT THIS
THIS CONVERSATION NOW MISTER
CHAIR IS JUST MUDDYING THE
WATERS ON WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE TODAY. SIR. YOU GET THE
MONEY THEM FURTHER HELLO
ACTUALLY WHAT I WANTED TO SAY
IS THE ACADEMIC SENATE EXISTS
IN STATUTE- AND REGULATION TO
HELP IMPLEMENT WHATEVER THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDES CURRENT
LEGISLATION IS- A SEPARATE
DISTRICT IN COLLEGE AND WE ARE
TRYING OUR BEST TO SERVE THAT
FUNCTION- AS BEST WE CAN- I DO
THINK WE HAVE LEARNED SOME
THINGS IN THE LAST TWO YEARS-
AND I APPRECIATE THE LEGEND
SURE I'M CENTERING HOW WE MOVE
FORWARD AT THIS MILESTONE
MARKER. I THINK THAT WE'VE
LEARNED. WE HAVE A DIFFICULT
TIME WITH JOB PLACEMENT
SERVICES LOCALLY WE AREN'T
FUNDED I FOR TO DO THAT KIND OF
WORK. WE KNOW THERE MAY BE SOME
NEED FOR STATEWIDE
COORDINATION. EFFORTS OF- HAVE
SOME AREAS AND SOME THAT
PROBABLY DON'T. ENTER AND THAT
THEIR SERVICE DIFFERENTLY I
THINK WE HAVE HIGHLIGHTED
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT INTERNALLY IN THE SYSTEM
ABOUT HOW WE ENCOURAGE- NON
CREDIT AND COMPETENCY BASED
EDUCATION IN OUR SYSTEM AND
THAT WE KNOW EXPLICITLY THE
BARRIERS THAT MAKE THAT LESS
DESIRABLE- FOR COLLEGES TO MAKE
THOSE CHOICES. AND I THINK WE
KNOW THAT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE IS UNDER FUNDED TO DO
SOME OF THOSE FUNCTIONS- THAT
THEY COULD BE DOING THAT NEED
TO THAT NEEDS SYSTEM MIGHT
INSTRUCTION. AND I THINK WE
LEARNED THAT WHEN THE SYSTEM IS
PROVIDED WITH MONEY AND CLEAR
DIRECTION TO EXPAND IN C. T. E.
IN THIS AREA. THAT THE CITY
ONLINE PATHWAYS GRANT FOR
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
RESULTS AT FOUR HUNDRED SEVEN
NEW AND IMPROVED PATHWAYS AND
NINETY NINE THOUSAND STUDENTS
SERVED IN TWO YEARS AND SO THIS
IS INFORMATION HELPS US MOVE
FORWARD- AT THIS POINT AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE THAT
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO
ALL OF THOSE ARE VERY VALID
POINTS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO I
KNOW I SPEAK FOR MY COLLEAGUES.
IN WORKING WITH THE EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU AND WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCES
OFFICE IN THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS AND ALL OF THOSE
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS IN
TRYING TO GET THIS RIGHT. THINK
IF ANYONE LEAVES. OF THIS
HEARING ROOM OF WAS NOTHING
ELSE SHE SHOULD LEAVE IT WITH
THAT TO. QUESTIONS ARE
QUESTIONS TRYING TO GET
INFORMATION AND NOT AN
INDICATION OF ANYTHING ELSE SO
WHAT THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND WE WILL NOW
PROCEED TO. THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
YES SHE THE MOVEMENT. IT'S BEEN
IT'S BEEN PLEASE PROCEED YOUR
NAME AND WHO YOU REPRESENT AND
A BRIEF OF. DEPENDING ON THE
LENGTH OF THE LINE- COULD BE
VERY BRIEF BUT- FIRST THING WE
NEED TO DO IS TURN ON HIS ON
IT'S ON HER RIGHT HI MY NAME'S
DOCTOR DEBORAH HENRY THANK YOU
SENATORS FOR LISTENING TO US- I
REPRESENT COASTLINE COLLEGE.
ACADEMIC SENATE PRESIDENT I'M
ALSO PROFESSOR OF ANATOMY AND
PHYSIOLOGY. THIS IS NOT MY
FIRST CAREER THIS TO MY SECOND
SO I HAVE TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT
TO MOUNT SAC PEOPLE BECAUSE I'M
A PHYSICIAN BY TRAINING A
PRACTICE FOR A LONG TIME WHEN I
WAS IN PRACTICE- NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE A TOOK BUSINESS
CLASSES IN THE EVENING AT MOUNT
SAC BECAUSE THAT WAS LACKING IN
MY MEDICAL EDUCATION. AND SO I
WROTE MY BUSINESS PLANS ON
STAMPS THOSE PLANS FOR AWHILE-
I HAVE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WAS BROUGHT UP LIKE
HELP THE TICKET BACK HELP BREAK
PANEL THAT WERE INACCURATE- ONE
OF THE FIRST ONES IS THAT
COASTLINE IS NOT A 100% ONLINE.
WE ARE 70% ONLINE WE HAVE BEEN
ONLINE SINCE NINETEEN SEVEN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN SO WE
HAVE TWENTY THREE YEARS
EXPERIENCE OF TAKE TO TEACHING
ONLINE CLASSES- I TEACH BOTH
ONLINE AND ON SITE CENTER TO
NOW TO ME BY NOW TO ME IS ON
SITE BUT ALSO OF AN ANATOMY AND
PHYSIOLOGY CLASS IT'S AN
INTRODUCTORY CLASS. THAT I
TEACH ONLINE THAT I'VE BEEN
DOING SEVERAL YEARS. SOME OF
THE- OTHER ISSUES ARE- BUT THE
THREE COURSES SO CAL BRIGHT NOW
OFFERS THE FIRST THING CAL BY
PROMISED WAS THEY WOULD NOT
OFFER OF COURSE ISN'T READY
BEING OFFERED WE'RE NOT
DUPLICATE ON. A COASTLINE
OFFERS MEDICAL CODING WE'VE
BEEN DOING THATFOR SEVERAL. AT
LEAST ON SOME TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE I STORE THERE STARBURST.
FOR TO PROBE SINCE I SECURE
SISTER. AND ONE IS. OKAY SO
THAT'S ALREADY BEING OFFERED.
COURSE THAT'S WHEN YOUR PHONE
TURNED OFF RIGHT- OF TO ADDRESS
ISSUES OF WORKING FORCE WORKING
LEARNERS OVER 50% OF OUR
STUDENTS WORK ALL RIGHT SO WE
HAVE MOST OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
WORKING LEARNERS- OUR HEAD
COUNT IS TWENTY SIX THOUSAND.
SO WE ADDRESS TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS ARE READY
RATHER THAN THIRTY SIX AND
AGAIN 70% OTHERS ARE TAKING
ONLINE COURSES OUR AVERAGE AGE
IS TWENTY NINE SO WE ARE
ADDRESSING THIS. APPARENT NEED
IN THAT AGE GROUP AND OUR AGE
GROUP GOES FROM NINETEEN TO
OVER. FIFTY THERE IS A- WE
HAVE- EMPLOYER CONTRACTS WE
HAVE SIXTEEN CURRENTLY
INCLUDING THE S. S. E. C. U. I
THINK I SAID THAT RIGHT THE
UNION WITH THE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS- SO WE HAVE SIXTEEN
IMPORT CONTRACTS IF YOU NEED TO
KNOW THOSE NAMES I HELP THEM-
WE- ARE LOOKING AT COMPASS HE
BASED LEARNING. WE HAVE FOUR WE
COURSES WITH EIGHT WEEK COURSES
WITH COURSES SO START IN
JANUARY WITH COURSES A START
MID TERM WE OF COURSE IS A STAR
AT THE END TERM WITH COURSES
AND SUMMER. OF WE HAVE COURSES
DURING AN INTERCESSION SO WE
HAVE REVOLVING COURSES THAT
OCCUR ALL THE TIME WE'RE
LOOKING AT COMPASS SEAS BASED
COURSES WE HAVE A GRANT FOR
DOING THAT NOW AND I AM VERY
FAMILIAR WITH COMPETENCY BASED
BECAUSE BEING A SEARCH. YOU
WOULD HOPE YOUR SURGEON IS
COMPETENT ALL RIGHT SO COMPUTER
BASED TRADING IS DEAR TO MY
HEART. DOCTOR THEIR PASSING THE
HOOK DOWN. I'M SORRY YEAH I'M
IT'S TOO MUCH. PASSING THE DOWN
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO WRAP UP
DOCTOR IF YOU COULD ALL RIGHT-
WE ARE A BIT BIG AND- WE AYE
AND WE'RE ALSO BIG AND- WE ARE-
WE CAN OFFER ENTIRE DEGREE-
WITH OPEN EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES
SO IT'S NO COST OF STUDENT- AND
WE HAVEN'T HEARD OPTION TO PATH
WITH US ACTUALLY. TOTALLY WE
ARE- WE'RE BOTH HISPANIC AND A
PC GRANT OR OUR SERVICE
ORIENTATION SO WE SERVICE ALL
DIFFERENT TYPES OF POPULATION.
SO IN AND DOING ALL THIS I
WOULD SAY THAT WHAT YOU HAVE
BEEN CALLED CALPERS YOU'RE
ALREADY HAVE FOR IN STATE OF.
EXTREMELY LOWER COST- WE ADJUST
ON THE SIDE IF THE STUDENT
CENTER FUNDING FOR MILLER WERE
FUNDED. CAN JUST ABOUT THAT
MONEY COULD FROM THE STUDENT
CENTER FUNDING FOR MILLER. AND
THAT WOULD HELP US GROW AND
SERVER THIS. AND TO. THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE A COUPLE. THANK
YOU DOCTOR. HOPEFULLY YOU
COVERED MY THE POINT THAT YOU
NEXT. WHAT THE COVER. HOPEFULLY
BUT I'M NOT A DOCTOR. I THINK
THAT'S OKAY THANK YOU TERM ROTH
AND SENATORS I'M TONY BARCELOS
I SERVE ON THE FACULTY AT
AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE WHICH IS
PART OF THE LOS RIOS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT HERE LOCALLY I
ALSO SERVE ON THE EXECUTIVE
BOARD OF THE A LAS RIOS-
COLLEGE FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
AND- I'M PLEASED TO BE BACK IN
FOR TWO OR THREE WHICH I USED
TO FREQUENT. BACK WHEN I WORKED
ON TE SENATE STAFF MY BOSS WAS
ALBERT RADHA CHAIRMAN OF THE
SENATE FINANCE COMMITTEE A
PREDECESSOR OF YOUR CURRENT
BUDGET AND APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEES. SO IT'S NICE TO BE
BACK. I AM NOT SPEAKING JUST AS
A PROFESSOR AT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. I'M A PRODUCT OF A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I'M ALUMNUS
OF PORTABLE COLLEGE DOWN AND
TULARE COUNTY- WHICH MEANS
THAT. I WAS A CONSTITUENT OF
THE LEGENDARY ROSE AND FOR
WHICH THE FIRST WOMAN IN THE
STATE SENATE. MY CONCERN ABOUT
CAL BRIGHT HAS BEEN SINCE THE
VERY BEGINNING IT'S DUPLICATIVE
NATURE. AND IT'S EXPENSIVE
NATURE. WE WERE TOLD THAT WE
WEREN'T DOING ENOUGH TO SERVE
CERTAIN THINGS LIKE UP MEDICAL
CODING. OUR HEALTH ED
PROFESSORS WOULD BE HAPPY TO DO
LOTS MORE TRAINING OF MEDICAL
CODERS IF THEY HAD THE-
FINANCING FOR IT IT'S SIMPLY A
MATTER. OF THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE EXISTING ONLINE PROGRAMS
WE HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE. WE
HAVE THE MANAGEMENT. NOT AS
COMPENSATED AS CAL BRYCE
MANAGEMENT BUT WE HAVE THE
MANAGEMENT WE HAVE TECH SUPPORT
WE HAVE FACULTY AND WE HAVE
STUDENTS. AND IF THE FUNDING
WERE THERE WE WOULD BE THERE TO
DO THE JOB AND SO I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. AND I'M DONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
BREVITY. NEXT YES GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND FOR HEARING US AND I
THINK THIS IS BEEN AN IMPORTANT
HEARING I THINK THAT YOU'VE
HEARD A LOT OF THINGS THAT-
NEED TO BE THOUGHT ABOUT
REVIEWED I THINK MR MAILER MADE
APPOINTED IF YOU'RE PAYING
ATTENTION WE'RE DONE HERE- I
THINK OR SOMETHING TO THAT I
JUST WANT TO DRAW YOUR TENSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DINA REQUESTED
FOR JOINT LEGISLATIVE
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE THE
TO BEING DONE OF CAL BRIGHT TO
SEE HOW THEY'RE DOING WITH
THEIR METRICS AND WHERE THE
MONEY TO GOING THE- SAME
BUILDING COULD YOU TO SUPPORT
ABOUT IT AND- CAREFULLY. WHEN
COMES OUT BECAUSE I THINK THAT
WE NEED IS MORE INFORMATION
SPECIFIC INFORMATION SEE HOW
WE'RE DOING AND I THINK TO SOME
INFO CAN BE PRESENTED HERE
TODAY KILEY CLEAR OR ACCURATE I
THINK THE AUDIT WOULD BE. THANK
YOU. THIS BILL. TAKE A LOOK AT
ADDED WHEN BROADER REQUEST WHEN
IT COMES BEFORE THE APPROPRIATE.
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR A ROTH
INTER LEYVA. NEXT TO ME AT THE
SAME THE NEXT IN CALIFORNIA AND
IF WE ARE DEEPLY EMBEDDED IN
OUR WORK ON. ADDRESS IN INCOME
INEQUALITY. AND AS SUCH WE HAVE
BEEN STRONG SUPPORTERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF CALIBRATE.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS A BETTER.
SUPPORT WORKFORCE TRAINING
INCREASE ALIGNMENT BETWEEN
AVAILABLE TRAINING AND EMPLOYER
NEEDS. THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT CAL
RIGHT IS MEANT TO DO AND IS
MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS W
BELIEVE TAT CALPERS MEANS
FOCUS ON CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS
THAT PROVIDE COLLEGE AND CAREER
SKILLS. THAT CAN REPEL STUDENTS
INTO ATTAINING HIGHER EDUCATION
DEGREES. AND INTO THE WORK
FORCE IN A FIELD WITH GROWTH.
AND IF YOU NEED TO PASS THREE
CALIBRATE OFFERS EMPLOYERS A
DIRECT LINE OF INTO. RIPARIAN
ARC RETURNING WORK FORCE. AND
OURS WAS A POOR CONNECTION
WE'VE BEEN ESTABLISHED IN OUR
FREE MY FUTURE SPEND AT WORK UP
AT. MONTHS STUDENT AT PRO. AT
WEAVER SEEN IN BARBERS. PRESS
WHO IN THEMSELVES IN. IN THE
SITUATIONS THAT THEY ARE.
BECAUSE THEY'RE- A PREDATORY
FOR PROFIT COLLEGES OUR
COMMUNITY. COLLEGE HAS TOM IS
PROGRAM THAT IS ACCESSIBLE. FOR
UP A GOOD JOB AT THE A LINE
BASICALLY A PROGRAM THAT WAS
PROMISED WILL MEET THEIR NEEDS
AND WHERE THERE AT AND THIS IS
WHERE CAL. AS STEP IN. OFFERING
SOLELY ENROLLMENT THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR WITH PROGRAMS LOOK
DIRECTLY LINKED TO EMPLOYER
NEEDS. AND A CURRICULUM THAT IS
I GO AT YOUR OWN PACE AND SO WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S. CHECKS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
AT EVERY STEP OF THE WAY SO
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING. WE BELIEVE THAT
CALIBRATE HAS BEEN MAKING THE
NECESSARY STEPS TO MEET THEIR
LEGISLATIVE OBLIGATIONS. AND
GIVEN MORE TIME TO ESTABLISH A
BRAND NEW COLLEGE OF AND GET A
FULLER PICTURE WHAT'S HAPPENING
AT THE SITUATION. THAT WILL SEE
THAT CALIBRATED BE ABLE TO MEET
ITS POTENTIAL TO PROVIDE THIS
KIND OF EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE
TRAINING THAT NONTRADITIONAL
RETURNING STUDENT SEEK. AND
NEED THE NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
MEANS THE SPORT CAL RIGHT HAPPY
TO CONTINUE OFFERING HER
SUPPORT AND RESOURCES. BOTH OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND ACCOUNT
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU NEXT. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
MASURIA FROM YOUNG PRINCIPLES
REPRESENT YOUNG ADULTS
CALIFORNIA AGES EIGHTEEN TO
THIRTY FOUR. OF ABOUT TWO YEARS
AGO WE SPOKE WITH STUDENTS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE. AND INITIAL
PLANNING STAGES OF CALIBRATE
OUR ADULTS THOSE WHO CAN I
ENTER. THROUGH THE COMMITTEE
CALL SYSTEM FOR MULTI REASONS
IN CALIFORNIA'S COST CRISIS. DO
DO FROM COMMITMENTS AND
OVERWHELM ME THE OVERWHELMING
SUPPORT. THE CALIBRATION- MANY
OF THEM HAD CONSIDERED A FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES. AS A MEANS TO
RECEIVE SPECIALIZED TRAININGS
BELIEVING THAT DEBT. THE TOOK
ON. WOULD BE AN OFFSET BY THEIR
NEWLY ACQUIRED EARNING
POTENTIAL. SO THAT'S WHY WE
SUPPORTED IN THE PAST. WE KNOW
THAT FOR PUBLIC COLLEGES PREY
ON THE STUDENTS IN THE GRAPHICS.
I'M ESPECIALLY NONTERMINAL
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF LOW
INCOME FOR THAT REASON YOU
INDIVIDUALS CURRENTLY SUPPORTS
THIS MODEL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT. GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR PUTTING
TOGETHER THIS HEARING MY NAME
IS GAIL YEAH AND I'M WITH
CALIFORNIA COMPETES HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR SHOWING CONNIE-
OUR WORK FOCUSES ON AND THE
TALK MILLION ADULTS WHO HAVE
BETWEEN THE AGES OF TWENTY FIVE
TO SIXTY FOUR THAT HAVE NO
COLLEGE DEGREE- BUT ALSO THE
FOUR MILLION THAT HAVE SOME
COLLEGE BUT DIDN'T COMPLETE AND
SO WE SEE CALVARY AS A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY. TO HELP
REIMAGINE ONLINE LEARNING AND
TO HELP GET THE STUDENTS TO
ENTER HIGHER AT- BUT WE DO
RECOMMENDS THAT CALIBRATE
PARTNER WITH EXISTING ON
SUCCESSFUL. PROGRAMS AT
SPECIFIC COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR
AT A SIXTEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES
LIKE THOSE SHASTA XCELERATED
COLLEGE EDUCATION PROGRAM. FROM
THE COMBINE TYPE OR COMBINES
FACE TO FACE AN ONLINE
LEARNING- AND SO SUCH
COLLABORATIONS WILL ALSO
REQUIRE THEM TO WORK WITH
STUDENTS AND FACULTY AND SO AS
WELL IT WILL HELP WITH STUDENT
SUCCESS. AND TO HELP DRIVE
ECONOMIC GROWTH THINK THANK YOU
FOR YOUR NEXT- YES THE-
CHARACTER LATER THANK YOU FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING. MY NAME
IS MICHAEL SHEETS AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE VENTURA
COUNTY FEDERATION OF COLLEGE
TEACHERS AFT LOCALLY CAN TWENTY
EIGHT. I JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IN URGING YOU TO DO
THE RIGHT THING FOR THE FUTURE
PUBLIC EDUCATION CALIFORNIA.
CALIBRATE COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS
NOT JUST A BAD IDEA IT'S
HARMFUL TO THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION. IN THE STATE RANKED
FORTY FIRST IN THE NATION ON
PUBLIC ON SPENDING FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION WE CANNOT AFFORD. TO
THROW GOOD MONEY AFTER BAD AND
CONTINUE ON THIS PATH. TO BE
CLEAR WE RECOGNIZE HOW YOU OF
TAKING EDUCATION TO THE
STUDENTS WHERE IT'S MOST NEEDED
IN FACT I HAVE LONG BEEN A
SUPPORTER OF ONLINE EDUCATION
AND CURRENTLY TEACH BOTH ONLINE
AND HYBRID COURSES HOWEVER. IN
THE STATE IN WHICH WE
CONTINUALLY STRUGGLE YEAR AFTER
YEAR STRETCH ARE LIMITED
EDUCATIONAL DOLLARS AMONG OUR
EXISTING PUBLIC SCHOOLS.%
SPENDING THE OUTRAGEOUS AMOUNT
OF MONEY NECESSARY TO SUPPORT A
REDUNDANT AND EFFICIENT PROGRAM
IS ALLEGE. MOUSE AND OF THE
VERY MY- IN. I DID MISS ME. FOR
WE ARE. IS A MY- CAP COMMUNE
KERR ARE CANCER WAS THE SOUTH
OF RIGHT 3% UP HUNDRED FIVE THE-
A YEAR. TO A PMR SO. PATIENT
UNDER. IN MY DAY ARE.
APPOINTMENTS THE ALREADY
OUTSTANDING ACADEMIC EXCELLENCE
OF OUR ON GROUND COURSES IN
WHAT UNIVERSE DOES IT MAKE
SENSE TO SPEND TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO EDUCATE FOUR
HUNDRED TO STUDENTS WHO YEAR.
WHEN EXISTING HUNDRED FOURTEEN
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
ALREADY IDEALLY SITUATED TO
MEET THE EMERGING NEEDS OF OUR
STATE. OUR DISTRICT BUDGET
HOVERS NEAR A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
AND EVERY YEAR WE STRUGGLE TO
MEET THE ON GOING FINANCIAL
BURDENS. OF DELIVERING THE
QUALITY EDUCATION OUR STUDENTS
DESERVE. INSTEAD OF WASTING THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
CALIBRATE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
REQUIRES TO STAY VIABLE.
REINVEST THE MONEY WHERE IT
BELONGS IN LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ONLINE PROGRAMS THAT
ACTUALLY HELP STUDENTS ACHIEVE
THEIR DREAMS. ON BEHALF OF THE
A FEW LOCAL EIGHTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT I URGE YOU TO MAKE THE
NECESSARY COURSE CORRECTIONS IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. REMAINS THE HIGH
QUALITY PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES DESERVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR NEXT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HOLDING
HEARINGS GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS NIKKI GONZALEZ HERE AND I'M
A FACULTY MEMBER AT DE ANZA
COLLEGE IN CUPERTINO. TOM
ALRIGHT BOOSTERS HAVE
CRITICIZED OUR EXISTING HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN COLLEGES FOR NOT
ADEQUATELY SERVING PEOPLE OF
COLOR. AND THOSE WITHOUT
COLLEGE DEGREES SO CALLED
STRANDED WORKERS. BUT CAL PRIDE
IS NOT DEMONSTRATED THAT THEY
CAN DO BETTER CERTAINLY NOT
BETTER ENOUGH TO JUSTIFY THEIR
EXTRAORDINARY FUNDING LEVELS.
IF THE CAL BRED APPROACH IS
SUPERIOR. THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO POINT TO IMMEDIATE POSITIVE
RESULTS IN THEIR ENROLLMENT
DATA AFTER ALL CAL BRIGHT HAS
BEEN BUILT FROM THE GROUND UP.
WITH THIS SUPPOSEDLY UNIQUE
METHODOLOGY TAILORED TO THE
VERY SPECIFIC STUDENT
POPULATION. THEY SAY NEEDS TO
BE SERVED BUT THE EVIDENCE DOES
NOT SUPPORT THIS CLAIM IN FACT.
QUITE THE OPPOSITE FIRST CAL
BRIDESMAID AND STUDENT BODY IS
TINY. SECOND THEY SERVED ABOUT
A THIRD OF THE PERCENTAGE OF
LATIN ACT STUDENT SAYS THE
SYSTEM AS A WHOLE BUT ALMOST
50% MORE WHITE STUDENTS. THEIR
STUDENTS ARE THREE TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE BA DEGREES AND
THE REST OF THE SYSTEM BUT ONLY
TWO THIRDS IS LIKELY TO HAVE NO
TO CREATE ALL. THE COW PRINT
BREWSTER'S MADE BIG WAS BASED
ON A THEORY THAT THEIR APPROACH
IS SPECIAL BUT IF THERE ARE
SPECIAL THE EVIDENCE FOR SAYS
IT'S NOT THE KIND OF SPECIAL
THAT ANYBODY WOULD WANT TO WRAP.
AND CERTAIN NOT KINDEST. THIS
SHOULD. TO FIND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT. I THINK
YOU GET AFTER TH. HI MY NAME IS
JENNIFER XIN I'M PRESS OF THE
PROUD TO FEDERAL OF TO IF TO
LOCAL SIXTY NO THREE I
REPRESENT THE SOME ONE
THOUSAND- FACULTY WHO WORK IN
THE PEARL TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT- CALIBRATE IS SITUATED
LITERALLY IN THE BACKYARD OF
THE PEARL TO. COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. IT IS COMPETING FOR
MANY OF THE STUDENTS ARE GOING
TO FOR PROFIT COLLEGES AS WAS
NOTED TODAY BUT IT'S ALSO
DIRECTLY COMPETING FOR OUR
STUDENTS. COLLEGE WHICH OFFERS
BOTH IT AND CYBERSECURITY
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE BEING
OFFERED TO CALIBRATE. HAS A
STUDENT POPULATION THAT'S 27%
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND 27% LATIN
ACTS. THIS IS THE TARGET
POPULATION THAT WE WERE TOLD
TODAY IS THE TARGET POPULATION
FOR CALIBRATE. WE ARE ALREADY
SERVING THAT POPULATION BUT WE
DON'T HAVE THE SUPPORT THAT WE
NEED TO SUFFICIENTLY HELP THOSE
STUDENTS AND ASSIST THOSE
STUDENTS AND WE CERTAINLY DON'T
HAVE A MARKETING BUDGET THAT
ALLOWS US TO RECRUIT STUDENTS
FROM AROUND THE STATE. THE
ONLINE OPTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
DESCRIBED TODAY ARE ALREADY
AVAILABLE AT OUR COLLEGES AS
YOU'VE HEARD- WE HAVE SYSTEMS
IN PLACE TO STEWART SERVE OUR
STUDENTS AND SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY. BUT WE DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES THAT WE NEED TO
FULLY SUPPORT THOSE STUDENTS OR%
THE SYSTEMS. THAT ARE HELPING
THEM. WHAT WE NEED IS NOT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTEENTH COLLEGE
WE NEED TO INVEST IN THE
EXISTING COLLEGES INCLUDING
THOSE IN OUR PEARL TO DISTRICT.
AND I WON ONE ADD ONE OTHER
NOTE- THERE WAS SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT CHARTER SCHOOLS CHARTER
SCHOOLS ORIGINALLY WERE TOUTED
AS THESE CENTERS OF INNOVATIVE
LEARNING- THEY WERE ORIGINALLY
INTENDED TO AUGMENT TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOL. SCHOOLS AND
INSTEAD WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS THAT
THEY'VE SIPHON DOLLARS AWAY
FROM OUR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AND
THEY'VE DONE SO IN MANY WAYS BY
CIRCUMVENTING SOME OF THE RULES
AND REGULATIONS OF OUR
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT MAKE THAT
SAME MISTAKE WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND I URGE ALL OF US
TO MAKE THAT DECISION. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME MY
NAME IS ANGER STARK AND I'M A
FACULTY MEMBER AT LANEY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN OAKLAND
AND A DISTANCE EDUCATION
COORDINATOR FOR THE PEARL TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AS A
WHOLE. AND I'M HERE TO URGE YOU
NOT TO CONTINUE TO FUND THE
LAUNCH OF THE CALIBRATE SYSTEM
NEW COLLEGE. BUT INSTEAD TO RE
ROUTE THOSE FUNDS TO EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES AND I
WAS GONNA SAY A BUNCH OF STUFF
THAT ONE I DO FEEL LIKE IT IS
TO PUT IT IS. AND I ALSO FEEL
LIKE IT'S AN INORDINATE AMOUNT
OF MONEY TO LAUNCH- SUCH A
SMALL AND I'M SORT OF RISKY
INITIATIVE. BUT INSTEAD OF
REHASHING NOT I'D LIKE TO MAKE
A SUGGESTION. AND THAT IS THAT
YOU CONSIDER RE USING THOSE
FUNDS FOR TO A DISTINCT GRAMS
BUT OUR X. ORDINARY AND ALREADY
DOING THE THINGS. IS TRYING.
DISTRICT FOR COLLEGES WILL BE
SUBMITTING OUR LOCATIONS THAT
CONSORTIUM NEXT WEEK AND WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED BECAUSE THEY
ALREADY ARE INNOVATIVE AND
BUILDING A STATEWIDE ONLINE
COLLEGE. WERE STUDENTS FROM
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE CAN
ENROLL IN TAKE COURSES AND
COMPLETE COURSEWORK AT COLLEGES
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE. YES IT
MIGHT BE A TINY BIT BEHIND ON
ONE SMALL PORTION THE EXCHANGE
BUT THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND THE GROWTH AND
THE TRAINING THAT HAS ALREADY
HAPPENED IS REALLY
EXTRAORDINARY. THE SECOND IS
ONE THAT YOU CHAIR ROF
MENTIONED AND IT'S CALLED THE
ONLINE CITY PATHWAYS
INITIATIVE. AND IT'S A GRANT
THAT WAS GIVEN OUT OF THIS YEAR
TO A NUMBER OF COLLEGES IN THIS
DISTRICT I BELIEVE IT'S ABOUT%
EIGHTY I MEAN THE STATE ABOUT
THE COLLEGES. TO SPECIFICALLY
GROW ON CREATE INNOVATION AND
GROW THE CTP PROGRAMS THEY ARE
A LITTLE BIT MORE DIFFICULT TO
PUT IT ON MY INVITE. AND IS
FUNDING ALL THESE COLLEGES
ACROSS THE STREET ALREADY TO
INNOVATE AND TRY TO PUT THOSE
ON LINE. TO CONTINUE THAT GRANT
BEYOND JUST ONE YEAR YOU WOULD
GET SO MUCH MORE VALUE FOR THE
MONEY THE PUTTING SO MUCH INTO
THE CAL BRIGHT. SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS NEXT YES
MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
RALPH CHAIR LEYVA I'M DEBBIE
KLEIN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND I'M PROUD TO BE A FACULTY
MEMBER FOR TWENTY YEARS NOW IN
OUR SYSTEM I TEACH
ANTHROPOLOGY. A GAVEL IN
COLLEGE AND I'M HERE TO ECHO
WHAT MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ALREADY SAID. SO WHEN THE
CONCEPT FOR CALIBRATE WAS
INITIALLY PROPOSED FAQ OFFERED
A MORE COST EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVE THAT WOULD BETTER
SERVE STUDENTS STATEWIDE AND
REGIONALLY WE STILL BELIEVE AND
INCREASING INVESTMENT IN THE
ONLINE EDUCATION INITIATIVE
pA LOT HERE. THIS REMAINS THE
BEST PATH FORWARD INSTEAD OF
CONTINUED FUNDING FOR
CALIBRATE. THIS SPRING OVER ONE
HUNDRED CTE COURSES HAVE BEEN
CONVERTED TO THE ONLINE
MODALITY WHICH WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT. THAT'S AROUND ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO
WILL COMPLETE THESE COURSES
THIS YEAR INCREASED INVESTMENT
IN OUR EXISTING ONLINE
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS ALREADY
PROVEN SUCCESSFUL. WE
UNDERSTAND THE GOAL OF OUT
COMPETING FOR PROFIT COLLEGES.
OUR EXISTING MODEL DOES IT
BETTER AND CHEAPER THAN THE FOR
PROFITS. WE CAN ALL BE PROUD OF
THAT. PLEASE ALRP CAO BRIGHT SO.
TO X. KERN. MY FOR A- FACT FOR
IS CELL AS A- TO THE LEAD. TO
FROM RIGHT BUT STILL. WILL BE
SIR PAUL CAO. BECAUSE STUDENT.
THANK YOU THANKS THANKS TIME.
FOR GOOD AFTERNOON SHERMAN
LEYVA GOOD AFTERNOON GERMAN RAW
MY NAME'S MILE MISS AT THE CALL.
AND WE SAY TO PROOF. TO ATTEND
THE CALL. IT'S A COME THAT HAS
T. LIKE ABOUT THE STUDENTS. HAS
A DIVERSE POPULATION WITH
PEOPLE OF ALL CAREERS AND AGES
RIGHT HAS A MYRIAD OF RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT STUDENTS AND THESE
ARE ALL THINGS WHICH ARE
ABSENCE FROM CAL BREAKS RIGHT
IT'S AN ONLINE COLLEGE WHO
SENSUALLY WEBSITE. RIGHT WITH
NO FULL TIME FACULTY NO
ESTABLISH STRUCTURES OF
OVERSIGHT AND DUPLICATE CLASSES
WHICH ARE LEGAL. RIGHT NOW
UNDERSTAND THE EXCUSE THAT HAS
BEEN GIVEN FOR FUNDING CAL
BRIGHT WAS THAT IT IT WOULD
SERVICE SPECIFIC POPULATION OF
STUDENTS WHOSE NEEDS WERE NOT
WITHIN THE SCOPE OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. BUT THE REASON THE
STUDENTS NEEDS ARE NOT MET BUT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BECAUSE THEY
LIKE THE FUNDING NECESSARY TO
DO THAT. AS JIM MILLER
MENTIONED COMMUNITY COLLEGES
RECEIVE THE LOWEST PER PER
PUPIL FUNDING OF ANY KIND OF
INSTITUTION IN CALIFORNIA. BOTH
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYER PARTICIPATION-
PROGRAMS WHICH ALREADY EXISTS
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
WITH EXTRA FUNDING. THESE
PROGRAMS COULD BE EXPANDED. AND
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY MENTIONED
FACULTY TRAINS SPECIFICALLY TO
CATER TO WORKING STUDENTS
NEEDS. AND I'M STILL A LITTLE
CONFUSED AS TO WHAT THAT MEANS
EXACTLY. BUT I'VE BEEN DEMANDS
A LONG ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT THE
FACULTY THERE IS PERFECTLY WELL
TRAINED ENOUGH. TO CATER TO
WORKING STUDENTS RIGHT IF
ANYTHING IT WOULD BENEFIT THE
MORE TO ALLOCATE FUNDS TO
EXPAND THE FACULTY IN BETTER
COMPENSATE THEM. SO ALL IN ALL
IF YOU WERE TO INVEST THESE
FUNDS INTO OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES NOT ONLY WOULD YOU
ALLOW FOR A LARGER DIVERSE CITY
OF PROGRAMS TO BE OFFERED.
WHICH WOULD ALSO BE PROVIDING
STUDENTS WITH MORE THAN JUST A
BROWSER TAB ON THEIR COMPUTER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS YES
SIR. THANK YOU FIRST OF ALL FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING I'M ROB
SCHNEIDERMAN ON THE PRESIDENT
THE COAST FEDERATION EDUCATORS
WE REPRESENT ABOUT A THOUSAND
FULL AND PART TIME FACULTY DOWN
ORANGE COUNTY. AND AS YOU KNOWS
STATEWIDE ENROLLMENT HAS BEEN
DECLINING AND I'M IN MEETINGS
DAY IN AND DAY OUT WITH THE
THREE COLLEGES ORANGE COAST
COLLEGE GOLDEN WEST COLLEGE IN
COASTLINE COLLEGE WE'RE JUST
WORKING HARD TO FIND WAYS TO
INCREASE OUR FULL TIME IN ROMAN
R. F. T. S. AND- I JUST KNOW IF
THIS WAS FUNDED. THE THAT
COMPETENCY BASED BASED
EDUCATION IF IT WAS FUNDED I
HAVE NO DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES WILL
STEP UP TO THE CHALLENGE AND
BRING THOSE STUDENTS AND
PROVIDE THAT COMPENSATE BASE
EDUCATION SO I HOPE YOU
CONSIDER FUNDING THE ALLOCATE
THAT MONEY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU THANK YOU TIME NEXT YES
MA'AM I HEAR IT YEAH I'M ROBERT
AT PHD IN GEOPHYSICS AND I'M
GEOLOGY AN EARTH SCIENCE
FACULTY AT ANTELOPE VALLEY
COLLEGE IN LANCASTER
CALIFORNIA- I DON'T WANNA BE
DUPLICATIVE. OF ANYTHING EITHER
SINCE LOOKS LIKE I'M LAST ON
THE LIST HERE WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT DUPLICATION ALL
DAYS YEAH EXACTLY SO JUST
ASSUMING THAT THE MONEY IS
FINITE IT'S CONCERNING BECAUSE
IT SEEMS OF THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR COME
RIGHT- THERE'S AN AWFUL LOT OF
MONEY THAT'S AVAILABLE FOR
APPARENTLY WHEN THE BRICK AND
MORTAR SCHOOLS ARE STRUGGLING.
AND WE ARE CONSTANTLY BEING
TOLD THAT THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
MONEY AVAILABLE FOR THINGS LIKE
BASIC SUPPLIES OR PROP- JUST
FOR RUNNING AB CLASSES. YEAH
IT'S AS IF THERE SHOULD BE SOME
SEARCHING ABOUT THIS IS THE
BEST USE. OF THAT KIND OF MONEY
BECAUSE- FROM WHAT I KNOW THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY UNDER
DISCUSSION HERE IS
APPROXIMATELY EQUAL TO. THE
YEARLY BUDGET OF AT LEAST MANY
OF THE MID SIZE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND SO IT'S
CONCERNING THAT THERE'S THIS
AMOUNT OF MONEY AVAILABLE WHEN
ON THE FLIP SIDE OF THE BRICK
AND MORTAR SCHOOLS STUDENTS ARE
STRUGGLING TO GET RESOURCES-
CLASSROOM PROGRAMS ARE
STRUGGLING TO GET RESOURCES.
AND ONE LAST COMMENT ABOUT THIS
IDEA OF ONLINE ACCESS. I A
REGULARLY COME ACROSS MANY MANY
MANY STUDENTS THAT DO NOT
ACTUALLY HAVE A LAPTOP. SO I'M
A BIT CONFUSED AS TO HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO BE VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN ONLINE PROGRAMS.
WHEN THEY DO NOT ACTUALLY HAVE
LAPTOPS OR TABLETS AND THIS
DOES SEEM CONCERNING TWO OTHER.
FOLKS THAT ARNOLD VALLEY
COLLEGE TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY
DO HAVE A LAPTOP TO LEARN
PROGRAM WHERE WHEN OUR
COMPUTERS. GET CYCLED OUT OF IT
FACULTY WORK SPACES ARE
COMPUTER LABS THE LAPTOPS AND
DESKTOPS BASICALLY GET DONATED
TO NEEDY STUDENTS. AS I THINK
THERE'S A YOU MENTIONED CART
BEFORE THE HORSE EARLIER AND I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
VERY VERY CONCERNING ABOUT
CALLED RIGHT SOMEONE REGISTER
MY OPPOSITION TO IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME ANY
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT. SEEING
NONE I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION AT THIS
OF. WHAT FOR OUR HEARING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE ARE NOW
ADJOURNED.